WE DO. THAT'S RIGHT. GOOD
MORNING, EVERYBODY. WELCOME TO
THE THIS MORNING'S SUNSET REVIEW
OVERSIGHT HEARING, WHICH IS
BEING HELD JOINTLY BY THE
ASSEMBLY, BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE AND THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. TODAY WE'LL BE
HEARING FROM FIVE ENTITIES
RESPONSIBLE FOR OVERSEEING THE
REGULATION OF OCCUPATIONS WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS, THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ATHLETIC COMMISSION, THE COURT
REPORTERS BOARD OF CALIFORNIA,
THE DENTAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA,
THE BOARD FOR PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS, LAND SURVEYORS AND
GEOLOGISTS AND THE BOARD OF
VOCATIONAL. AND PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS. FOR EACH PORTION OF
TODAY'S HEARING. WE WILL BEGIN
BY HEARING FROM REPRESENTATIVES
OF THE ENTITY UNDER UNDER REVIEW
. NEXT WE WILL OPEN THE
DISCUSSION UP FOR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. FINALLY WE
WILL INVITE OTHER INTERESTED
STAKEHOLDERS HERE IN THE ROOM TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. WE ASK
THAT SPEAKERS LIMIT THEIR
REMARKS TO TWO MINUTES PER
ORGANIZATION. I AM LOOKING
FORWARD TO TODAY'S HEARING WHERE
I ANTICIPATE WE WILL HAVE A
PRODUCTIVE DIALOGUE WITH THE
REGULATORY ENTITIES ABOUT HOW
THEY ARE WORKING TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC AND HOW WE IN THE
LEGISLATURE CAN FURTHER EMPOWER
THEM IN THE WORK. THEY DO. UH
AND I TAKE THE CHALLENGE.
SERIOUSLY THE BAR THAT CHAIR
ASHBY SET YESTERDAY. UH, OF HOW
TO MOVE A SUNSET REVIEW HEARING
ALONG EFFICIENTLY. UM AND SO
THAT WILL BE THAT WILL BE MY
RESPONSIBILITY TODAY, BUT BEFORE
WE BEGIN, I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
MY SENATE COUNTERPART, UH, CHAIR
ASHBY FOR ANY INTRODUCTION. THE
REMARKS. IF I CAN. THERE YOU GO.
YEAH. THANK YOU. UH, THANK YOU.
I JUST WANNA THANK EVERYBODY FOR
BEING HERE TODAY. IT'S AN EARLY
MORNING, RIGHT AFTER CHANGING
TIMES, AND, UH YOU KNOW, WE ALL
KNOW HOW THAT GOES. WE'RE ALL
TIRED, BUT I APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE AND I APPRECIATE THE
CHAIR. WE HAVE A LOT OF
IMPORTANT TOPICS. WONDERFUL
STAFF. I'M I'M NEW TO BP. BUT
THE ONE THING I HAVE LEARNED IN
MY FIRST COUPLE OF WEEKS HERE IS
THAT I HAVEN'T EXCELLENT
CO-CHAIR OVER HERE FROM THE
ASSEMBLY AND THAT WE BOTH HAVE
EXTRAORDINARY STAFF, AND THESE
TOPICS ARE HARD AND TOUGH TO
GRAPPLE WITH, AND SO THANK YOU
FOR ENGAGING IN THE PROCESS AND
THANK YOU TO OUR STAFF FOR YOUR
YEARS AND YEARS OF HARD WORK.
THANK YOU. CHAIR ASHBY. TODAY'S
HEARING WILL BEGIN WITH
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ATHLETIC
COMMISSION. I WOULD LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
UH MIKE GIBSON IS JOINING US FOR
THE DISCUSSION OF èC S¼, A ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON ARTS, ENTERTAINMENT, SPORTS
AND TOURISM CHAIR. GIBSON WOULD
YOU LIKE TO MAKE ANY OPENING
REMARKS BEFORE WE HEAR FROM THE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM èC S¼, A
SURE, SURE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
UH MR CHAIRMAN AND TO OUR SENATE
COUNTERPARTS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR ONE, ALLOWING ME TO BE
PART OF THIS AS A CHAIR OF ARTS
AND ENTERTAINMENT AND SPORTS AND
TOURISM. UM THE STATE ATHLETIC
COMMISSION. UM THE WORK THAT
THEY DO IS VERY, VERY IMPORTANT
TO ALL OF US, AND ESPECIALLY TO
MY COMMITTEE TO ENGAGE IN
PROFESSIONAL, UM AND AMATEUR
BOXING. UM UM KICKBOXING AND
ALSO MÐI MIXED MARTIAL ARTS
WITHOUT THIS, UH, THIS
COMMISSION AND, UM, THE WORK
THAT IT DOES. WE CAN'T REALLY BE
AS IMPORTANT AND VIABLE AS, UH,
WE WANT IT TO BE. WE KNOW THAT
PRIOR TO ME BEING APPOINTED BY,
UH UH, THE SPEAKER. UH THERE WAS
SOME OUTSTANDING OR AN
OUTSTANDING, UM, BILLS AND
DIRECTION THAT WAS GIVEN BY THE
ARTS AND ENTERTAINMENT REALLY
WOULD LIKE TO SEE. YOU KNOW
WHAT, UM, HAS COME OUT OF THAT.
SO AS YOU COME AND TALK ABOUT,
UH, THE, UH, ATHLETIC COMMISSION
. IF YOU CAN PLEASE ELABORATE ON
THE WORK THAT WAS DONE LAST
YEAR. BEFORE THE CHANGE TOOK
PLACE, BECAUSE AGAIN, UH YOU'RE
PART OF OUR ECONOMY. YOU'RE PART
OF WHAT MAKES CALIFORNIA GREAT.
UH PEOPLE COME FROM ALL AROUND
THE WORLD TO SEE, UM AND
EXPERIENCE. UM, OUR SPORTS ARE
ENTERTAINMENT. UM, THINGS OF
THAT NATURE AND THIS COMMISSION
IS VERY, VERY VITALLY IMPORTANT.
SO I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE AND LOOK
FORWARD TO THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION AS WE MOVE FORWARD,
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU. CHAIR
GIBSON. UH, WITH THAT WE'LL
BEGIN OUR WITH OUR FIRST PANEL.
UH AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE PETER
UH VILLEGAS, SCOTT WETCH AND
ANDY FOSTER HERE REPRESENTING
THE COMMISSION. READY WHEN YOU A
RE. GOOD MORNING CHAIR. BERMAN,
UH, CHAIR ASHBY AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR HAVING
US. MY NAME IS PETER VIEGAS AND
I SERVE AS CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ATHLETIC
COMMISSION. THIS COMMISSION
REGULATES ALL PROFESSIONAL
COMBAT SPORTS IN CALIFORNIA AND
HAS OVERSIGHT. OVERALL AMATEUR
COMBAT SPORTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH ME
TODAY, OUR COMMISSIONER SCOTT
WETCH, THE APPOINTEE OF THE
SENATE, AND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR, ANDY FOSTER. OF THE
COMMISSION. I'D LIKE MR WETCH
JUST TO MAKE SOME REMARKS. SHE
KNEW HOW TO DO THAT BY NOW. MR
CHAIRMAN AND MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU AND COMMISSIONER AND, UH,
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THANK YOU. UM
I AM HERE TODAY, PROUDLY
REPRESENTING AS AN APPOINTEE OF
THE OF THE SENATE TO, UH èC S¼
A AND, UH YOU KNOW, THIS IS MY
37TH YEAR WORKING IN AND AROUND
STATE GOVERNMENT, AND I'VE
SERVED ON A NUMBER OF, UH OF
BOARDS AND I HAVE TO SAY DURING
MY SHORT TENURE, MR CHAIRMAN, UH
, I'VE BEEN EXTREMELY IMPRESSED
WITH THE DEDICATION AND THE
PROFESSIONALISM OF BOTH THE
EXECUTIVE STAFF AND THE FIELD
STAFF. I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ATTEND BOTH SMALL REGIONAL
EVENTS AS WELL AS LARGE, UH,
EVENTS BEING TELECAST
INTERNATIONALLY AND THE
ATTENTION TO DETAIL AND
PROTECTING THE WELFARE AND
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
FIGHTERS IS, UH, HAS BEEN
IMPRESSIVE TO SAY THE LEAST. AND
I'LL BE DEFERRING TO THE CHAIR.
BUT I'LL BE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT I MAY BE
ASSISTANCE WITH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I'D BE REMISS IF TO
NOT ALSO HIGHLIGHT THAT,
ALTHOUGH ANDY FOSTER IS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF èC S¼, A.
HE IS GLOBALLY RECOGNIZED AS THE
BEST COMMISSIONED LEADER IN THE
COUNTRY REPRESENTING THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. UM SINCE THE
COMMISSION LAST APPEARED BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE, THE WORLD HAD
EXPERIENCED A GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
THE COMMISSION WAS GREATLY
IMPACTED BY THE HALT OF SPORTING
EVENTS IN CALIFORNIA, BUT WITH
THE ASSISTANCE OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS QUICKLY
WROTE EMERGENCY REGULATIONS TO
BEGIN REGULATING EVENTS USING A
COVID BUBBLE. WITH THE PAN
PANDEMIC BEHIND US. WE HAVE
RETURNED TO THE HIGH VOLUME OF
EVENTS IN CALIFORNIA THAT WE ARE
KNOWN FOR. ONCE AGAIN BECOMING
THE BUSIEST ATHLETIC COMMISSION
IN THE COUNTRY AND IN NORTH
AMERICA. I HAVE REVIEWED THE
SUNSET BACKGROUND PAPER PREPARED
BY LEGISLATIVE STAFF AND WANT TO
COMMEND THE HARD WORK OF CHIEF
CONSULTANT SARAH MASON. IN THE
SENATE AND CONSULTANT VINCENT
CHEE IN THE ASSEMBLY. THE
BACKGROUND PAPER IS VERY WELL
WRITTEN, ACCURATE AND HIGHLIGHTS
A NUMBER OF CURRENT ISSUES
FACING THE COMMISSION. INCLUDING
THE NEED FOR CLARIFICATION THAT
IN THE EVENT, A COMMISSION
ASSIGNED RINGSIDE POSITION
DETERMINES A FIGHTER OR
PARTICIPANT NEEDS TO BE
TRANSPORTED TO A TRAUMA
HOSPITAL. THAT THE ASSIGNED
AMBULANCE TAKE THEM IMMEDIATELY.
SOMETIMES THE AMBULANCES ARE
CONTRACTED WITH THE COUNTY. WE
NEED TO HAVE OVERSIGHT, UH, TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
FIGHTER IS TAKEN CARE OF. I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS ON THE ITEMS IN THE
BACKGROUND PAPER OR ANYTHING
ELSE YOU'D LIKE TO DISCUSS
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR FOSTER. I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU WANNA MAKE ANY COMMENTS OR
HERE FOR TECHNICAL EXPERTISE.
YES, SIR. I'M JUST HERE. PERFECT
THANK YOU, SIR. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE IT, UH, OPENING UP TO
COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SEND HER YES, I'D LIKE
TO, UH COMMENT AND OBVIOUSLY,
UH, COMPLIMENT THE COMMISSION.
I'VE HAD THE OCCASION TO GO TO A
COUPLE OF FIGHTS. AND I WAS, UH
AT RINGSIDE AND I WAS REALLY
IMPRESSED BY THE, UH ON HANDS, I
GUESS OF YOUR PERSONNEL THAT ARE
THERE WITH THE CLOCKS AND
WATCHING THIS AND RUNNING HERE
AND RUNNING THERE AND JUST
TOTALLY INVOLVED IN THE FIGHT,
AND, UH, AND THE DOCTOR. THAT
UH, WOULD GO OVER AND SO I FELT
VERY PROUD OF THE COMMISSION,
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND, UH,
THE INVOLVEMENT OF THE
COMMISSION, THE STAFF AND SO ON.
SO I. I JUST WANTED TO POINT
THAT OUT, AND I LOOK FORWARD TO,
UH, YOUR SUCCESS EVEN FURTHER,
SO CONTINUE THE SAFETY AS YOUR
NUMBER ONE ITEM FOR ALL THE
BOXERS AND EVERYONE INVOLVED.
PLEASE ALWAYS KEEP THAT IN MIND.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ARCHULETA. SENATOR ROTH. THANK
YOU, MR CHAIR. I'M JUST CURIOUS.
WHY WOULD AN AMBULANCE PROVIDER
PUBLIC OR PRIVATE NOT CARRY
TRANSPORT OF INJURED FIGHTER TO
HEALTH CARE FACILITY. EVER. WHY
DO YOU NEED SOMETIMES THE
AMBULANCES ARE OFTENTIMES THE
AMBULANCES HAVE CONTRACTS WITH
THE COUNTY. AND SO WHEN AN EVENT
IS IN A RESPECTIVE COUNTY THEY
LOOK TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
COUNTY APPROVES OF THAT OF THAT
TRANSPORTATION, THE PROMOTER IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR HIRING THE
AMBULANCE COMPANY. NOT THE
COMMISSION, THE PROMOTER AND
SOMETIMES THE AMBULANCE COMPANY
THAT THEY HIRE ARE NOT
CONTRACTED WITH THAT RESPECTIVE
COUNTY THAT THE FIGHT IS IN SO
ARE THESE AMBULANCE PROVIDERS?
NOT WHEN THEY'RE AT YOUR
FACILITY? THEY'RE NOT PART OF
THE EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
SERVICE. THAT THE COUNTY OR A
LOCAL JURISDICTION IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR OPERATING I'M
I'M CONFUSED. I MEAN, IF YOU
PICKED UP IF YOU DIAL 911, WOULD
SOMEBODY RESPOND TO YOUR
FIGHTER? IS THAT THE DIFFERENCE,
SIR, THAT'S THAT'S SORT OF THE
THAT'S THAT'S IN A NUTSHELL. THE
ISSUE IS WHAT WHAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING ON SEVERAL OCCASIONS
IS THE SPRINGSIDE PIC SAID. THIS
FO IS HURT. HE NEEDS TO GO TO
THE HOSPITAL NOW. AND THE
AMBULANCE COMPANY WILL CALL
DISPATCH AND WAIT FOR APPROVAL
FROM THE FIRE DEPARTMENT OR FROM
LOCAL EM S¼. AND WE RAN INTO
THAT SITUATION LAST YEAR, UH,
WITH WITH CATASTROPHIC
CONSEQUENCES. I MEAN, IS IT A IS
IT WHO'S GONNA PAY? IS THAT WHAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH WITH HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS AND AMBULANCE
SERVICES? I THINK THAT'S A PIECE
OF IT, BUT IT'S ALREADY BEEN
PAID. I THINK IT'S MAINLY JUST
JURISDICTIONAL. WHO'S GOING TO
MAKE THE CALL, AND, UH STATE
STATE ATHLETIC COMMISSION,
SAYING GO IN THE AMBULANCE
PROVIDER IS SAYING, WELL, WE
NEED TO GET APPROVAL. WE NEED TO
GET DISPATCHED TO ALLOW US I'M A
BIG SUPPORTER OF THE OF OUR
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS AND OUR
AMBULANCE SERVICE OF FOLKS AND
PROUD OF WHAT THEY DO IN THE
STATE. BUT I I'M JUST ONE OF 100
AND 20 AROUND HERE, BUT I'LL
TELL YOU THIS. SOMEBODY OUGHT TO
FIX THIS. WELL THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
HOPING THAT WE CAN ANYBODY WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO DO IT THROUGH
A SUNSET REVIEW PROCESS IN THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE SANDBOX, RIGHT, WELL,
WE WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS FURTHER MAKE SURE THIS
IS DONE RIGHT IF AN EVENT IS
HAPPENED HAPPENS IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. RIVERSIDE COUNTY HAS A
CONTRACT WITH THE AMBULANCE
COMPANY IF THE PROMOTER HIRES AN
OUTSIDE AMBULANCE COMPANY THAT'S
NOT CONTRACTED WITH RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. THEY'RE HESITANT TO
TRANSPORT THAT FIGHTER. AND WE
WANT TO HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO DO
THAT. WHY WOULD YOU HIRE A
COMPANY THAT'S OUTSIDE THE
COUNTY? THE JURY DO NOT DO THE
HIRING THE PROMOTER. HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY TO HAVE TWO
AMBULANCES ON SITE FOR EVERY
EVENT, SO THEY'RE PAYING THE
PROMOTER IS PAYING FOR THE OR
THE AMBULANCE SERVICES. WELL A
RE YOU ABLE? I DON'T WANNA
BELABOUR THIS BUT JUST ONE MORE
QUESTION. SO AT AN EVENT IF A IF
A FIGHTER MY SERIOUSLY INJURED
CAN YOU PICK UP AND DIAL 911 AND
GET AN AMBULANCE THERE? WE COULD
, SIR, I MEAN, AND THAT'S THAT'S
BEEN THE SUGGESTED SOLUTION. BUT
THAT SORT OF DEFEATS THE PURPOSE
OF HAVING AMBULANCES ON SITE
BECAUSE THE IDEA IS TO USE THE
AMBULANCE THAT WE ALREADY HAVE
THERE IN THE MEDICAL STAFF. WE
ALREADY HAVE THERE TO TAKE THEM
TO THE HOSPITAL. THAT'S BEEN THE
SOLUTION IS AND IN FACT, THAT IS
WHAT HAPPENED, UH, LAST YEAR AS
THEY CALL 911 AND SWITCH FROM
THE AMBULANCE TO WELL, I, I JUST
MAKE A SUGGESTION. I'M NOT AN
EXPERT ON THIS. UM, EVEN THOUGH
I'VE BEEN ON THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE A WHILE, BUT I'M
CERTAINLY NOT AN EXPERT, BUT I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT SOMEBODY SIT
DOWN WITH THE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT FOLKS AND FIGURE OUT
IF YOUR SOLUTION IS THE BEST
SOLUTION UNDER THIS, UH,
CIRCUMSTANCE BECAUSE IT SORT OF
CONFLICTS WITH I THINK THE WAY
THE COUNTIES AND THE STATE
ORGANIZED THE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT RESPONSE SYSTEM. YOUR
SYSTEM IS SORT OF AN OUTLIER,
AND THAT MAY BE THE SOURCE OF
THE PROBLEM. THANK YOU, MR
CHAIR. THANK YOU, SENATOR. AND
THE GOOD NEWS IS EVERYONE
RECOGNIZES THIS IS A HUGE
PROBLEM. UH, THERE NEEDS TO BE
FIXED AND AS WE KNOW, IN IN OUR
JOB, THAT'S 90% OF THE BATTLE.
UH SO CONFIDENT WILL WE'LL FIND
THE RIGHT SOLUTION? UH, CHAIR
GIBSON. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. UM
I JUST HAVE ONE QUESTION I WOULD
LIKE TO HEAR ABOUT THE CHANGES
IN THE NEW, UH, PROCESSES THAT
HAS BEEN PUT IN PLACE OR IN
MOTION FROM THE LAST SUNSET
REVIEW. UH, FOR ONE EXAMPLE IS
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEW
RETIREMENT BENEFITS FOR MIXED
MARTIAL ARTS. UH, CAN YOU
ELABORATE ON THAT FOR ME,
PLEASE? HELLO. UH UH, MR
CHAIRMAN. UH, UH, THE SINCE THAT
WAS, UH, THE BILL LAST YEAR.
THAT WAS, UH, MR HANEY'S BILL.
AND WE, UH WE'VE ACTUALLY BEGAN
COLLECTING MONEY. WE'VE UH,
TRANSFERRED THE FUNDS. WE'RE
ABOUT TO GET A DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE CODE. IT'S GOING INTO
THE INTO THE, UH INTO THE
ACCOUNT. AND WE ARE, UH,
COLLECTING MONEY FOR THE M MA
FIGHTERS AT THIS TIME. SO SOME
PROCESS AND THE AND THE BENEFIT
IS THAT YOU'RE COLLECTING MONEY.
WHAT'S THE PROCESS TO COLLECT
THE MONEY? IT'S A DOLLAR A
TICKET, SIR. BASED ON THAT IS
ATTACHED TO THE TICKET SALE. UH,
YES, SIR. SO WHEN THE WHEN THE
PROMOTER TURNS IN THEIR GATE RE
REPORT IF THEY SOLD LIKE, UH, WE
JUST SOLD, UH, UF èC DID LIKE
16,000 TICKETS. THEY ADDED
16,000 THAT WAS ALLOCATED TO
THAT TO THAT FUND. OK, THAT'S
DONE AT EVERY UH, EVERY GAME
EVERY MIXED MARTIAL ARTS EVENTS
OR AND FOR BOXING. IT'S 88 CENTS
A TICKET. UM AS YOU PROBABLY SAW
ONE OF THE REQUESTS WE REQUESTED
WAS TO CHANGE THAT TO A DOLLAR
AS WELL SO THAT THE BOXING AND
THE MIXED MARTIAL ARTS ARE THE
SAME. BUT YES, AT EVERY EVENT,
SIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'D
LIKE TO ALSO HIGHLIGHT THE
CALIFORNIA LEADS THE COUNTRY IN
THIS AGAIN. WE ARE THE ONLY
COMMISSION THAT HAS A RETIREMENT
FUND FOR M MA FIGHTERS AND A
PENSION FUND FOR BOXERS IN THE
COUNTRY, BUT THE ONLY ONES WHERE
THE PARTICIPANTS IN CALIFORNIA
BENEFIT FROM THAT AND I THINK
THERE ARE I THINK CERTAINLY
THOSE WHO ARE PLAYING APPRECIATE
THAT BECAUSE RETIREMENT IS
ABSOLUTELY IMPORTANT, ESPECIALLY
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I'M NOT
SURE THAT, UH NONE OF US ON THIS
PANEL RECEIVE AFTER 12 YEARS OF
BEING IN OFFICE. IT'S UH MOST
UNFORTUNATE, BUT THAT'S ANOTHER
DAY FOR ANOTHER STORY. UH, BUT
I'M CER. ANOTHER COMMITTEE.
CERTAINLY WE WANNA BE ON THAT
COMMITTEE, RIGHT? UM CERTAINLY,
UM, THOSE WHO PUT THEIR BLOOD
PUT THEIR UH UH BLOOD AND INTO A
CAREER, UH, SUCH AS MARTIAL
ARTS. UM, AT THE END OF THE
THEIR TIME SHOULD BE ABLE TO
RETIRE AND HAVE SOMETHING SET
ASIDE FOR THEM. UM AND SO I
APPRECIATE YOU EVEN MOVING TO 88
CENTS TO A DOLLAR, MAKING IT
CONSISTENT. UM UM FOR THE
INDUSTRY, SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR RESPONSE. THANK YOU.
AND JUST FOR NOTE IN 2023 WE
WERE ABLE TO COMMISSION WAS ABLE
TO LOCATE AND PAY 39 RETIRED
BOXERS TOTALING OVER $581,000
FOR THE PARTICIPATION IN
CALIFORNIA. RIGHT? THAT'S GREAT.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS BEFORE
I GO TO MY CO CHAIR. ASBY. THANK
YOU. OK I JUST HAVE ONE QUESTION
AND ONE COMMENT. LET'S START
WITH THE COMMENT FIRST ON THE
AMBULANCE ISSUE COMING FROM THE
LOCAL AND I'M SURE I'M NOT THE
ONLY ONE UP HERE. I UNDERSTAND
THE SCOPE ISSUE THERE WITH, UM
COUNTIES HAVING VARIOUS
CONTRACTS IN PLACE FOR WHO CAN
PROVIDE AMBULATORY SERVICE, SO
WE'LL TAKE A LOOK AT THAT ON THE
SENATE B MP SIDE AND TRY TO
FIGURE OUT IF THERE'S A WAY WE
CAN ADDRESS THAT ISSUE, MOVING
FORWARD AND AT LEAST FOR YOUR
INDUSTRY, ALTHOUGH IT DOES
APPEAR TO BE A LARGER ISSUE AS
WELL. AND THEN MY QUESTION FOR
YOU. AND UH, NOT SURE. WHICH ONE
OF YOU THIS IS BEST FOR ME, MR
FOSTER. BUT SO TASKING YOU WITH
THIS THE ONGOING ADMINISTRATION
OF THE EXISTING PENSION FUND
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE
AND NOW ALSO THE MIXED MARTIAL
ARTS RETIREMENT BENEFIT FUND. IT
SEEMS LIKE A PRETTY LARGE TASK.
AND I AM, YOU KNOW, WONDERING,
GIVEN THE DAY TO DAY WORK THAT
YOU ARE ALREADY REQUIRED TO DO
ALL ACROSS THE STATE. TO ENSURE
THAT THAT THINGS ARE FAIR AND
THAT THAT THE FIGHTS ARE AS SAFE
AS POSSIBLE. IS THIS THE BEST
WAY TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO BENEFIT FROM
THOSE FUNDS? MADAM CHAIR. THAT'S
UH, THAT'S ALMOST LIKE A. THAT'S
A POLICY QUESTION IF IT'S THE
BEST WAY. IT'S PROVIDING FUNDS.
IT'S SOME SOMETHING IT'S BETTER
THAN NOTHING AND REGARDING OUR
WORKLOAD, WHICH I THINK IS WHAT
YOU WERE GETTING AT. UM IT'S
SIGNIFICANT BUT AT THIS STAGE OF
THE GAME OF THE NEWLY CREATED
FUND, WE'RE LITERALLY JUST
COLLECTING MONEY. OK THIS
CONVERSATION WILL CERTAINLY
HAPPEN AS THE FUN MATURES AND
FIGHTERS START GETTING TOWARDS
VESTING. BUT THAT'S SEVERAL
YEARS IN THE FUTURE, IF NOT 678
YEARS IN THE FUTURE. RIGHT NOW,
WE'RE JUST COLLECTING MONEY,
WHICH IS MINIMAL WORKLOAD
INCREASE. AND I WOULD ADD AS
BEING THE ONLY COMMISSION THAT
DOES THIS. THERE'S NÓ ONE WE CAN
REALLY REFER TO IN OUR INDUSTRY,
SO WE'RE REALLY CREATING
DEVELOPING, UM, THE CORRECT
PROCESS, BUT WELCOME ALL
THOUGHTS AND IDEAS. I THINK
THAT'S SORT OF THE POINT WHEN I
SET YOU UP FOR SUCCESS IN THE
LONG TERM. ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
PLEASE, SENATOR. UH, OBVIOUSLY,
YOU KNOW, WE ALL APPLAUD THE
FACT THAT THERE IS A AAA PENSION
OR RETIREMENT. IS THAT A NUMBER
OF YEARS OR A NUMBER OF FIGHTS?
HOW IS THAT IMPLEMENTED? YES
SENATOR ARCHULETA. THE UH THE
BOXERS, UH, REQUIRE 75 ROUNDS,
UH, TO VEST BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
THEY FOUGHT IN 468 S¼ TENS AND
TWELVES. THE MIXED MARTIAL ARTS
FIGHTERS HAVE 39 ROUNDS BECAUSE
MOST OF THEM ARE THREE, BUT SOME
OF THEM ARE FIVE ROUNDS. YOU
SEE? THEY'RE A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT, BUT, UM, IF YOU
FOUGHT THE 75 ROUNDS IN
CALIFORNIA, YOU WILL VEST. UM
WITHOUT LIKE A BREAK. THERE ARE
A FEW LITTLE RULES, BUT
ESSENTIALLY, IT'S 75 ROUNDS AND
A MIXED MARTIAL ARTS. IT'S 39
ROUNDS AND YOU WILL VEST AND
AFTER THAT TIME PERIOD DO THEY
REACH A CERTAIN AGE AND THEN
THEY'LL START RECEIVING IT AT 62
OR WHATEVER. WHAT 50 YEARS OLD,
SIR, THEY CAN MAKE THE CLAIM AND
IT'S A ONE TIME A CLAIM. IT'S A
ONE TIME BENEFIT. AND IS IT A
LUMP SUM PAYMENT? OR IS IT
PAYMENT OVER YEARS? IT'S A LUMP
SUM PAYMENT, SIR. OK, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR ARCHULETTA.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS? WELL,
THANKS. UH, THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU FOR THE
ANSWERS. I THINK FOLLOWING UP ON
YOUR ASHBY'S, UH, POINT. IF AS
YOU'RE IMPLEMENTING, UM, YOU
KNOW THESE THESE NEW PROGRAMS IF
YOU IDENTIFY AREAS WHERE MAYBE,
UH, YOU KNOW, THE CODE IS
IMPEDING YOUR ABILITY TO
IMPLEMENT THEM TO THE TO THE
BEST OF YOUR ABILITY. LET US
KNOW. DON'T HESITATE TO REACH
BACK OUT TO THE COMMITTEES TO
LET US KNOW IF TWEAKS NEED TO BE
MADE ALL THE TIME. TWEAKS NEED
TO BE MADE TO, ESPECIALLY IN NEW
PROGRAMS THAT WE THAT WE PROP
UP. I HAVE A QUICK QUESTION ON
KIND OF FLUIDITY AND REVENUES
AND EXPENDITURES. UH, ISSUE FIVE
OF THE BACKGROUND PAPER. UM HAS
THE COMMISSION BUT YOU KNOW,
BECAUSE OF COVID. THINGS HAVE
CHANGED AND YOU KNOW, THERE
AREN'T AS MANY IN PERSON EVENTS
AND NOT AS MANY PEOPLE ARE
ATTENDING THEM, UH, IN IN PERSON
, HAS THE COMMITTEE CONSIDERED
REVENUE SOURCES OTHER THAN THE
GATE AND BROADCAST FEES TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU HAVE THE RESOURCES
THAT YOU NEED, UH, TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT, UH, YOU KNOW, BOXERS
AND FIGHTERS, UH, ARE ARE SAFE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. UH, THE
COMMISSION. UM THE COMMISSION
CONTINUOUSLY REQUESTS
APPROPRIATE. APPROPRIATIONS AS
THE LEGISLATORS NOTED MULTIPLE
TIMES. THE STABLE EXPENDITURES
OF THE OFFICE STAFF RENT AND ARE
ONLY ABOUT HALF OF THE TOTAL
EXPENDITURES. UH, IF WE IF THE
COMMISSION HAS A HIGH VOLUME
YEAR EXPENDITURES AS WELL AS
REVENUE WILL BE HIGHER
BUDGETING. THERE IS A CHALLENGE,
BUT WE'RE ALWAYS LOOKING FOR
IDEAS AND STRATEGIES. I THINK
ONE THAT WE THOUGHT OF WAS THE
LICENSE PLATE. UM ESTABLISHING A
LICENSE PLATE SO PEOPLE CAN PAY
FOR A LICENSE PLATE RECOGNIZING,
UH, OUR INDUSTRY AND THAT'S A 11
ITEM. 11 IDEA, BUT WE HAVE
MULTIPLE OTHERS OTHER ARE THERE
OTHERS, ANDY THAT WE'VE YES,
SIR. ANOTHER IDEA THAT WE'VE
HAD, UM SOUND A LITTLE CRAZY,
BUT, UH, THE  N B A S¼ DID IT.
THE  N FL DID IT. MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL DID IT? WE KICKING.
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE IDEA OF
PERHAPS PUTTING A LOGO OR SOME
KIND OF SPONSORSHIP ON A
REFEREES UNIFORM. IT'S DOABLE.
IT'S POSSIBLE, BUT WE'RE THAT
THAT'S THAT'S NEW, SO THAT'S ONE
IDEA AND THAT WOULD GENERATE
SIGNIFICANT REVENUE. UM, AS LONG
AS THE FIGHTERS CAN'T SPONSOR
THOSE THOSE LOGOS. OF COURSE.
YEAH, NÓ. I'M KIDDING. KIDDING.
UM NÓ UNBIASED REFEREES. YEAH.
BUT THE BACKGROUND PAPER DID
BRING UP THE VERY IMPORTANT TO
YOUR POINT ABOUT THE REVENUES OF
THE COMMISSION. REVENUES
FLUCTUATE JUST WILDLY, AND WE
GET THE COM THIS COMMISSION GETS
88% OF ITS REVENUE FROM EVENTS.
SO IF THE COMMISSION HAS EVENTS,
WE GET MONEY AND THEN WE NEED
THE MONEY TO EXPAND. SO WE LIKE
DURING THE COVID YEAR, WE ONLY
HAD EXPENDITURES ABOUT HALF OF
OUR APPROPRIATION BECAUSE THE
FIXED COSTS WERE ABOUT HALF THAT
MAKES SENSE SO LIKE AND SO, UM,
YEAH, IT'S CONTINUAL. BEEN A
CHALLENGE. MR FOSS OR MR W?
YEAH, MR. CHAIRMAN IN, UM IN
REGARD TO, UH NOT THE, UH,
FUNDING OF THE COMMISSION ITSELF
, BUT OF THE BENEFIT, UH, PLANS
FOR THE FIGHTERS. WE HAVE ALSO
CONSIDERED LOOKING AT THE MODEL
OF THE 5050 RAFFLE, WHICH IS,
UH, AUTHORIZED IN YOU KNOW OTHER
MAJOR SPORTING EVENTS. UM THEY
ONLY DIFFERENCE HERE IS THAT
INSTEAD OF HAVING IT JUST BE A
RANDOM CHARITY. IT WOULD BE A
DEDICATED TO THE HEALTH AND
WELFARE OF, UH OF THE FIGHTERS.
VERY INTERESTING IDEA. YEAH. UM
GREAT. I THINK THOSE ARE ALL MY
QUESTIONS ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM COLLEAGUES NEXT?
LET'S YEAH, THAT'S WHERE I WAS
GOING. THANKS. APPRECIATE YOU.
UM SO LET'S GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC, UH, WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ATHLETIC COMMISSION? ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO WANNA COME AND
MAKE COMMENTS. OR OR OR. SOME
TRAINING ANYTHING, NÓ. NONE. OK,
UM. THEN I THINK THAT'S ALL WE
HAVE. OH, I SHOULD SAY, UH UH, I
. I REMEMBER HAY HAS TALKED TO
ME ABOUT, UH, BOTH. HOW F MUCH
FUN HE HAD AND HOW INFORMATIVE
IT WAS, UH, GOING TO EVENTS. UM
SO THAT MIGHT BE SOMETHING THAT
I'LL FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ALL ON
TO GET AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO AND
HELP GET A BETTER UNDERSTANDING
OF THE COMPLICATE. YOU KNOW HOW
HOW FAST THINGS ARE MOVING IN
THE COMPLICATED NATURE OF THE
WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING, AND
YOU'RE YOUR TEAMS ARE DOING TO
MAKE SURE EVERYONE STAYS SAFE.
SO I APPRECIATE EVERYTHING THAT
Y'ALL DO. THANK YOU FOR COMING
TODAY. THANK YOU, MR CHAIR, MR
CHAIR. COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OK
NEXT ON THE AGENDA. WE'LL BE
HEARING FROM THE COURT REPORTERS
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA I BELIEVE
YOU HAVE THE BOARD'S EXECUTIVE
OF, UH, OFFICER YVONNE FENNER IN
THE ROOM WITH US TODAY, AND
BOARD CHAIR DENISE TOGA TOGA. WE
WILL BE JOINING VIA WEBEX.
HOPEFULLY, MAYBE. UM WELL, MR
CHAIR, I'M HERE. THANK YOU.
PERFECT. LOVE IT WHEN THINGS
WORK. PLEASE BEGIN WITH YOUR
OPENING REMARKS WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU. CHAIR MEMBERS.
THE COURT REPORTERS BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA LICENSES CERTIFIED
SHORTHAND REPORTERS èC S¼ R S¼
MORE COMMONLY KNOWN AS COURT
REPORTERS AND OVERSEES
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS, A COURT
REPORTING THERE ARE CURRENTLY
APPROXIMATELY 5584 ACTIVE. I èC
èC S¼, AND WE HAVE 213
REGISTERED COURT REPORTING
FIRMS. THE WORLD OF REPORTING
HAS UNDERGONE DRAMATIC CHANGES
SINCE WE WERE LAST BEFORE YOU IN
2019 DURING THE PANDEMIC, COURT
REPORTERS QUICKLY OFFERED THE
REPORTING, ALLOWING DEPOSITIONS
AND SOME TRIALS TO PROCEED. THE
VIRTUAL PLATFORM FOR DEPOSITIONS
WITH ITS COST SAVINGS TO
LITIGANTS IS HERE TO STAY.
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF IMPROVEMENTS
IN REMOTE TECHNOLOGY. THE BOARD
WAS ALSO ABLE TO PIVOT TO ONLINE
SKILLED LICENSING SOMETHING THEY
HAD BEEN PURSUING SINCE 2018 AND
THUS HAD ALMOST EVERYTHING IN
PLACE. THIS ALLOWED THE BOARD TO
CONTINUE LICENSING WITHOUT
INTERRUPTION DESPITE PANDEMIC
RESTRICTIONS. ON JANUARY 1 2022
VIA S¼ B 241 BY SENATOR UMBERG.
THE BOARD WAS AUTHORIZED AND
DIRECTED BY THE LEGISLATURE TO
REGISTER NON CSR OWNED FIRMS
THAT OFFER COURT REPORTING
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA. THE
BOARD BEGAN REGISTERING FIRMS
THAT OFFER COURT REPORTING
SERVICES IN JULY OF 2022. DEBATE
UH, AS I MENTIONED, THE BOARD
HAS REGISTERED 215 FIRMS, WHICH
INCLUDES BOTH LICENSEE OWNED AND
NON LICENSING OWNED FIRMS, NON
LICENSING OWNED FIRMS ARE
REQUIRED TO REGISTER WITH THE
BOARD. REGISTRATION FOR LICENSEE
OWNED FIRMS IS OPTIONAL. WE ARE
IN THE MIDDLE OF A TECHNOLOGY
MODERNIZATION PROJECT THAT IS
FUNDED BY THE TECHNOLOGY
MODERNIZATION FUND. THE Tð MF
THROUGH èC Dð Tð. THIS WILL
BRING èC RB FULLY OFF OF THE
LEGACY SYSTEMS COMPLETELY ONLINE
FOR CONSUMERS AND LICENSEES
WHILE AIMING FOR PAPERLESS
COMMUNICATIONS. UH, AS A RESULT
OF A B 156, WHICH WAS SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR AND CHAPTERED ON
SEPTEMBER 7TH 2022, THE BOARD
WAS ALLOWED TO LICENSE VOICE
WRITERS, AN INITIATIVE THE BOARD
HAS BEEN PURSUING SINCE 2018.
VOICE WRITING IS AN ALTERNATIVE
METHOD OF COURT REPORTING USING
VOICE TECHNOLOGY RATHER THAN A
STEREOTYPE MACHINE. BOTH METHODS
CREATE SHORTHAND NOTES OF THE
PRECEDING SUB VIA DIFFERENT
TYPES OF EQUIPMENT. THE BOARD
WAS ABLE TO ADAPT THE LICENSE
APPLICATION SET UP PROCTOR AND
INSTRUCTIONS AND BEGIN
ADMINISTERING THE LICENSE EXAM
TO QUALIFIED VOICE WRITING
CANDIDATES IN TIME FOR THE
NOVEMBER 2022 EXAM CYCLE. STAFF
HAS COMPLETED REGULATIONS TO
UPDATE CURRICULUM REQUIREMENTS
TO INCLUDE VOICE WRITING. VOICE
WRITING IS A MAJOR CHANGE TO THE
COURT REPORTING INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA. THE TRAINING PROGRAM
IS SIGNIFICANTLY SHORTER THAN
TRAINING STENO WRITERS AND
ENJOYS A HIGHER COMPLETION
PERCENTAGE. FOR REPORTING
SCHOOLS WILL BENEFIT FROM
OFFERING A VOICE WRITING
TRAINING PROGRAM AS A MORE
CLOSELY ALIGNED WITH VOCATIONAL
EDUCATION GOALS, ASKED OF THEM
BY THEIR CREDIT BODIES. A ROBUST
WORKFORCE ALLOWS THE CONSUMER TO
NOT ONLY BE ASSURED OF HAVING A
COURT REPORTER AVAILABLE TO
CREATE AN IMPARTIAL RECORD OF
THEIR PROCEEDING, BUT ALSO KEEPS
THE MARKETPLACE COMPETITIVE.
THANK YOU TO MEMBERS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. UM AND, UH, MS
FENNER. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS YVONNE
FENNER. I'M THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FOR THE COURT REPORTERS
BOARD, AND I'M HERE JUST TO
ANSWER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AND
ASSIST CHAIR TO GDE WITH
ANYTHING THAT SHE NEEDS FROM
STAFF. WONDERFUL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. UH, I'D LIKE TO TURN OVER
TO COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR THE COURT REPORTER
BOARD FROM COLLEAGUES. JUST A
GOOD MORNING. THANKS FOR BEING
HERE. UH JUST AAA COMMENT AND
MAYBE A QUESTION AT THE SAME
TIME. UH, LAST YEAR, I WAS ASKED
TO VISIT HER. ACCORDING IN
VICTORVILLE. I REPRESENT THE
VICTORVILLE AREA IN SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY. I THINK WE
ALL KNOW WHERE, UH, GOING
THROUGH A SHORTAGE OF, UH UH
THIS PROFESSION. UM, I. I ASKED.
WHAT IS IT THAT, UH IS, UH THE
BLOCK TO SEE HOW PEOPLE ARE MORE
INTERESTED IN TRYING TO SERVE AT
THAT CAPACITY. UH THEY TOLD ME
THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO PROVIDE
AS MUCH AID AS NECESSARY,
WHETHER IT, UH THROUGH GRANTS OR
EVEN SIGN UP BONUSES AND
GUARANTEE THAT THEY'LL GET A JOB
ONCE THEY GO THROUGH THE
PROGRAM. UM WHAT IS IT IN YOUR
VIEW? THAT IS, UH, CREATING SUCH
A BIG SHORTAGE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. UH, THANK YOU. SO MUCH
FOR THE QUESTION. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. UM, YOU KNOW, WORKFORCE
HAS BEEN UH, ONE OF THE GREATEST
CHALLENGES, UM, THAT WE'VE SEEN,
AND, UM, YOU KNOW, AS AS I'VE
MENTIONED, IT'S A REALLY LONG
STANDING ISSUE THAT WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT, SINCE, UM WELL
BEFORE 2018 AND YOU KNOW, WE
HAVE. WE HAVE LOOKED AT MANY
DIFFERENT UH, WAYS TO, UH, TO
ATTACK THIS ISSUE, WHETHER
THAT'S UM WHETHER THAT'S UH,
ENCOURAGING NEW FORMS OF COURT
REPORTING, UH THROUGH VOICE
WRITINGS THAT, UH, THAT THAT
INCLUDES MORE FOLKS INTO THE
PROFESSION AT A FASTER RATE. UM
REGISTERING FIRMS LIKE I
MENTIONED, UM, BUT, UH, WE'VE
ALSO SEEN INVESTMENTS FROM THE
LEGISLATURE. UH, WHICH WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL FOR, UM, TO
ENCOURAGE HIRING AT THE COURTS.
UM AND SO, UH, YOU KNOW, WE'VE
WE'VE DEFINITELY PRIORITIZED
THAT IT'S A LONG STANDING ISSUE,
AND I KNOW THERE'S A LONG
HISTORICAL PRECEDENT AS WELL
THAT I'M HAPPY TO TURN OVER TO
MISS FENNER TO SPEAK TO SO AS A
LONG TIME COURT REPORTER. I
WOULD JUST PUT IT INTO
PERSPECTIVE. A LITTLE BIT. UM
MANY YEARS AGO WHEN I FIRST
STARTED TRAINING AS A COURT
REPORTER. I HAD TO WAIT JUST TO
GET INTO THE TRAINING PROGRAM.
BY THE TIME I FINISHED THE
PROGRAM, THERE WERE SO MANY
REPORTERS THAT THERE WAS, UH, A
GLUT IF YOU WILL, SO I HAD A
REAL HARD TIME FINDING WORK. UM,
SO I'VE SEEN THE CYCLES OVER THE
YEARS GO UP AND DOWN, AND IT'S
UM, DEFINITELY BEEN COMPLICATED
BY THE UNIVERSAL LABOR PROBLEMS
THAT WE HAVE ALL EXPERIENCED
AFTER. COVID UM SO THIS ONE'S I
THINK A LITTLE BIT MORE
PERVASIVE THAN WE'VE EXPERIENCED
IN THE PAST. THE GOOD NEWS IS
THANKS TO THE LEGISLATURE'S
FORWARD THINKING WE HAVE BEEN
LICENSING VOICE WRITERS, AND
THAT PROGRAM FITS VERY WELL WITH
VOCATIONAL TRAINING, ADULT
EDUCATION AND WHAT WE'RE SEEING
IN THE SCHOOLS RIGHT NOW ARE
WAITING LISTS TO GET INTO THE
PROGRAMS. WE SEE DIFFERENT
SCHOOLS ALSO HIRING ADDITIONAL
TEACHERS TO TRY AND HELP HANDLE
THIS DEMAND FOR THE PROGRAM AND
TRAINING RIGHT NOW, AND WE'VE
SEEN THAT TRICKLE OVER, UM INTO
THE NUMBER OF STATISTICS FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE COMING TO TAKE
THE LICENSE EXAM. SO THREE YEARS
AGO, WE MAYBE HAD, UM, LESS THAN
20 PEOPLE. FIRST TIME TAKERS FOR
THE LICENSE EXAM IN NOVEMBER. WE
HAD 59 1ST TIME. WE HAVE 54 FOR
THE CURRENT CYCLE. SO YOU CAN
SEE THAT. IT'S DEFINITELY
DRIVING UP. AND WE WILL HAVE FOR
WORKFORCE. NOW IT'S GONNA TAKE
SOME TIME AND THE BOARD HAS
RECOGNIZED THAT SO WE'RE, UM,
STILL EXPLORING RECIPROCITY WITH
THE NATIONAL LICENSE? UM WE'RE
PROMOTING REMOTE REPORTING AS
MUCH AS WE CAN, BECAUSE WE FEEL
THAT THAT WOULD OPEN UP A LOT OF
POSSIBILITIES TO THERE ARE
REPORTERS THEY'RE JUST NOT
NECESSARILY NEXT TO THE
COURTROOM OR NEXT TO THE
CONFERENCE ROOM OR THE
DEPOSITION IS BEING HELD. SO WE
DO HAVE SOME CHALLENGES, BUT I
THINK WE'RE WORKING HARD ON
SOLVING THEM. THANK YOU. SO CREO
SENATOR ROTH. WERE YOU GONNA
JUST A ARE YOU ASKING ON THIS
ISSUE OR DIFFERENT ISSUE
REPORTERS? UH, WORKFORCE
PERFECT. YOU KNOW, AS UM LONG
TIME FORMER ATTORNEY. I WAS A
CUSTOMER OF THE COURT BEFORE I
CAME UP HERE AND UH, WE DEPEND
ON COURT REPORTERS IN OUR
COURTROOMS FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS, BUT CERTAINLY TO MAKE
SURE AS YOU WELL KNOW, AS A CORE
REPORTER, AND AS YOU KNOW, MADAM
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR, UH, WE
DEPEND ON COURT REPORTERS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE RECORD IS
ACCURATELY, UH TRANSCRIBED. SO
WHEN WE HAVE AN ISSUE THAT WE
WANT TO TAKE UP TO THE APPELLATE
COURT, THE APPELLATE COURT AND
THE JUSTICES WHO WEREN'T IN THE
COURTROOM WHEN WE TRY OUR CASE,
THEY'RE ABLE TO FIND OUT EXACTLY
WHAT HAPPENED AND DECIDE THE
ISSUE FOR US. UM, AS YOU KNOW,
THEY'RE MANDATED. COR COURTROOMS
ARE MANDATED TO HAVE REPORTERS,
SOME OF THEM THE CRIMINAL
COURTS, THE JUVENILE COURTS, BUT
THERE ARE COURTS THAT DEAL WITH
OUR MOST VULNERABLE. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT ARE NOT
MANDATED TO HAVE COURT REPORTS
SUCH AS THE FAMILY LAW COURT.
WHICH IS A PROBLEM BECAUSE
THEY'RE DEALING WITH OUR MOST
VULNERABLE AT TIMES THAT ARE THE
MOST VULNERABLE THEY PROBABLY
WILL EVER HAVE IN THEIR LIFE.
THEY'RE CRITICAL DECISIONS BEING
MADE AND WITHOUT A COURT RECORD,
IT'S ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE. TO
APPEAL WHAT GOES ON IN THAT
COURT, AND THERE MAY BE OTHERS.
I DON'T KNOW. I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER PROBATES MANDATED WHAT
WHAT ARE WE DOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT ONE? WE KNOW WHAT THE
WORKLOAD AND WORKFORCE SHORTAGES
IN OUR NON MANDATED COURTROOMS.
UM AND WHAT A RE WE GOING TO DO
ABOUT IT? LET'S START WITH THE
FIRST QUESTION. DO WE KNOW? EVEN
WITH THIS NEW WORKFORCE EFFORT
WITH VOICE WRITING, WHICH I'VE
LONG SUPPORTED SINCE I CAME OUT
OF THE MILITARY, AND THAT'S
BASICALLY ALL WE HAD WHEN WE
DEPLOYED PEOPLE DOING STENO MÁS
REPORTING. DO WE KNOW WHAT OUR
NON MANDATED COURTROOM WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES? ANYONE ANY TAKERS? UM
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION,
SENATOR ROTH. UM AND, UH, YOU
KNOW, I'LL TURN TO MISS FENNER
ON ON THAT IF WE DO HAVE
NUMBERS. WHAT DID YOU DO? THANK
YOU, MO. WE DEFINITELY DO NOT
HAVE THOSE NUMBERS. THOSE ARE
KEPT BY THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
THE BOARD DOES NOT TRACK WHERE
PEOPLE WORK. AND SO THE
SHORTAGES THAT WE KNOW OF UM,
THE INFORMATION COMES FROM
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. NOW WE KNOW
THAT MOST OF THE COURTS HAVE
STOPPED PROVIDING COURT
REPORTERS, OFFICIAL COURT
REPORTERS IN CIVIL MATTERS AND
THEY'VE ADDED, UH, THE FAMILY
COURTS THE FAMILY LAW COURTS AS
YOU SAID, AND THAT IS DEFINITELY
OF CONCERN TO THE BOARD BECAUSE
THOSE ARE, AS YOU SAID, THE VERY
MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE. IT'S THE
LOWEST POINT OF THEIR LIFE AND
NOT ONLY DO THEY HAVE MONEY AND
POSSESSIONS AT STAKE, BUT OFTEN
IT'S CUSTODY OF THE CHILDREN AND
SO IT THESE ARE VERY IMPORTANT
MATTERS AND THE RECORD IS
CRITICAL. SO THE BOARD HAS A
VESTED INTEREST IN MAKING SURE
THAT THOSE COURTS ARE COVERED.
HOWEVER THE ACTUAL HIRING IS
OUTSIDE OF OUR CONTROL. AND AS A
FOREMOST MEMBER OF ATTORNEY WHO
PRACTICED IN THE CI CIVIL SIDE
OF THE COURTROOM. THOSE WHO
COULD PAY GOT A COURT REPORTER
AND THOSE WHO COULDN'T PAY
DIDN'T LESS CRITICAL ON THE
CIVIL SIDE MORE CRITICAL IN THE
MANDATED COURTS, AND I THINK WE
ALSO CAN'T CONTROL WHERE THESE
COURT REPORTERS GO, THESE NEW
ONES WHO WERE IN TRAINING
BECAUSE THEY HAVE CHOICES. THEY
COULD TAKE DEPOSITIONS FOR
SOMEONE LIKE ME WHO HAS WHO HAD
CLIENTS WHO COULD PAY
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF MONEY FOR
THE COURT REPORTER TIME AND THE
PREPARATION OF THE UM WERE THOSE
COR REPORTERS COULD CHOOSE TO GO
TO A COURTROOM AND SIT WHERE THE
COMPENSATION PERHAPS WAS LESS
LUCRATIVE. UM, JUST A COMMENT.
YOU KNOW, WE'VE BEEN DEBATING
ELECTRONIC COURT ELECTRONIC
REPORTING IN THIS LEGISLATURE
FOR SOME TIME. AND THEIR
DEFICITS THERE, OF COURSE, BUT I
THINK AT SOME POINT WHETHER IT'S
ON A TEMPORARY BASIS OR
OTHERWISE, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO FACE THE FACT THAT WE'RE
UNABLE TO STAFF OUR MANDATED
COURTROOMS, PARTICULARLY IN
FAMILY LAW. AND GRAPPLE WITH
THIS ELECTRONIC REPORTING ONCE
AGAIN AGAIN, PERHAPS EVEN ON A
TEMPORARY BASIS UNTIL THE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE SUBSIDES, AND
WE CONVINCE COURT REPORTERS WHO
COMING OUT OF TRAINING TO TAKE A
SWING AT THE COURTROOM REPORTING
HOPEFULLY IN FAMILY LAW COURT.
THANK YOU, MR CHAIR. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ROTH AND JUST TO DRILL
DOWN ON THAT A LITTLE BIT MORE.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
JUDICIAL COUNCIL HAS, UH,
REQUESTED THINGS LIKE A
WORKFORCE SURVEY, FOR EXAMPLE,
UH, WHICH I THINK MIGHT ANSWER
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
SENATOR ROTH, UH OR GET SOME OF
THE ANSWERS THAT SENATOR ROTH IS
LOOKING FOR IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT HAS HAS BEEN DISCUSSED? I
KNOW WORK FOR A SURVEY AND ALSO
HELPING ÁP APPLICANTS OUT WITH
THE EXAM. UM ARE THE 22 MAIN
ISSUES THAT THEY HIGHLIGHTED. I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S BEEN HAS BEEN OR IS BEING
DISCUSSED. UM YES, UH, CHAIR,
BERMAN. UM, WE, UH UH, EXECUTIVE
OFFICER ON F AND I HAVE MET WITH
JUDICIAL COUNCIL REGARDING THAT
REQUEST. UM AND BEFORE I GO TO
THAT, I'LL I'LL JUST RESPOND
QUICKLY TO SENATOR ROSS. UM,
LAST STATEMENT. UM YOU KNOW, UM
W. WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT UH,
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN UM,
THE SHORTAGE OF FOR REPORTERS
AND THE SHORTAGE OF, UH
REPORTERS WHO ARE WORKING IN THE
COURTS, AND SO, UH, FOR EXAMPLE,
UM WHAT USED TO BE ONE OR TWO
COURT REPORTERS FOR A DAY IN A
COURT HAS NOW TURNED INTO FIVE
COURT REPORTERS WHO ARE, UM, WHO
ARE NOW HAVING TO, UM CONTRACT
EACH FOR ONE CASE, TWO CASES,
AND SO THERE'S AN EFFICIENCY
LOSS THERE. UM AND SO PART OF
THE QUESTION IS, HOW DO WE HOW
DO WE RETURN BACK TO THAT
ORIGINAL SYSTEM OR SOMETHING
CLOSER TO IT? UM AND SO, UM, YOU
KNOW, THAT IS THAT IS PART OF
THE DISCUSSION WE'VE HAD WITH
JUDICIAL COUNSEL. I WILL SAY WE
ARE. WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
LOOKING AT MUCH OF WHAT JUDICIAL
COUNSEL HAS REQUESTED. LOOKING
AT HOW WE CAN, UH BETTER HAVE
RECIPROCITY. UM WITH, UM OTHER
TESTS WITH OTHER, UM STATES. UM
AND THEN, UM, ALSO LOOKING AT
UH, HOW WE CAN TRY TO BRING OUR
TESTING IN LINE WITH OTHER, UH
WITH OTHER TESTS THAT ARE OUT
THERE. UM, IN TERMS OF HOW WE
CAN HELP. UH, TEST TAKERS PASS
THE TEST. HOWEVER UM, THE BOARD
HAS HAD, UM, EXTENSIVE
DISCUSSIONS ON THAT ISSUE. UM
AND HAVE DETERMINED THAT, UM,
REALLY A CONFLICT OF INTEREST
BECAUSE THE BOARD, UM, DOES
ISSUE THE TEST. AND SO, UM, IF
WE'RE BOTH ISSUING THE TEST AND
THEN HELPING APPLICANTS TO PASS
IT, UM, THAT THAT COULD
CONSTITUTE, UM, A AN ISSUE THERE
. AND SO WE HAVE LEFT, UM, THAT
ROLE TO, UM BOOK, THE SCHOOLS
AND THE TRADE ASSOCIATIONS. UM,
THAT SAID AGAIN, WE ARE LOOKING
AT, UM, WAYS TO MAKE THAT TEST
ALIGN BETTER WITH EXISTING TESTS
IN OTHER STATES AND NATIONALLY.
SENATOR JUST A FOLLOW UP. YOU
KNOW WHETHER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
RECIPROCITY OR TEST TAKING
ASSISTANCE OR ANYTHING ELSE.
THESE EFFORTS ARE GOING TO TAKE
TIME NEW STUDENTS IN PIPELINES.
UM THE COURTS, OF COURSE, RAISE
THE ISSUE BECAUSE WITHOUT A
COURT REPORTER, THERE'S NÓ
EFFECTIVE APPEAL, AND WE'RE
DEALING WITH PEOPLE WHO DON'T
HAVE THE MONEY TO PAY FOR A
COURT REPORTER. I GUESS MY
COMMENT AND THE REASON I RAISED
IT IS, I THINK THERE'S A CERTAIN
SENSE OF URGENCY THAT WE NEED TO
ALL ADOPT HERE TO CREATE AT
LEAST A TEMPORARY SOLUTION TO
THIS PROBLEM FOR THOSE PEOPLE
WHO ARE STUCK IN THESE COURTS
AND DO NOT HAVE A COURT REPORTER
TO MAKE A RECORD. UH JUST MY
COMMENT AND I THE BOARD. IT'S
NOT THE BOARD'S RESPONSIBILITY.
YOU HAVE YOUR SANDBOX AND YOUR
PERFORMING VERY WELL IN IT. AND
I'M THANKFUL FOR THAT. AS A
FORMER CUSTOMER OF YOURS, UH,
BUT I DO THINK AS A GROUP AND AS
A LEGISLATURE. WE NEED TO ADOPT
A SENSE OF URGENCY WITH THIS AND
IT'S CAUGHT UP IN THE POLITICS
AND NOBODY UNDERSTANDS POLITICS
BETTER THAN THOSE OF US WHO SIT
UP AT THE DAIS. BUT I THINK AT
SOME POINT WE NEED TO PUT
POLITICS ASIDE AND WORK A
TEMPORARY SOLUTION TO THIS. SO
FOR THOSE IN THE AND THOSE
LISTENING TO THIS. I THINK WE
OUGHT TO PUT OUR SHOULDER TO THE
WHEEL AND FIX THIS PROBLEM AGAIN
ON AT LEAST ON A TEMPORARY
BASIS. THANK YOU, MR CHAIR.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. SOME MEMBER
OF PIN. THANK YOU. I'M I'M
READING HERE THAT SOME OF THE
FAILURE RATES ARE 70 TO 80% AND
IN ONE YEAR IT WAS 94.5. SO UM,
MY QUESTION. WHY DO YOU THINK
IT'S SO HARD FOR FOLKS TO PASS
THIS TEST? IS THAT SO, I. I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THE FIRST TIME PASS RATE
, SO THE OVERALL PASS RATE IS
SKEWED IN THE SENSE THAT ONCE
THE CANDIDATE LEAVES SCHOOL, WE
DON'T KNOW IF THEY CONTINUE TO
PRACTICE OR WHAT EFFORT THEY
ACTUALLY PUT INTO GETTING BETTER
AT THE SKILL. SO FOR COMPARISON
PURPOSES WE ALWAYS USE THE FIRST
TIME PASS RATE. BEFORE WE WENT
ONLINE IN 2020. THE PASS RATE
WAS ALL OVER THE BOARD AND IT
WAS AS LOW AS YOU SAID IN THE IN
THE TEENS AS A PERCENTAGE RATE.
ONCE WE MOVE THE SKILLS TEST
ONLINE, WE SAW AN AMAZING SIDE
EFFECT IN THAT THE PASSAGE
RATES. UM STARTED TO SMOOTH OUT.
IT'S BEEN 50 TO ALMOST 60%
PASSAGE RATE SINCE WE MOVED THE
SKILLS TEST ONLINE SO THAT
STABILIZED IN ADDITION TO THAT,
ONCE WE STARTED LICENSING VOICE
WRITERS, WE'VE SEEN THAT PASS
RATE INCREASE AS WE EXPECTED,
AND THE MOST CURRENT PASS RATES
ARE IN THE 60 TO ALMOST 70% PASS
RATE. SO WE ARE SEEING THAT OK?
OK AND THEN I JUST ANOTHER
QUESTION. UH, HOW IS A I
IMPACTING YOUR INDUSTRY? I MEAN,
IS THAT WHAT THE VOICE RECORDERS
ARE THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT?
OR NÓ ACTUALLY A I IS A WHOLE
LEVEL ABOVE THAT. SO THE VOICE
RECORDERS, THE DIGITAL, UH,
MONITORS, THEY BASICALLY COME IN
WITH TAPE RECORDING EQUIPMENT,
AND THAT HAS ITS OWN PROBLEMS AS
WELL AS THE TRANSCRIPTION FROM
THOSE RECORDINGS. SEPARATE
PROBLEM. IF YOU WANT TO TALK
ABOUT A I, I WOULD JUST SAY THAT
IT'S PRETTY AMAZING HOW COURT
REPORTER AS AN INDUSTRY HAVE
ALWAYS EMBRACED TECHNOLOGY, AND
SO WE ARE ON THE CUTTING EDGE OF
IT. YOU'LL FIND A I ALREADY
BUILT INTO ALL OF THE, UM
TRANSLATION SOFTWARE PROGRAMS
THAT COURT REPORTERS ARE USING.
WHERE IT GETS TO BE TRICKY AND
WILL BE KIND OF THIS IS A
PREVIEW OF COMING ATTRACTIONS
FOR ALL OF THE LEGISLATORS. WE
HAVE SOFTWARE THAT WILL OFFER A
TRANSLATION. IT WILL SAY THIS IS
WHAT WE THINK IT HEARD NOW. THAT
CAN BE ONE WORD. IT CAN BE THE
ENTIRE PROCEEDING. IN A STATE AS
DIVERSE AS CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE
SOME SPECIAL PROBLEMS WITH THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE TESTIFYING IN
COURT AND IN DEPOSITIONS, THEY
COME FROM SO MANY DIFFERENT
ETHNICITIES. UM THEY MAY BE
FIRST GENERATION AMERICANS. THE
ACCENTS ARE VERY STRONG. AND IT
DOESN'T EVEN HAVE TO BE. PEOPLE
ARE BORN OUTSIDE OF THE COUNTRY.
WE HAVE REGIONAL DIALECTS THAT
ARE VERY STRONG AND ON THE A. I
IS NOT ABLE TO MAKE THE
DIFFERENTIATION AND MAKE THE
CORRECT GUESS IF YOU WILL. AT
WHAT THAT WORD IS. SO WE ARE
ALWAYS GOING TO NEED THAT. THAT
HUMAN ELEMENT WE'RE GOING TO
NEED A COURT REPORTER AS A
NEUTRAL THIRD PARTY THAT THAT'S
CAN SAY I'M IMPARTIAL. THIS IS
WHAT HAPPENED AND I CERTIFIED.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENED HERE YOU
ARE LITIGANT. YOU CAN TAKE THIS
TO THE APPEALS COURT. NOT IN A
CASE RIGHT NOW. I THINK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO ACT. BUT AS
IT DEVELOPS, I THINK THAT YOU
WILL SEE THIS ISSUE COMING BACK
BEFORE YOU. THANK YOU. JO ASHBY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. UH, FIRST, I
JUST WANNA SAY, UH, GOOD MORNING
TO M TARRE. IT'S NICE TO SEE
YOU. UM I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS FOR YOU GUYS. UH, ONE
IS, WHAT ARE WHAT ARE SOME OF
THE IDEAS FROM THE BOARD'S
PERSPECTIVE TO INCREASE COURT
REPORTING EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS.
THERE APPEAR TO BE JOB
OPPORTUNITIES. UM SO I'M JUST
WONDERING WHY THERE AREN'T MORE
PROGRAMS. LET ME GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE. IN CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE
MORE THAN 100 SCHOOLS THAT OFFER
COSMETOLOGY PROGRAMS, BUT ONLY
THAT I KNOW OF ABOUT EIGHT
SCHOOLS THAT OFFER TRAINING FOR
COURT REPORTERS. DO YOU GUYS
HAVE SOME SUGGESTIONS ON
PATHWAYS. UM, THANK YOU, UH, UM
SO, UM, ACTUALLY, MUCH OF THE
TRAINING CAN HAPPEN ONLINE. UM,
AND HAPPENS OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO THOSE EIGHT
SCHOOLS ARE JUST, UM, THOSE THAT
ARE LOCATED IN CALIFORNIA. UM
THAT SAID, WE ARE, UM, WORKING
WITH THE CALIFORNIA UM,
COMMUNITY COLLEGES, UM, AND
WOULD LOVE TO WORK MORE
EXTENSIVELY WITH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO GET MORE
PROGRAMS INTO OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BECAUSE, UM, YOU KNOW,
AS WE'VE SAID, THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLY DYNAMIC PROFESSION,
UM, OF LUCRATIVE 11 THAT CAN, UM
TO REALLY GREAT JOBS. UM AND SO,
UM, I KNOW. UM MISS FENNER AND
OTHER STAFF WITH THE BOARD HAVE,
UM, DONE GREAT WORK TO DO.
OUTREACH. UM, AT DIFFERENT
WORKFORCE AND JOB FAIRS. UM BUT,
UM, CERTAINLY LOOKING TO EXPAND
OUR REACH WITH, UH, WITH THE
CREATION OF SCHOOLS. CERTAINLY,
UM UH, MISS. WE DO YOU DO YOU
WANT TO ADD ANYTHING? I WOULD
JUST ADD TO THAT WE COURT
REPORTERS HAD THE BEST JOB THAT
NÓ ONE'S EVER HEARD OF. UH, MOST
PEOPLE NEVER COME IN CONTACT
WITH THE LEGAL SYSTEM, AND IF
THEY DO, IT'S A IT'S A ONE TIME
THING, SO THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW
COURT REPORTERS ARE OUT THERE.
IT'S A WONDERFUL, UH, CAREER IT
IT'S OPEN TO WE HAVE A LARGE
NUMBER OF MINORITIES, A LARGE
NUMBER OF, UM WOMEN THAT ARE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES
SINGLE HANDEDLY WITH THROUGH
THIS PROFESSION, SO IT'S REALLY
KEY THAT WE GET THE WORD OUT.
WHAT'S EXCITING NOW IS I THINK
WE ARE IN A TIME OF MORE
ACCEPTANCE FOR VOCATIONAL
TRAINING. THERE WAS A TIME WHERE
OH, NÓ YOU HAD TO GO TO COLLEGE
VOCATIONS REALLY DIDN'T HAVE A
PLACE SO THAT, UM, ATTITUDE HAS
CHANGED. AND SO WE ARE, UM,
HOPEFUL THAT, UM, THE
LEGISLATURE WILL HELP US GET
INTO THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
GET INTO, UM, THE DIFFERENT
HIGHER EDUCATION. UM OVERSIGHT
AGENCIES THAT THAT, UM, GIVE
FUNDING FOR ADULT EDUCATION.
IT'S A OFTEN A SECOND CAREER.
IT'S NOT EVERYONE COMING OUT OF
COLLEGE OR EXCUSE ME OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL. UM IT'S A SECOND CAREER
PEOPLE HAVE, YOU KNOW, FINISHED
THEIR DEGREE AND FIND OUT THEY
DON'T WANT TO TEACH ENGLISH. BUT
THEY HAVE THE ENGLISH BACKGROUND
THAT WILL MAKE THEM PERFECT
COURT REPORTERS, RIGHT WASN'T
PLANNING ON TELLING THIS STORY,
BUT I THINK I WILL. ONE OF THE
ROLES OF THIS COMMITTEE THAT THE
CHAIRMAN AND I BOTH AGREE UPON
IS YOU KNOW THERE'S THIS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT PIECE,
RIGHT? YES THERE'S THE SUNSET
PARTS AND ALL THESE THINGS THAT
WE DO, BUT IN THIS STATE, WE'RE
ALWAYS LOOKING FOR OPPORTUNITIES
FOR GOOD HIGH WAGE JOBS FOR
PEOPLE AND THIS IS ONE OF THEM,
AND WE NEED TO FIND WAYS TO SING
IT FROM THE ROOFTOPS. AND I LOVE
THE IDEA OF IT BEING CONSIDERED
MORE VOCATIONAL AND FOCUS. ON
HOW THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES CAN
HELP US PUSH PEOPLE TO THIS
CAREER AND INTRODUCE IT TO THEM.
AND THIS IS THE STORY. I WANT TO
TELL PEOPLE IN THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO, THE CITY ATTORNEY IS
THE FIRST LATINA FEMALE TO HOLD
THAT POSITION. SHE IS A LAWYER
BECAUSE WHILE BEING RAISED BY A
SINGLE MOM IN L, A HER MOTHER
WAS A COURT REPORTER, AND SHE
AND HER LITTLE SISTER SAT IN THE
BACK OF THE ROOM AFTER SCHOOL
BECAUSE SHE HAD A VERY NICE
JUDGE. AND SO SUSANA ALCALA WOOD
AND HER SISTER SAT IN THE BACK
OF THOSE CHAMBERS EVERY DAY AND
WATCHED THEIR MOM SUSANNA WAS SO
MOVED THAT SHE ENDED UP BECOMING
A LAWYER AND NOW RUNS THE CITY
OF SACRAMENTO'S LEGAL DEPARTMENT
, WHICH OVERSEES ABOUT 35
ATTORNEYS. SO, I, I DO BELIEVE
THAT BEING A COURT REPORT
THERE'S QUITE THE NOBLE
PROFESSION AND CAN REALLY LEAD
PEOPLE INTO OTHER CAREERS AS
WELL. SO I THANK YOU FOR THE
WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING AND LOOK
FORWARD FOR THE TO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP GET MORE
PEOPLE IN THIS PROFESSION. DO
YOU HAVE ONE LAST QUESTION FOR
YOU? AND THIS ONE. I JUST KIND
OF WANT TO GET ON THE RECORD SO
THAT WE CAN INCLUDE IT IF WE
NEED TO IN ANYTHING FURTHER HAS
THE BOARD RECEIVED ANY
COMPLAINTS ABOUT ELECTRONIC
RECORDINGS? I KNOW IT'S A TOPIC.
ADJACENT THAT COMES UP A LOT
HERE OR THE OTHER TRANSCRIPT.
ISSUES THAT ARE NOT WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTION. AND IF SO, DOES
THE BOARD REFER THESE COMPLAINTS
TO ANY OTHER AGENCY? I'LL JUMP
INTO THAT ONE, MADAM TO GOTTI IF
YOU DON'T MIND JUST BECAUSE IT'S
TECHNICAL AND DEALS WITH THE
COMPLAINTS, SO WE DON'T HèA
ACTUALLY HAVE JURISDICTION OVER
WORK THAT PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT
COURT REPORTERS ARE DOING SO,
FOR INSTANCE, WE DO HAVE, UM
PEOPLE THAT WILL CALL AND SAY, I
GOT A TRANSCRIPT FROM AN
ELECTRONIC RECORDING, AND I
DON'T THINK IT'S ACCURATE. WE
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
ANYTHING ABOUT THAT BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT LICENSED COURT
REPORTERS. UM WE DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY RIGHT NOW, IF WE HAVE A
COMPLAINT ABOUT ACCURACY OF THE
TRANSCRIPT, WE CAN GO TO THE
COURT AND SAY, SEND US THE NOTES
FOR THIS PROCEEDING. IF IT'S A
DEPOSITION, WE CAN GO TO THE
COURT REPORTER AND SAY, SEND US
YOUR NOTES FOR THIS PROCEEDING.
WE CAN LOOK AT THE FINAL
TRANSCRIPT. WE CAN LOOK AT THE
ORIGINAL NOTES THAT ON ARE THE
BASIS OF THE GENERATION OF THAT
TRANSCRIPT AND SAY YES, THIS IS
ACCURATE OR NÓ. THERE WAS A
PROBLEM. WITH AN AUDIO RECORDING
. WE DON'T KNOW WE DON'T HAVE
THE AUDIO RECORDING. WE DON'T
KNOW THE AUTHENTICITY OF THE
AUDIO RECORDING. WE DON'T KNOW
IF IT'S BEEN IN, UM, MANIPULATED
IN ANY WAY OR OR ALTERED. AND
THAT PERSON THAT TRANSCRIBES IT
DOESN'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION SO
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
COMPLAINTS, BUT WE AREN'T ABLE
TO ACT ON THEM. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU, UH,
LET ME JUST FIRST KIND OF DRUPAL
DOWN ON THE P S¼ A. THAT COURT
REPORTING IS A WONDERFUL
PROFESSION. UH UH UH, A VERY
GOOD PAYING PROFESSION AND, UH,
MORE PEOPLE SHOULD BE GOING INTO
IT. UM AND SO DEFINITELY, YOU
KNOW, LET US KNOW, UH, ANY
ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO TO HELP,
UH, IN TERMS OF ENCOURAGING MORE
PEOPLE, IT'S ENCOURAGING TO HEAR
THE NUMBERS OF, UH, APPLICANTS
AND FOLKS TAKING THE TEST ARE
INCREASING, UH, OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS, SO HOPEFULLY
THAT CONTINUES TO PROGRESS. UH,
ONE QUESTION A LOT OF THE YOU
HAVE IMPORTANT QUESTIONS HAVE
BEEN ASKED AND ANSWERED, UM,
REGARDING THE TRANSCRIPT
REIMBURSEMENT FUND. II I THINK
THIS IS A CRITICAL PROGRAM. BUT
IT SEEMS THAT THE CURRENT WAY
WE'RE FUNDING MAY BE A BIT
COMPLICATED. ARE THERE
CHALLENGES FOR THE BOARD TO WORK
THROUGH FISCAL ISSUES AND
DEVELOP A BUDGET WHEN THERE IS
PRESSURE TO KEEP THE Tð RF
FUNDED IN THE BOARD'S OPINION,
COULD IT BE POSSIBLE TO SEPARATE
OUT THE REVENUE NEEDED TO FUND
THE Tð RF INTO ITS OWN FEE
ASSESSMENT, SO WE CAN HAVE A
MORE RELIABLE PICTURE OF WHAT'S
BROUGHT IN, UH, AND WHAT'S SPENT
ON THE PROGRAM. UH, THANK YOU,
MR CHAIR. UM, YOU KNOW, THE Tð
RF IS, UM ONE OF THE MOST
CRITICAL PROGRAMS THAT WE DO
HAVE, UM, WHEN WE SPEAK ABOUT,
UH, THE URGENCY FOR IN INDIGENT
NEEDS, UM AND YOU KNOW, I. I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE TO ADD, UM
HOW MUCH THE BOARD FEELS THAT
URGENCY. UM AND JUST TO ADD THAT
, UM, YOU KNOW, THIS IS THE ONE
OF THE WAYS THAT WE MAKE SURE
THAT, UM THAT, UM, OUR, UM MOST,
UH IN THE CALIFORNIANS ARE
GETTING THE SERVICES. UM, AND
THAT THEY ARE GETTING THE SAME
EXACT, UM, SERVICES THAT SOMEONE
WHO CAN AFFORD TO PAY FOR THOSE
SERVICES CAN GET AND SO, UM, YOU
KNOW, UH, WE WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT, UM THAT POOR PEOPLE ARE
NOT GETTING SOME SORT OF LESSER
OPTION. UM IN THE COURSE OF
URGENCY. UM BUT, UH, YOU KNOW, I
IN TERMS OF HOW WE FUND THE Tð
RF, UNFORTUNATELY, UM, IT IS. IT
IS COMPLICATED. UM AND PART OF
THAT IS THAT, UH, THE NUMBER OF
LICENSES CHANGES EVERY YEAR AND
SO, UM, IN ORDER TO, UH, FOR
EXAMPLE, SET AN EXACT AMOUNT.
FOR, UM FOR THE Tð RF TO BE
FUNDED AT, UM, WILL REQUIRE US
TO KNOW EXACTLY HOW MANY, UH,
LICENSES WE HAVE EVERY YEAR AND
THEN CHANGE THAT SET AMOUNT. FOR
A LICENSEE, FOR EXAMPLE, UM, OR
TO COME UP WITH UM YOU KNOW SOME
OTHER SOME OTHER SOURCE, UM, WE
HAVE RECEIVED GENERAL FUND
INFUSIONS IN THE PAST, UM, FOR
WHICH WE'VE BEEN VERY GRATEFUL.
AND IT HAS REALLY HELPED, UM,
KEEP THE Tð RF SUSTAINABLE.
HOWEVER, UM YOU KNOW, AT AT THIS
TIME IT IT DOESN'T SEEM THAT
THERE IS A WAY. UH, TO CHANGE
THE CURRENT UH, THE CURRENT
FORMAT OF THE OF THE FUND BUT
WOULD BE OPEN TO IDEAS FROM
LEGISLATURE. I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT, UM, WE WE'VE HAD THE Tð RF
BUILT INTO OUR, UM, BUDGETING
PROCESS FOR SO LONG, AND IT SORT
OF TAKES PRIORITY, SO THAT'S OUR
MAIN SOURCE OF FUNDING. SO
FIRST, IT'S STAFF. THEN IT'S THE
Tð RF. SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT EVERYTHING. UM IF
ANYBODY HAS AN IDEA ON A WAY OF
ASSESSING THAT WE WOULD
DEFINITELY BE OPEN TO IT. I
THINK OUR CHAIR TOUCHED ON THE
FACT THAT WITH THAT MOVING
TARGET WITH A NUMBER OF LICENSES
CHANGING I'M NOT SURE HOW WE
WOULD FACTOR THAT IN BUT WE'RE
TOTALLY OPEN TO IT. GREAT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. UM AND SENATOR
ROTH HAD A HAD A GOOD SUGGESTION
ON HIS WAY OUT OF, YOU KNOW,
REACHING OUT EVEN LOWER THAN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE, MAYBE TO THE
HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL. MAYBE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARD
ASSOCIATION, UM, TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY KNOW, UH, ABOUT THESE
REALLY, REALLY GOOD
OPPORTUNITIES THAT COULD EXIST
FOR, UH, FUTURE COURT REPORTERS.
WE'VE BEEN IN CONTACT WITH THE
GUIDANCE COUNSELORS, FOR EXAMPLE
, BECAUSE THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW
ABOUT THE INDUSTRY THAT IT'S A
VIABLE CAREER. EXACTLY RIGHT.
THAT'S GREAT. UM SO WITH THAT,
WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. UH, ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO WANT TO COME AND
TESTIFY FOR UP TO TWO MINUTES
PER ORGANIZATION ON THE COURT
REPORTER BOARD. I DON'T SEE
ANYBODY LEAPING UP NOW I DO OK.
UM AND I THINK, JUST PULL THE
MICROPHONE UP. I'M ASSUMING IT'S
ON IF IT'S NOT, WE'LL FIGURE IT
OUT. HOLD ON ONE SECOND. IS THE
MIC ON YEAH. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRS AND MEMBERS,
IGNACIO HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COURT REPORTERS
ASSOCIATION, UM, SUPPORT OF THE
èC RB IN THE EXTENSION OF THE
SUNSET. UM, BUT ALSO WANT TO
ADDRESS A COUPLE OF ISSUES THAT
I CAN GO TO THE ENTIRE
DISCUSSION ON WORKFORCE. UM, A
COUPLE OF, UM ARE WITHIN THE
PURVIEW OF THE èC RB RIGHT NOW,
AND SOME SUGGESTIONS ON THINGS
THAT CAN'T BE DONE. UH, NUMBER
ONE. THERE ARE TWO ISSUES THAT
COME UP RIGHT NOW. THE
IMMEDIATELY THAT WE ARE
CONCERNED AT THE èC RB THAT
COULD HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE
NUMBER OF LICENSES IN, UM,
CALIFORNIA AND THAT IS THE Dð RB
IS MOVING TO, UH, WITHDRAW THE,
UH, AUTHORITY OF AN APPLICANT TO
REVIEW UH, HER HIS OR HER, UM,
ONLINE, UH, EXAM, UH, TO SEE
WHERE THEY HAVE MADE SOME OF THE
MISTAKES, UM, AND ALSO
WITHDRAWING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAL. UM THE FAILURE OF AN OF
SOMEBODY FAILS AN EXAM. UH WITH
JOHN THE ABILITY TO APPEAL THE
RESULTS. THOSE TWO THINGS WE ARE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT BECAUSE
THAT ACTUALLY COULD LOWER THE
NUMBER OF FOLKS WHO PASS. UM
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF, UM,
LICENSEES WHO THEY HAD TO TAKE
IT MULTIPLE TIMES AND BEING ABLE
TO REVIEW THE DICTATION PORTION
OF IT, AND ALSO TO APPEAL IS
WHAT LED THEM TO THE PATHWAY TO
ACTUALLY GET THEIR LICENSE. SO
WE ARE ASKING THE èC RB TO
REVERSE THAT PUT A HOLD ON THOSE
CHANGES. AND WE SHOULD LOOK AT
THAT VERY CLOSELY AND FIND A
WAY, UH, TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
TO ALLOW FOR REVIEW AND APPEAL.
ON THE WORKFORCE PIECE. I REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE DISCUSSION. I
CAN SPEAK FOR TWO HOURS ON THAT.
UM BUT I WON'T. BUT I WILL
MENTION A COUPLE OF THINGS. ONE
IS THE L A Ó JUST RELEASED A
LETTER AT THE REQUEST OF, UM,
THE CHAIR OF THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE SPECIFICALLY
ON COURT REPORTERS AND THE, UH,
NEED FOR COURT REPORTERS, AND I
KNOW MEMBERS OF THE OF THE, UH
OF MY CLIENT. UM CESAR
PARTICIPATED AND PROVIDED A
NUMBER OF VERY SPECIFIC THINGS
THAT COURTS CAN DO TODAY TO
INCREASE THE AVAILABILITY OF
COURT REPORTERS, UM IN
COURTROOM. IN FAMILY LAW COURTS.
IT'S JUST A MAT MATTER OF DAILY
MANAGEMENT, UM, AND A NUMBER OF
OTHER THINGS OF CO ORDINATION SO
HAPPY TO SHARE SOME OF THOSE IN
WRITING, UM, WITH THE CHAIRS AND
WITH THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS, SO
THERE ARE THINGS THAT CAN BE
DONE NOW, WE SPENT HOURS TALKING
TO THE L A Ó AND BEING
INTERVIEWED, UM, FOR THAT
REPORT. THAT REPORT IS OR THAT
LETTER IS ONLINE. IF ANYONE
WANTS TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT,
AND THAT'S TWO MINUTES, SO IF
YOU CAN WRAP UP, UH AND THEN
SUBMIT ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
FOR YOUR WRITING WOULD BE GREAT
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. WE ARE
WORKING ON A PROJECT SIMILAR TO
WHAT I WORKED ON WITH THE
INTERPRETERS, WHICH WOULD ALLOW
FOR SOME PAYMENT OF UH, COVER
SOME OF THE COST OF TRAINING AND
COST OF THE EXAM AND WITH THE
GUARANTEED JOB ALREADY
AVAILABLE, SO FOLKS GO THROUGH
THE TRAINING, KNOWING THEY'LL
HAVE A JOB AT THE END. WE'RE
WORKING ON THAT RIGHT NOW AND
HAPPY TO SHARE SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION. UH, WITH EVERYONE,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MR CHAIR,
MADAM CHAIR, COY JASPER ON
BEHALF OF THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
YVONNE, HOW ARE YOU? CHAIR OF
THE COURT REPORTERS BOARD. I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE EXCELLENT WRITE
UP. THAT COVERED ALL THE ISSUES.
WE SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS, ESPECIALLY
THOSE, UH, RECOMMENDATIONS
RELATED TO A WORKFORCE STUDY. I
THINK THAT'D BE REALLY IMPORTANT
TO GET SOME BASIC INFORMATION
ABOUT THE EXISTING WORKFORCE.
THE UH ANY KIND OF ASSISTANCE
WITH NEAR PASSERS WOULD BE A
VERY BENEFICIAL AS WELL. ALSO
THE RECIPROCITY WITH THE, UH
WITH THE NATIONAL TEST I WOULD
POINT OUT THAT THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL HAS A SUCCESSFUL
NEUROPATH NEUROPATH PROGRAM FOR
COURT INTERPRETERS, THE COUNCIL
LICENSES AND CERTIFIES COURT
INTERPRETERS. BUT WE ALSO
IDENTIFY NEAR PASSERS. WE HAVE A
CONTRACT WITH THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR STATE COURTS THAT IS
THEN ABLE TO PROVIDE
INDIVIDUALIZED INTENSIVE
TRAINING. HERE, TUTORING ONE ON
ONE SMALL GROUP TUTORING
SPECIALIZED RESOURCES TO HELP
THOSE COURT INTERPRETERS WHEN
THEY SET FOR THE EXAM THE NEXT
TIME SO THEY THEY CAN BE, UH,
SUCCESSFUL. AS THE SUPREME COURT
NOTED IN THEIR 2018 JAMISON VIVA
DUSA RULING. BOTH THE ABSENCE OF
A VERBATIM RECORD OF TRIAL COURT
PROCEEDINGS WILL OFTEN HAVE A
DEVASTATING EFFECT. LITIGANTS
ABILITY TO HAVE AN APPEAL
DECIDED ON THE MERITS. THE
STEADY DECLINE IN THE NUMBER OF
COURT REPORTERS THREATENS ACCESS
TO JUSTICE. THIS IS A REAL
CRISIS IN THE, UH IN THE COURTS,
ESPECIALLY FOR CALIFORNIANS THAT
CANNOT AFFORD TO PAY THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS. FOR THEIR OWN
PRIVATE COURT REPORTER WHEN A
COURT PROVIDED REPORTER IS NOT
AVAILABLE. IN THE QUARTER. JULY
TO SEPTEMBER, 2020 THREE ALONE
100 AND 33,000 PROCEEDINGS.
HEARD WITHOUT A VERBATIM RECORD.
AND THE FAMILY, PROBATE AND
UNLIMITED CIVIL THE LAST THREE
YEARS. WHILE WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT
THE INCREASE OF VOICE WRITERS
THAT ARE BEING LICENSED, YOU
KNOW WE HAD 68. NEW CSRS LAST
YEAR, 35 THE YEAR BEFORE. AND 39
THE YEAR BEFORE THAT, UH, THE
CURRENT SHORTFALL OF COURT
REPORTERS IS 650. THE L A Ó
REPORT LAST WEEK HAD I THINK 671
AS THE AS THE NUMBER SO THE
NUMBER OF NEW COURT REPORTERS
COMING IN IS NOT ADDRESSING THE
EXISTING SHORTFALL. LOS ANGELES
HAS 100 AND FIVE VACANCIES TODAY
AND THAT'S TWO MINUTES. SO IF
YOU WRAP UP AND THEN SUBMIT ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AND WRITING
THAT DEFINITELY THANK YOU, MR
CHAIR WE DEFINITELY WANT TO WORK
WITH. YOU KNOW, ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. UH, CHAIRS AND MEMBERS
MIGHT BE. OUR FIRM HAS A NUMBER
OF CLIENTS WHO ARE VITALLY
INTERESTED IN THE COURT REPORTER
ISSUE, INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
JUDGES ASSOCIATION, THE CIVIL
DEFENSE BAR, AND WE ALSO
REPRESENT A COALITION OF
NATIONAL COURT REPORTING FIRMS.
UH, THE PROBLEM IS BIGGER THAN
JUST THE COURTS. IT'S THE MOST
ACUTE IN THE COURTS, BUT WE ARE
ALSO HAVING TROUBLE STAFFING
DEPOSITIONS WITH èC S¼ R S¼,
WHO ARE THE GOLD STANDARD AND
OUR MEMBERS, OUR CIVIL DEFENSE
MEMBERS, UH, IT GIVEN THEIR
DRUTHERS WOULD HAVE A LIVE èC
S¼ R ON SITE. UM THE WHETHER THE
ANSWER IS VOICE WRITING, OPENING
MORE SCHOOLS OR SOMETHING ELSE.
TECHNOLOGY WHATEVER IT IS, UH,
WE THINK THE PROBLEM IS BOTH IN
THE COURTS AND IN HAVING PEOPLE
AVAILABLE FOR DEPOSITIONS. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
BOARD AND THEIR EFFORTS TO ON
WORKFORCE WITH THE SCHOOLS, UH,
AND WITH YOU BECAUSE THE PROBLEM
IS, UH, LARGE AND GROWING, WE
THINK THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CHAIR BERMAN AND VICE CHAIR
ASHBY IS KOBE VATTI. UH, I'M A
WASHINGTON UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT TRUSTEE. AND I THINK
YOU HIT ON SOME VERY KEY POINTS
WHEN YOU SAID, UH PLEASE BRING
THIS ISSUE TO THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION. I
THINK THAT'S A VERY CRITICAL
COMPONENT. BECAUSE A PATHWAY, UH
IN THE SCHOOLS IS THE RIGHT WAY
TO GO ABOUT BRINGING IN NEW
IDEAS AND EXPER. UH YOU KNOW,
GETTING CHILDREN? TO SEE THAT
THERE ARE ACTUALLY GOOD PATHWAYS
, GOOD PAYING JOBS OUT THERE FOR
THEM THAT DON'T REQUIRE A FOUR
YEAR DEGREE I. I ALSO HAPPEN TO
SEE THIS PROFESSION GROWING UP
AS MY FATHER WAS. COURT REPORTER
AND HE STARTED A FIRM IN 1974,
PIZATTI AND JARNIGAN AND
ASSOCIATES. SO I JUST WANNA SAY
I'VE HAD THE EXPERIENCE OF
SEEING THIS PROFESSION GROW AND
BLOSSOM AND SEE THE UPS AND
DOWNS THAT IT'S HAD. BUT II. I
REALLY WISH THAT THE BOARD,
PLEASE. UH UM GO OUT AND TALK TO
èC S¼ B A THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SEEING NÓ ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS FROM THE PUBLIC WANT TO
BRING IT BACK FOR THE LAST
QUESTIONS, IF ANY, FROM
COLLEAGUES ON THE COMMITTEE
NUMBER YEAH. ON THE LAST, UH,
SPEAKER, UM, BRINGING IT UP TO
èC S¼ BA. I THINK THAT THAT
WOULD BE A GREAT A GREAT PATH.
UH, BECAUSE WHAT? IN MY VIEW,
WHAT WE ARE EXPERIENCING IS A
GROWTH IN INTEREST IN èC Tð E,
UH, GREAT TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
UM AND I THINK I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPLORE THAT MYSELF. WITH MY, UH
SCHOOLS AND CONTACTS E S¼ B, A
LIKE TO HEAR FROM YOU. YOU SEE
THAT? THAT'S A PATH, UH, VIABLE.
DEFINITELY THAT'S DEFINITELY
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN PURSUE,
AND IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR IT TO
BEGIN AS EARLY AS HIGH SCHOOL. I
AGREE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR TESTIFYING TODAY.
UM, WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT THE NEXT BOARD.
THANK YOU, EVERYBODY. THANK YOU.
SO NEXT, WE'LL BE HEARING FROM
THE DENTAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA.
I UNDERSTAND DOCTOR, ALAN FENN
FELD, BOARD PRESIDENT, AND TRACY
MONTEZ, THE BOARD'S EXECUTIVE
OFFICER, ARE HERE WITH US TODAY.
UH, PLEASE BEGIN WITH YOUR
OPENING REMARKS. WHENEVER YOU
ARE READY.
GOOD MORNING. UH, GOOD MORNING.
CHEERS ASHBY AND BERMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I AM DOCTOR
ALAN FELSEN FELD AND I'M PROUD
TO BE SERVING IN MY THIRD TERM
AS THE PRESIDENT OF THE DENTAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA. SITTING TO
MY LEFT IS DR TRACY MONTEZ, OUR
EXECUTIVE OFFICER. OUR BOARD
LICENSES AND MONITORS AND
REGULATES APPROXIMATELY 100 AND
4000 DENTAL PROFESSIONALS,
SPECIFICALLY, 40 THREE 1000
DENTISTS, 46,000 REGISTERED
DENTAL ASSISTANTS AND 2000,
THREE 100 REGISTERED DENTAL
ASSISTANTS AND EXPANDED
FUNCTIONS. THE BOARD ALSO SETS
THE DUTIES AND FUNCTIONS OF
UNLICENSED DENTAL ASSISTANCE TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC. AND WE ISSUE
MANY TYPES OF PERMITS, SUCH AS A
GENERAL ANESTHESIA OR MODERATE
SEDATION PERMIT FOR QUALIFIED
DENTISTS AS WELL AS PERMITS FOR
DENTAL SEDATION OR ORTHODONTIC
ASSISTANCE. IN CARRYING OUT THIS
COMPLEX WORK. THE BOARD'S
HIGHEST PRIORITY IS THE
PROTECTION OF THE PUBLIC. THIS
WORK IS PERFORMED WITH AN
APPROPRIATED BUDGET OF
APPROXIMATELY $19 MILLION. AND
84 AUTHORIZED POSITIONS
DISTRIBUTED ACROSS
ADMINISTRATIVE CUSTOMER SERVICE
LICENSING, COMPLAINT, INTAKE
ENFORCEMENT AND DISCIPLINE
UNITS. THE BOARD ITSELF IS
COMPOSED OF 15 MEMBERS AND
THANKS TO GOVERNOR NEWSOM FOR
HIS RECENT APPOINTMENTS, ONE OF
WHOM IS SITTING IN THE BACK OF
THE ROOM RIGHT NOW, UH, I, I
MIGHT ADD, UH, THAT WE ARE NOW
ONLY WITH TWO VACANCIES. AS OF
2011. THE BOARD HAS ALSO HAS A
DENTAL ASSISTANT COUNSEL
CONSISTING OF SEVEN MEMBERS.
BOARD MEMBERS, COUNCIL MEMBERS
AND BOARD OF STAFF WORK TOGETHER
TO CARRY OUT THE BOARD'S MISSION
TO PROTECT AND PROMOTE THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF CONSUMERS
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A FEW MOMENTS
TO HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THAT WE'VE HAD
DURING THE PAST FIVE YEARS. FOR
PERSONNEL. OUR BOARD HAS HIRED A
NEW EXECUTIVE OFFICER IN
NOVEMBER. 2022 AND A NEW
ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE OFFICER IN
DECEMBER OF 2022. OUR VACANCY
RATE, WHICH WAS HOVERING AROUND
25% FOR MANY YEARS HAS BEEN
REDUCED TO ABOUT A 7% RATE,
WHICH IS VERY GOOD FOR A
GOVERNMENT AGENCY. AS OF APRIL
1ST. ALL POSITIONS IN THE
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION WILL BE
FILLED. THAT INCLUDES BOTH SWORN
AND NON SWORN INVESTIGATORS. IN
ADDITION, MANDATED TRAINING IN
ADDITION TO MANDATED èC TRAIN
EXCUSE ME, BOARD MEMBERS AND
MANAGEMENT PARTICIPATED IN THE
DIVERSITY, EQUITY AND INCLUSION
TRAINING. WITH RESPECT TO
LICENSING OF OUR OF OUR MEMBERS,
COMPLETE APPLICATIONS ARE BEING
PROCESSED WITHIN 30 DAYS. NÓ
BACKLOGS EXIST AND THAT IS VERY
GOOD. THE 90 DAYS IS THE
STANDARD. UH ARE GOOD. CONTINUE
EDUCATION ARTISTS HAVE BEEN
RESUMED AFTER BEING DELAYED DUE
TO STAFF VACANCIES. AND FINALLY,
THE ACCESS TO CARE COMMITTEE HAS
BEEN REINSTITUTED TO MORE
CLOSELY EXAMINE WORKFORCE
SHORTAGE REPORTED FOR THE DENTAL
ASSISTING PROFESSION AS WELL AS
SERVING THE UNDERSERVED WITH
RESPECT TO ENFORCEMENT, WHICH I
FEEL IS PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT RESPONSIBILITIES WE
HAVE. SINCE EARLY 2020 THREE,
THE BOARD HAS BEEN THE SUBJECT
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS, ENLIGHTENED ENFORCEMENT
PROJECT, WORKING WITH Dð èC, A
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS AND BOARD
STAFF TO REVIEW UPDATE AND
IMPROVE BOARD ENFORCEMENT
PROCESSES. INSPECTIONS WHICH ARE
COMPLAINT DRIVEN, ARE UNDER 30
INSPECTIONS TO BE PERFORMED
ACROSS BOTH NORTHERN AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND IN BOTH
2021 AND 2020 THREE, THE BOARD
SWORN OFFICERS INVESTIGATED
UNLICENSED ACTIVITY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA, RESULTING IN BOTH
MISDEMEANOR AND FELONY ARRESTS.
WITH RESPECT TO LEGISLATION. 25
BILLS OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS
HAVE IMPACTED THE BOARD. FOR
EXAMPLE, S¼ B 501, WHICH YOU'RE
AWARE OF, WAS A COMPREHENSIVE
UPDATE TO THE DENTAL PRACTICE
ACT COVERING ANESTHESIA AND
SEDATION, ESPECIALLY FOR
PEDIATRIC PATIENTS. AN A B 526
WHEN WE NEEDED HELP AUTHORIZED
DENNIS TO ADMINISTER COVID-19
AND INFLUENZA VACCINATIONS
PROVIDED THEY COMPLY WITH
SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS. BEFORE
CONCLUDING I WOULD LIKE TO END
WITH THE BOARD'S OUTREACH
EFFORTS. SINCE THE COVID-19
PANDEMIC STOLE STATE OF
EMERGENCY CONDUCTED. EXCUSE ME,
CONCLUDED THE BOARD HAS ATTENDED
SOME RESCUE AND SOME RESOURCE
FAIRS AND PROFESSIONAL
ASSOCIATION MEETINGS. THE BOARD
REINSTITUTED ITS NEWSLETTER,
PRODUCING BOTH MAY AND NOVEMBER
ISSUES. AND THESE ARE POSTED
ONLINE. THE BOARD IS NOW ON
SOCIAL MEDIA X, FORMERLY
TWITTER. BORDERS ALSO COMPLETING
A COMPREHENSIVE UPDATE OF ITS
WEBSITE TO MAKE IT MORE USER
FRIENDLY. THIS SHOULD BE
COMPLETED BY THE END OF THIS
MONTH. AND FINALLY, THE BOARD
WILL BE PRESENTING THE FINDINGS
OF ITS SUPPLEMENTAL DIVERSITY
EQUITY AND INCLUSION SURVEY AT
ITS AUGUST BOARD MEETING FOR
INTEGRATING INTO ITS CURRENT
STRATEGIC PLAN. THE BOARD
WELCOMES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH Dð èC A
OUR STAKEHOLDERS, THE
LEGISLATORS AND THE PUBLIC TO
CARRY OUT THE MISSION OF THE
BOARD, AND WE WILL BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE NOW. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I'M JUST HERE FOR SUPPORT, ALL
RIGHT? EVERYONE NEEDS A LITTLE
SUPPORT. OPEN UP THE COLLEAGUES
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
STARRING YEAH, UH, SOME OF THEM
CREOLE. GOOD MORNING AND THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE. UM S¼ SOME
AREAS. I  N THE STATE DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO DENTISTS, UM, SERVICES
? UH, THE LACK OF ACCESS NOT
ONLY IN THE DENTAL CARE, BUT
ALSO IN HEALTH CARE. AND ALSO I
NOTICED THAT IN SOME, UM AREAS.
THERE IS NÓ. DENTIST PRACTICING
THAT, UM, SIMULATE THE
POPULATION THAT THEY SERVE. WE
HEARD ON THE PREVIOUS PANEL, UH,
HOW DIVERSE CALIFORNIA IS AND
THE IMPORTANCE OF HAVING ACCESS.
UM IN THAT CASE FOR CORE
REPORTING, UH, THE SAME I
BELIEVE IS FOR HEALTH CARE. AND
THOSE ARE CONVERSATIONS THAT
I'VE HAD WITH èC MA THAT
DOCTORS ASSOCIATION TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE A DIVERSE UH, PROFESSION
PROFESSIONALS THAT SERVE THE
COMMUNITIES THEY REPRESENT. AND
I. I MY EXPERIENCE. I KIND OF
SEEN THE SAME THING IN THE
DENTAL PROFESSION. UH THAT THERE
IS NOT A DIVERSE, UM, NUMBER OF
DENTISTS THAT REPRESENT THE
AREAS THAT THEY SERVE. UH IS
THERE SOMETHING THAT IS BEING
DONE TO TRY TO GET THIS KIND OF,
UM DIVERSE PROFESSIONALS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE, AND I'M
SURE THERE'S ALSO A LACK OF, UH
PROFESSIONALS. DENTISTS? UH, HOW
MANY INTO A STATE? IS THERE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT THE
OTHER? PROGRAMS WHERE YOU COULD
ATTRACT DENTISTS TO COME AND
SERVE IN IN CALIFORNIA THAT
SIMULATE THE POPULATION. YES WE
CERTAINLY ARE AWARE OF WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES AND OUR DATA IS
ACTUALLY SHOWING THAT IT'S NOT
AS BAD AS REPORTED. WHAT WHAT
WE'RE FINDING IS, IT'S MORE THE
ABILITY TO HIRE. HAVING SAID
THAT, THOUGH OUR BOARD IS
WORKING WITH THE HEALTH CARE, UM
AND ACCESS, UM, INFORMATION
CENTER TO GATHER DATA THROUGH
VARIOUS SURVEYS TO LOOK AT
POTENTIAL WORKFORCE SHORTAGES,
AND OUR DATA DOES SHOW FAR IS
SHOWING SOME IN THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY REGIONS AND STANISLAUS
COUNTY REGIONS. AND SO IN FACT,
I'M GOING TO A MEETING TOMORROW
WITH THEM, UM AND SO WORKING
WITH THEM CLOSELY TO LOOK AT
MENTORSHIP PROGRAMS, UM THINGS
LIKE THAT, ESPECIALLY WITH
REGARD TO OUR DENTAL AUXILIARIES
. AND THEN AS FAR AS THE
DENTISTS ARE, WE DO HAVE, UM,
VARIOUS PATHWAYS. UH, USED TO BE
FIVE. IT'S MORE FOR NOW
DIFFERENT PATHWAYS TO COME INTO
THE STATE LICENSED BY CREDENTIAL
LICENSED BY RESIDENCY AND SO
FORTH, SO WE ARE LOOKING AT WAYS
TO FACILITATE ACCESS INTO
CALIFORNIA AND REACHING OUT TO
OTHER UNDERSERVED AREAS. UM AS
DOCTOR FELSEN FELD MENTIONED IN
OUR INTRODUCTION, WE HAVE
REINSTITUTED OUR ACCESS TO CARE
COMMITTEE AND SO WE ARE CHARGED
WITH AGAIN TRYING TO BRING IN A
VARIOUS PIECES OF INFORMATION
AND WORKING WITH OTHER
STAKEHOLDER GROUP. TO REALLY GET
A GOOD PICTURE OF THE WORKFORCE,
SHORTAGE AND DIVERSITY. MUCH OF
THE DATA THAT WE COLLECT THROUGH
OUR SURVEYS IS VOLUNTEER, UH
REPORTED, AND SO WE NEED TO KIND
OF DIG DOWN AND REALLY GET A
SENSE OF THE TRUE PICTURE OF
CALIFORNIA BEYOND JUST THE
VOLUNTEER DATA, BUT IT IS ON OUR
RADAR AND WE'RE WORKING WITH
VARIOUS ORGANIZATIONS TO DO TO
DO OUTREACH AND AGAIN TO LOOK AT
ANY KIND OF BARRIERS OR CONCERNS
WITH AND SERVED. I MIGHT ALSO
ADD, UH, THIS YEAR. WHILE IT'S
NOT A RAPID RESPONSE THIS YEAR,
WE OPENED A NEW DENTAL SCHOOL
NUMBER SIX IN CALIFORNIA. SO THE
MORE DENTISTS THAT WE PRODUCE,
THE MORE LIKELY THEY'RE GONNA
WANT TO STAY IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S BEEN THE TREND AND, UH,
MORE LIKELY THAT THEY'LL BE ABLE
TO FIND THEIR JOBS WHERE THE
JOBS ARE. THAT'S GOING TO TAKE A
FEW YEARS OBVIOUSLY TO COME TO
FRUITION. UH, HAS HAVE THERE
BEEN ANY DISCUSSIONS ON HAVING
THIS NEW PROFESSIONALS GOING
THROUGH THE ACCREDITATION
PROGRAM AND GETTING THEIR
LICENSES. WHO HAVE HIM SERVING
CALIFORNIA, AS OPPOSED TO
TRAINING THEM IN CALIFORNIA, AND
THEN THEY GO TO OTHER STATES.
UH, HAVE YOU HAVE YOU HAD ANY
THOUGHTS OR DISCUSSIONS ON
MAKING THAT PART OF IT?
REQUIREMENT PER S¼ E FOR THEM TO
STAY AND SERVE IN THE UN UN UN
UNSERVED COMMUNITIES. WE DID
HAVE A GRANT PROGRAM MANY YEARS
AGO, WHERE STUDENTS WERE AWARDED
MONEY FOR, UH, THEIR EDUCATION
BY GOING AND PARTICIPATING IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. HOWEVER
WE HAVE SINCE DEPLETED THAT
GRANT MONEY. UH, BUT ONCE UPON A
TIME, THERE WAS, UH, SOMETHING
SET UP FOR THAT. SOUNDS LIKE A
BUDGET REQUEST. OPPORTUNITY IS
WE CREOLE? UH, NÓ ON ROSARIA.
THANK YOU. AND UH, GOOD MORNING.
UM I. I JUST WANNA FOLLOW UP ON
UH, WHAT? ASSEMBLY MEMBER CAR?
UH, BROUGHT UP BECAUSE I THINK
THE ISSUE OF ACCESS IS EXTREMELY
CRITICAL TO COMMUNITIES, RURAL
COMMUNITIES THAT WE REPRESENT.
AND SO, UM I UNDERSTAND YOUR
POINT THAT WE'RE WORKING ON IT.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO BE WORKING
ON IT? LIKE WHAT? YOU KNOW.
THAT'S GREAT THAT YOU GUYS ARE
WORKING ON IT, BUT I'D LIKE MORE
DETAIL. WELL AS I MENTIONED, UH,
WE'RE WORKING WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS TO IDENTIFY THE
DATA IN TERMS OF WHERE THERE'S
ACTUAL WORK WORKFORCE SHORTAGES
BECAUSE AGAIN RIGHT NOW, THE
DATA IS NOT TRENDING THAT IT IS
AS WIDESPREAD AS REPORTED,
HOWEVER, THAT DATA IS VOLUNTARY,
SO THAT'S WHY OUR ACCESS TO CARE
COMMITTEE IS GOING TO BE WORKING
TO GET A MORE FORMAL SER SURVEY
OUT TO TRY AND GET A SENSE OF
WHERE THESE INDIVIDUALS WHEN
THEY GRADUATE WHERE THEY GO.
PRACTICE WE DON'T COLLECT THAT
DATA, SO THAT'S WHY WE HAVE TO
WORK ON IT BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
THE IMMEDIATE DATA AT HAND. UM
WE ALSO AGAIN LIKE I SAID, WE
HAVE THE VARIOUS PATHWAYS. WE'RE
WORKING ON A LEGISLATIVE BILL
WITH ONE OF OUR STAKEHOLDER
ASSOCIATIONS TO LOOK AT, UM, A
PRECEPTORSHIP POTENTIAL PATHWAY
FOR OUR DENTAL ASSISTANTS, WHICH
WILL AGAIN HOPEFULLY INCREASE
THE INFLUX OF INDIVIDUALS INTO
THE PROFESSION. AND SO AGAIN.
LOOKING AT OUR PATHWAYS LOOKING
AT OUR DATA THAT WE HAVE AND
TRYING TO FIND A BETTER MATCH SO
THAT WE CAN REACH OUT TO THOSE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. WE, UM
YOU KNOW, COMMENT CAME UP
EARLIER ABOUT HOW TO, YOU KNOW,
HELP WITH ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
ONE OF THE NICE THINGS ABOUT THE
DENTAL AUXILIARY IS WE HAVE OUR
DENTAL ASSISTANTS WHO MANY OF
THEM THEN GO ON TO BE R Dð A S¼
AND THEN REGISTERED DENTAL
HYGIENIST AND EVEN IN SOME CASES
, DENTIST AND SO WE DO HAVE
PATHWAYS TO GET INDIVIDUALS
LICENSED. THE NEXT STEP IS THEN
TO GET THEM INTO THESE
COMMUNITIES. SO UM, I THINK IN
YOUR COMMENTS, UH, EARLIER YOU
MENTIONED THAT THERE WAS TWO
COUNTIES STANISLAUS. AND WHAT
WAS THE OTHER COUNTY? LOS
ANGELES COUNTY, WHICH IS A LARGE
COUNTY AND THOSE ARE THE TWO
COUNTIES WHERE THERE ARE
SHORTAGES PRIMARILY OF OUR
DENTAL AUXILIARIES. OKAY? YEAH
I, I THINK, UM IT JUST SEEMS
LIKE I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY WE
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO HAVE THAT
DATA MORE READILY AVAILABLE
SINCE YOU GUYS GIVE THE LICENSES
AND DO HOW DO WE NOT HAVE THAT
DATA? WELL, THAT DATA IS
COLLECTED UPON RENEWAL. SO WE
HAVE TO BE VERY CAREFUL ABOUT
THE DATA THAT WE COLLECT UPON
LICENSURE UNLESS IT IS DIRECTLY
RELATED TO THE QUALIFICATIONS OF
THE LICENSEE. SO WE TEND TO STAY
AWAY FROM DEMOGRAPHIC TYPE OF
DATA UPON LICENSURE BECAUSE THAT
CAN BE PROBLEMATIC IN TERMS OF
LICENSING DECISIONS. IT'S A
PERCEPTUAL ISSUE SO LEGALLY, WE
HAVE TO BE VERY SENSITIVE OF THE
DATA THAT IS COLLECTED UPON
LICENSURE. HOWEVER DURING
RENEWAL, WE DO HAVE A SURVEY
THAT IS COMPLETED. WE ARE
MANDATED. THERE'S ACTUALLY TWO
SURVEYS THAT ARE LICENSES
COMPLETE, AND THAT'S THE DATA
THAT WE'RE STARTING TO LOOK AT.
NOW AGAIN. THIS IS A SEPARATE
STATE AGENCY THAT COLLECTS THE
MOST ROBUST DATA. AND THEY HAVE
JUST STARTED DOING THIS OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS AND PUTTING
IT UP ON A DASHBOARD. AND SO
WE'RE WORKING WITH THEM AND
THEIR DATA TO GET A BETTER SENSE
AGAIN OF THE NEEDS OF THE
UNDERSERVED POPULATION. I HAVE
TO AGAIN REALLY REINFORCE THIS,
THOUGH IT'S A VOLUNTARY DATA. SO
IT'S UP TO THE LICENSEE, AND
IT'S WITHIN ALL OF OUR BOARDS IN
THE DEPARTMENT TO GO THROUGH THE
SURVEY AND ANSWER THE VARIOUS
DEMOGRAPHIC, EDUCATIONAL
TRAINING QUESTIONS AND SO FORTH.
HOW ABOUT THE DATA WITHOUT THE
DEMOGRAPHIC PIECE? LIKE JUST THE
NUMBERS? I KNOW IN MY AREA, I WE
HAVE A LACK. OF YOU KNOW, ALL OF
THE ABOVE WHEN IT COMES TO
DENTAL HEALTH CARE SERVICES,
RIGHT? SO WE DO COLLECT DATA AS
FAR AS UH, COUNTIES AND WE DO
REPORT THAT AT AT OUR QUARTERLY
BUT BOARD MEETINGS, SO WE DO
KNOW IT'S JUST WE DON'T HAVE.
THERE ISN'T A STANDARD PER S¼ E
THAT SAYS FOR EVERY 100,000
CALIFORNIANS. YOU SHOULD HAVE X
AMOUNT OF DENTIST SO WE REPORT
HOW MANY DENTISTS AND DENTAL
ASSISTANTS, BUT WE DON'T HAVE A
STANDARD TO SAY YES, THERE IS A
AN EXTREME SHORTAGE. DON'T SO
HOW? HOW DO WE CREATE A STANDARD
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT WE HAVE ONE
FOR DOCTORS, RIGHT? WE SAY THE
RATIO PER WEEK EVEN LIKE
HOSPITALS, RIGHT? THEY REGULATE
AND SAY WE NEED THIS MANY
NURSES, PER WHATEVER PATIENT SO
I'M JUST CURIOUS. I'M NOT AWARE
OF A POPULATION RATIO. UM THAT
CERTAINLY WE CAN LOOK INTO THAT
AND REPORT BACK TO YOU, UM YES,
THERE'S HOSPITAL PATIENT RATIOS.
UM BUT AS FAR AS POPULATION
RATIOS, I'M NOT AWARE OF THAT
STANDARD. I'M NOT SURE HOW WE
WOULD GO ABOUT THAT, BUT I'M
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO DO THE
RESEARCH AND REPORT BACK. RIGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. DIXON. FOR
THE HØI. I APOLOGIZE. I'VE BEEN
IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE. SO MISSED
A LOT OF THE EARLIER DISCUSSION,
BUT I DO. UH I DID MEET WITH
SOME FOLKS IN THE LEAD UP TO
THIS HEARING, SO I JUST HAD A
COUPLE OF CLARIFYING QUESTIONS
REGARDING DENTAL ASSISTANCE. UH,
THE QUESTION WAS ASKED OF ME.
UH, IF THE DENTAL BOARD COULD
INCREASE. BY ONE SEAT. AN
ADDITIONAL MEMBER ON THE DENTAL
BOARD TO INCLUDE ASSISTANTS. SO
QUESTION NUMBER ONE. I DON'T
KNOW THE PROCESS. UH, IF THE
BOARD RECOMMENDS, OR WE ARE TO
RECOMMEND THAT'S QUESTION NUMBER
ONE NUMBER TWO. I DID LEARN IN
MY DISCUSSION WITH DENTAL
ASSISTANTS. AND FORGIVE ME. I
DON'T HAVE MY NOTES IN FRONT OF
ME. BUT THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF
DENTAL ASSISTANCE LICENSE DENTAL
ASSISTANCE PRACTICING IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THAT'S
TERRIFIC. I ALSO LEARNED TO
CORRECT THIS INFORMATION. IF I'M
WRONG, THAT THERE ARE THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE PERFORMING THE ROLE OF
DENTAL ASSISTANT IN DENTAL
OFFICES WHO ARE NOT LICENSED. IS
THAT? SO ANSWER THOSE TWO
QUESTIONS, PLEASE. HOW ARE THE
BOARD POSITIONS DETERMINED AND
ALLOCATED AMONGST THE ANCILLARY
MEMBERS OF THE PROFESSION AND
NUMBER TWO CLARIFY THE SITUATION
ABOUT DENTAL ASSISTANT
LICENSING. THE SHORT ANSWER TO
THE FIRST QUESTION IS THAT'S
DONE BY STATUTE WHO'S ON THE
DENTAL BOARD. WE ARE A MANDATED
CERTAIN SEATS, AND WE ARE
ACTUALLY LOOKING AT THE
POSSIBILITY OF INCREASING THAT.
IT'S GONNA HAVE TO COME FROM YOU
GUYS, OF COURSE, BUT, UH, THAT
IS SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN
CONSIDERING AND TALKING ABOUT AS
WELL, INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
DENTAL ASSISTANTS ON THE BOARD.
AS FAR AS THE SECOND PART OF THE
QUESTION, UH, THEN PLEASE ASK IT
AGAIN. I'M SO I'M SORRY. I'M I'M
WELL, I DON'T HAVE, AS I SAY. I
DON'T HAVE THE DATA IN FRONT OF
ME. BUT THERE'S THE BASIC ISSUE.
THERE'S A THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
PERFORMING THE ROLE OF DENTAL
ASSISTANTS WHO ARE NOT LICENSED.
UNLICENSED IN. THANK YOU. UH, WE
, UH, TAKE A GREAT GREAT PRIDE
IN WANTING TO SEE OUR DENTAL
ASSISTANTS LICENSED TO DO THEIR
JOBS. BUT IT'S NOT A MANDATE
THAT YOU DO THAT TO BE A DENTAL
ASSISTANT. YOU CAN DO ON THE JOB
TRAINING AND LEARN HOW TO DO
THAT IN A DENTAL OFFICE. SO IF
YOU WANNA BE A DENTAL ASSISTANT,
YOU GO TO YOUR DENTIST. OR SHE
CAN TEACH YOU HOW TO BE A DENTAL
ASSISTANT. BUT THERE WERE
CERTAIN THINGS YOU CANNOT DO.
THERE ARE CERTAIN SKILL SETS
THAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE. THERE ARE
CERTAIN LEGAL IMPLICATIONS. SO
WHEN YOU GET LICENSED, YOU CAN
DO MORE THAN JUST GENERAL. TAKE
THE PATIENT AND TAKE THEIR BLOOD
PRESSURE TYPES OF THINGS. YOU
CAN DO OTHER THINGS WITH THE
PACE AND WITH THE DENTIST YOU'RE
WORKING WITH, SO IT'S OK TO BE
ON LICENSE AND WE DO CONTROL THE
LEGISLATION. WE DO NOT THE
LEGISLATION. WE CONTROL THE
RULES OF WHAT THEY CAN DO AND
WHAT THEY CAN'T DO. WE HAVE THAT
CAP. I WAS HEADED, ENFORCE. SAY
THAT AGAIN, I SAID, HOW IS IT
ENFORCED OR HOW EVERYTHING THAT
IS ENFORCED IS ENFORCED BY
COMPLAINTS WE DO. WE DON'T GO
RUNNING INTO DENTAL OFFICES AND
SAY, LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT
YOU'RE DOING. BUT IF WE GET A
COMPLAINT, WE DO INVESTIGATE
THAT, AND WE DO SEE, UNLIKE
THERE WAS A THERE WAS A NOT
DENTAL ASSISTANT. IT WAS JUST A
BIG ARREST IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA FOR UNLICENSED
DENTISTRY, DENTISTS PRACTICING
SO WE ARE ABSOLUTELY
INVESTIGATING. IF WE GET A
COMPLAINT ABOUT THAT, ARE THERE
MANY DO DOES THE BOARD RECEIVE
ANY COMPLAINTS ABOUT UNLICENSED
DENTAL ASSISTANCE? I DON'T KNOW
THE ANSWER TO THAT. RARELY
RARELY, UM, AND IF I MAY
ELABORATE A LITTLE BIT, THERE'S
ABOUT AGAIN. 46,000 LICENSED
REGISTERED DENTAL ASSISTANCE. WE
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY UNLICENSED
DENTAL ASSISTANCE BECAUSE WE
DON'T TRACK THAT WE MERELY, UH
OR I SHOULD SAY THE LEGISLATURE
HAS SET THEIR DUTIES IN STATUTE
AND AGAIN. UM UH, THERE ARE, UM
PREREQUISITES, OF COURSE. BUT
AGAIN, WE DON'T TRACK THAT. UM
THE DENTIST HAS THE ULTIMATE
AUTHORITY OVER UNLICENSED DENTAL
ASSISTANCE AND REGISTERED DENTAL
ASSISTANTS. IN TERMS OF, UM THE
DUTIES THAT ARE PERFORMED WITHIN
THE IDENTIFIED SCOPE. AND SO IF
WE GET COMPLAINTS, IT'S USUALLY
AGAINST THE DENTIST, NOT
NECESSARILY THE ACTUAL
UNLICENSED OR LICENSED DENTAL
ASSISTANT. OKAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM COLLEAGUES? AND A
SMALL QUIVERS. THANK YOU, MR
CHAIR. UM I MY QUESTION HAS TO
DO WITH THE VACANCY RATES,
PARTICULARLY AROUND THE DENTAL
ASSISTING WORK. UM I'VE HAD THE
CAN YOU HEAR? MY RIGHT TURN MY
VOLUME UP. CAN YOU HEAR ME? IS
THAT BETTER? THANKS THANK YOU.
UM I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
VISIT VISIT CHOWCHILLA, OUR
WOMEN'S PRISON AND INSIDE OF
THAT PRISON, WOMEN ARE HELPING
TO BUILD SOME OF THE, UM DENTAL
TRAYS AND GUARDS. UH AND, UM,
SOME OF THE CUSTOM DENTURES. UH
AND I'M I KNOW THAT THERE IS
WHERE MANY WERE PLACES WHERE
MANY OF THESE WOMEN HAVE COME
FROM. THERE IS A SHORTAGE OF
DENTAL ASSISTANTS. SO I'M
WONDERING, DOES THE BOARD SORT
OF MONITOR AND WORK WITH èC PI
A AROUND, YOU KNOW, PROVIDING
SOME TRAINING PROGRAM THAT MIGHT
ADDRESS OUR SHORTAGE BY
CERTIFYING AND TRAINING THESE
WOMEN, UM, WHO ARE ALREADY DOING
FAIRLY HIGH LEVEL, SOPHISTICATED
WORK INSIDE AND THEN I ALSO
WANTED TO KNOW MORE ABOUT YOUR
LICENSING THE LICENSURE PROCESS
AS IT RELATES TO FORMALLY
INCARCERATED, UH PEOPLE AND WHAT
THE BOARD IS DOING, UM TO
ADDRESS THE VACANCIES WITH
UNDERREPRESENTED POPULATIONS. TO
ADD TO SOME EARLIER CONVERSATION
ON WORKFORCE SHORTAGES, SO THE
BOARD DOES NOT, UM DOES NOT
PROVIDE TRAINING PROGRAMS. WE
REGULATE. UH WE LEAVE THE
TRAINING PROGRAMS TO OUR SCHOOLS
AND OUR ASSOCIATIONS, AND WE
ENCOURAGE THEM TO WORK CLOSELY
WITH PROGRAMS LIKE THAT TO, UH,
SHOW THEM HOW TO MOVE THROUGH
THE LICENSURE PROCESS AND AGAIN,
WE DO HAVE SOME LEGISLATION OUT
THERE THAT WE ANTICIPATE WILL
ADD AN ADDITIONAL PATHWAY TO OUR
DENTAL AUXILIARY. BROWN AGAIN.
I'M GONNA USE THE EXAMPLE OF
GETTING INTO DENTAL ASSISTING
THE UNLICENSED PART MOVING INTO
A REGISTERED DENTAL ASSISTANT
HYGIENE AND THEN A DENTIST. WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A BOARD MEMBER
THAT THAT'S HER PATH. UM AND SO
WE REALLY, UM ARE TRYING TO DO
AS MUCH OUTREACH AS WE CAN WITH
DIFFERENT COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS TO SHOW THEM HOW
TO GET INDIVIDUALS LICENSE. I
KNOW IT SOUNDS LIKE A VERY SMALL
THING, BUT JUST EVEN UPDATING
OUR WEBSITE. WE HAVE SO MANY
PEOPLE THAT REALLY LOOK TO OUR
WEBSITE. HOW DO YOU GET LICENSE?
WE WANT TO MAKE IT AS EASY AS
POSSIBLE. THE OTHER THING THAT
WE'RE DOING IS WE ARE REACHING
OUT TO OUR APPLICANTS, FOR
EXAMPLE, THAT, UM, MAYBE HAVING
DIFFICULTY GETTING LICENSED,
THEY THEY TURN IN WHAT WE CALL A
DEFICIENT APPLICATION. IT
DOESN'T HAVE NECESSARILY ALL THE
TRAINING CERTIFICATES. IT'S
CONFUSING. WE WORK WITH THEM TO
HELP THEM GET THROUGH THE
PROCESS. SO WE HAVE LOTS OF
OUTREACH. LOTS OF MATERIALS. UM
WE'RE HAPPY TO CONNECT WITH ANY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT NEED
ASSISTANCE. BUT AGAIN, WE DON'T
WE DON'T DO THE TRAINING PER S¼
E. WE DO THE LICENSING PART OF
THAT. AND I GUESS JUST TO FOLLOW
UP ON MY CLARIFICATION. UM WHAT
SORT OF DATA ARE YOU COLLECTING
TO LOOK AT OPPORTUNITIES TO
ADDRESS THE VACANCY RATES I. I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU AREN'T DOING
THE DIRECT RECRUITMENT BUT HOW
ARE YOU INFORMING, UH, THE
FIELDS THE SECTOR ON WAYS TO BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE AND
I'M PARTICULARLY BECAUSE YOU ARE
A STATE BOARD AND THE STATE HAS
A RELATIONSHIP WITH THE WOMEN'S
PRISON. UM I'M JUST CURIOUS HOW
YOU KNOW, EVEN IN THAT EXAMPLE,
ARE YOU ARE YOU DOING ANY EFFORT
TO LOOK AT THE TREND OF WHO?
THOSE SORT OF DENTAL WORKERS ARE
INSIDE OF OUR PRISONS. AND HOW
MIGHT WE, UH, BUILD SOME, UM,
CONNECTIONS BETWEEN THE FOLKS
WHO ARE DOING THE RECRUITMENT?
WHAT DATA DO YOU HAVE? DO YOU
COLLECT THAT? WHAT TRENDS? ARE
YOU SEEING? WE DON'T COLLECT
THAT DATA AGAIN. THE DATA THAT
WE TEND TO COLLECT IS RELATED TO
THE PROFESSION, THE
QUALIFICATIONS TO THE PROFESSION
SO WE DON'T NECESSARILY COLLECT
DIRECT DEMOGRAPHIC DATA. UH WE
DO HAVE SOME DATA ON WHERE
INDIVIDUALS GO TO SCHOOLS AND SO
FORTH, UM, AGAIN, HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THE STATE AGENCY TO SEE
WHAT WE CAN DO. UM BUT IT'S
TYPICALLY AGAIN. UM DEMOGRAPHIC
DATA IS SEPARATE THAN INITIAL
LICENSURE DATA, BUT WE WILL WORK
WITH ORGANIZATIONS WHEN THEY
INDICATE THAT THEY HAVE
SHORTAGES. GO OUT. TO UH,
RESOURCE FAIRS MAKE
PRESENTATIONS WORK WITH THE
SCHOOLS. LET THEM KNOW OF WHAT
WE'RE HEARING AND OFTEN AGAIN,
OUR ASSOCIATIONS AND OUR
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS ARE VERY GOOD
AT DOING THAT KIND OF REACH
RESEARCH. REACH, UH, OUTREACH AS
WELL. I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON THAT, UM I'M
AUTHORING A BILL RIGHT NOW. 1067
AND HEALING ARTS WORKING WITH
THE HEALING ARTS BOARDS TO
EXPEDITE LICENSURE FOR FOLKS WHO
ARE GONNA DO THE WORK IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. AND SO
I THINK THERE ARE WAYS FOR US TO
MAKE THE CONNECTIONS. UM AT THE
BOARD LEVEL, UH, TO DEAL WITH
THE VACANCIES AND AT THE SAME
TIME HELP THE STATE DEAL WITH
OUR PROBLEM, WHICH IS TO ADDRESS
POVERTY. UM AND THE LACK OF
REPRESENTATION IN IN SOME OF
THESE SECTORS, SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING. YOU ON THAT, BUT
THANK YOU FOR THAT. THANK YOU.
AND I WOULD THIS IS NOT
UNDERSERVED. I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
WITH REGARD TO THE MILITARY, WE
HAVE EXPEDITED 156 LICENSES AND
WE ALSO HAVE WITH REGARD TO A B
107 EXPEDITED, UM, MILITARY FOR
TEMPORARY. WE'RE DOING THAT,
TOO. SO IF WE'RE IF WE'RE TOLD
TO EXPEDITE WE ARE ON IT. THANK
YOU, SENATOR. UH, SOME CRIO. IT
IS FOLLOWING UP ON, UH, THE
PREVIOUS COMMENTS. UH, FULLY
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU DON'T
COLLECT DATA. UM, FOR VARIOUS
REASONS. AND GOING BACK TO
DENTIST THAT SERVE UNDER SERVED
COMMUNITIES. HAVE YOU THOUGHT
OF, UM LOOKING INTO FOREIGN
DENTAL SCHOOLS BEING ABLE TO
PRACTICE HERE, THEIR STUDENTS
QUITE FRANKLY, YOU KNOW, THE
CALIFORNIA AGAIN IS VERY DIVERSE
POPULATION IS TO BE REPRESENTED,
AND IF, UH DENTAL SCHOOLS FROM
LATIN AMERICA ARE ABLE TO THOSE
STUDENTS BE ABLE TO GO THROUGH
SOME CERTIFICATION PROCESS TO BE
ABLE TO SERVE OUR COMMUNITIES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. BEING
SENSITIVE AGAIN BECAUSE YOU
DON'T COLLECT THAT DATA. WOULD
THAT BE SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
A PATH TO REPRESENT THE
POPULATION THAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA? WE? WE AT PRESENT
HAVE A FOREIGN DENTAL SCHOOL IN
MEXICO. WHICH UNFORTUNATELY IS
GOING TO LOSE THEIR ABILITY TO
GIVE US DENTISTS TO BE LICENSED
BECAUSE OF ACCREDITATION REASONS
. LET ME LET ME EXPLAIN. PERHAPS
YOU'RE NOT AWARE OF IT. THIS HAS
BEEN AN ONGOING PROBLEM FOR
MANY, MANY YEARS. THIS IS NOT A
NEW ISSUE. UH OUR LAST SUNSET
BILL? UH, A B. UH, 5 1519 IN
2019 TRANSFERRED THE APPROVAL OF
DENTAL SCHOOLS TO ALLOW STUDENTS
WHO GRADUATE FROM THEM TO COME
AND TAKE OUR LICENSING PATHWAYS
TO GO OUT AND PRACTICE WHEREVER
THEY WANT, NOT NOT MANDATING IT,
BUT WHEREVER THEY WANT THAT THAT
BILL TRANSFERRED THE APPROVAL
PROCESS FROM THE DENTAL BOARD TO
THE AMERICAN DENTAL ASSOCIATION
COMMISSION ON DENTAL
ACCREDITATION. THE CODA AS IT'S
CALLED, WHICH IS THE U S¼
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
RECOGNIZED ACCREDITATION BODY
FOR DENTAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS
NOW PRIOR TO THEM HAVING
INTERNATIONAL PROGRAMS WHICH
HAVE ONLY BEEN AROUND FOR A FEW
YEARS. UH, THIS BOARD RECEIVED
APPLICATIONS. OUR BOARD RECEIVED
APPLICATIONS FROM A SCHOOL IN
MEXICO AND ONE IN MOLDOVA FOR
APPROVAL. AND SO THAT THEY CAN
ACCEPT STUDENTS AND THEN SEND
THEM BACK TO CALIFORNIA FOR
LICENSING TO DO WHATEVER OR TO
SEND THEM BACK WELL TO SEND THEM
BACK AT THAT TIME, KOTA DID NOT
HAVE INTERNATIONAL
ACCREDITATION. SO OUR MECHANISM
WAS TO TAKE THREE OR FOUR BOARD
MEMBERS AND OUTSIDE PEOPLE AND
SEND THEM IN THERE, USING
WHATEVER CRITERIA THEY COULD
FIND FROM CODA THAT WAS RELEASED
AND AVAILABLE AND WENT OUT AND
LOOKED AT THESE THESE PROGRA
MMES AND APPROVE THEM. UH THE
DENTAL BOARD DOES NOT HAVE THE
EXPERTISE TO DO ACCREDITATION.
WHICH IS A RIGOROUS PROCESS. I
AM A SITE VISITOR FOR CODA FOR
ORLA MAXWELL FACIAL SURGERY
PROGRAMS. IT IS A BIG THING TO
DO THESE THINGS AND A DENTAL
SCHOOL IS EVEN MORE MORE
IMPRESSIVE. SO IT'S USUALLY A
LARGE GROUP OF TRAINED EXAMINERS
WHO WILL GO IN AND LOOK AT IT
COULD BE 10 OR 12. PEOPLE COMING
IN LOOKING AT THE CURRICULUM,
THE DIFFERENT FORMS OF THE
CURRICULUM PARTS OF THE
CURRICULUM AND ALSO LOOKING AT
EDUCATIONAL PROCESSES, TO BE
SURE THAT THE PEOPLE COMING OUT
OF THERE LIVE AT THE SAME LEVEL
THAT THE PEOPLE COMING OUT ARE
66 DENTAL SCHOOLS DO. THERE A RE
ALTERNATE MEANS FOR IN
INTERNATIONALLY EDUCATED
DENTISTS TO COME UP AND PRACTICE
IF THEY WISH TO DO SO THEY THEY
THERE'S A TWO YEAR IT COSTS TWO
YEARS. I GET THAT THERE'S A TWO
YEAR PROGRAM IN FIVE OF THE SIX
DENTAL SCHOOLS IF THEY WISH TO
COME AND PRACTICE IN OUR IN OUR
STATE. FROM ANYWHERE THEY TAKE
THE EXAM. THEY QUALIFY THIS AND
THEN THEY 22 YEARS AND WHEN
THEY'RE ALL DONE, THEY HAVE THE
SAME Dð Dð S¼ DEGREE COMING
FROM, LET'S SAY U èC L A WHERE
I WAS FROM AND I. I HAVE THAT
WITH THE SAME DEGREE. SO THEN
THEY ARE FREE TO GO WHEREVER
THEY WISH. UH IT IS UNREASONABLE
TO THINK THAT THESE
INTERNATIONAL DE DENTAL PROGRAMS
SHOULD HAVE A PATHWAY FOR
APPROVAL THAT IS LESSER OR
DIMINISH FROM THAT WHICH THE
OTHER SCHOOLS HAVE TO GO
THROUGH. OUR BOARD TOOK AN
OPPOSED POSITION TO 1552 LAST
YEAR AND IS SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PROCESS THAT EXISTS TODAY, WITH
CODA BEING THE ACCREDITING BODY
FOR ALL SCHOOLS THAT SEND PEOPLE
TO CALIFORNIA. THAT'S THE BEST
WAY THAT WE CAN HOPE THAT
THEY'LL GET THE GOOD QUALITY
CARE THEY NEED, AND WE DON'T
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THE LESSER
ACCREDITATION PATHWAYS. THAT'S
WHY A CODE EXISTS. THANK YOU FOR
THAT CLARIFICATION FOR
ADDRESSING THAT. I'M NOT
FAMILIAR WITH, UH, CORA OR THIS
OTHER SCHOOLS. I MERELY JUST
TRYING TO FIND A WAY TO GET OUR
POPULATIONS TO BE SERVED. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT AND WE DO HAVE
WE HAVE AS AN JUST AN
ILLUSTRATION? WE DO HAVE, UH,
NÓ. WE HAVE THE STANDARDS WE
HAVE, UH, A S¼. DAKOTA HAS
ALREADY ACCREDITED SCHOOL IN
TURKEY AND A SCHOOL IN SAUDI
ARABIA. WHICH MEANS IN THEORY,
IF WE WANT TO SEND AMERICAN
STUDENTS THERE THEY CAN BE.
TRAIN THEIR COME BACK HERE AND
THEN THEY ARE ELIGIBLE LIKE ANY
OTHER DENTAL STUDENT COMING OUT
OF ANY ONE OF OUR SCHOOLS. WELL,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SENATOR
ROTH. YOU MENTIONED THE SCHOOL
IN MEXICO. I THOUGHT I READ IN
OUR BACKGROUND PAPER THAT THAT
SCHOOL PREVIOUSLY APPROVED BY
THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL BOARD, IS
CURRENTLY WINDING ITS WAY
THROUGH THE NATIONAL
ACCREDITATION PROCESS. IS THAT
NOT CORRECT? I DON'T KNOW. I
DON'T KNOW FOR SURE. AS I
UNDERSTAND IT. IT'S AND IT THIS
IS YOU KNOW, IT'S ANECDOTE. I
DON'T REALLY WANNA PUT THAT INTO
THE RECORD, BUT I DON'T KNOW IF
THEY ARE AT THIS POINT. WE HAVE
ASKED CODA AND MOLDOVA AND WE
HAVE NOT RECEIVED ANY. I'M SORRY
. MOLDOVA IS NOT SORRY, MEXICO.
I MEAN, WE HAVE WE HAVE ASKED
THEM AND THEY HAVE NOT, UM,
CONFIRMED THAT THEY ARE IN THE
APPROVAL OR THE PROCESS OF BEING
APPROVED. UM èC Dð CANNOT
RELEASE INFORMATION ON ANY OF
THE SCHOOLS THAT MAY HAVE
INITIATED THE PROCESS UNTIL IT
BECOMES PUBLIC. AND UM, WE HAVE
NOT RECEIVED CONFIRMATION WHEN
WE'VE WORKED WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS ON MEXICO. OK,
WELL, THAT ANSWERS THE QUESTION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COLLEAGUES? ON THE
COMMITTEE'S èC ASHBY. IS GOOD.
UH, ONE QUESTION. UM MAKE SURE I
GET THIS RIGHT. I'M CURIOUS TO
HEAR THE BOARD'S PERSPECTIVE, UH
, ON THE PROPOSAL THAT'S
DISCUSSED IN THE BACKGROUND
PAPER AROUND A LOT OF LICENSES
TO TAKE SOME OF THEIR CONTINUING
EDUCATION CO, UH, IN COURSES IN
MENTAL HEALTH AND WELLNESS. UM
YOU KNOW, I'M I FEEL STRONGLY
THAT BURNOUT IS A SERIOUS
PROBLEM. IN ALL THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONS AND AS WE'RE
CONSTANTLY DEBATING HOW WE CAN
INCREASE OUR HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE, WHICH IS SO IMPORTANT
WE CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO RISK
LOSING THE PROFESSIONALS WE
ALREADY HAVE BECAUSE OF
CHALLENGES TO THEIR MENTAL WELL
BEING, AS THE BOARD TAKEN A
POSITION ON THE CONCEPT OF
MENTAL HEALTH AND WELLNESS
COURSES COUNTING TOWARDS, UH,
CONTINUING EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS, AND ARE YOU OPEN
TO WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
TO PURSUE A PROPOSAL ALONG THOSE
LINES? UM THE BOARD HAS NOT
FORMALLY TAKEN A POSITION YET,
BUT WE ARE HOPING TO DO SO AT
THE MAY BOARD MEETING. UM WE
HAVE TALKED WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS AND DOCTOR FELSEN
FELD AND I AGREE THAT MENTAL
HEALTH IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
AND WE FEEL THAT IT WOULD BE, UM
, USEFUL TO HAVE IT CLARIFIED IN
OUR CONTINUING EDUCATION,
BECAUSE, AS YOU KNOW, OUR
CONTINUING EDUCATION IS BROKEN
UP IN TERMS OF, UH èC E THAT IS
DIRECTLY RELATED TO SERVICES.
THOSE THAT ARE ARE, UH, COURSES
THAT ARE, UH, LESS NOT AS
BENEFICIAL TO THE PROFESSIONAL
AND THEN THOSE THAT ARE
COMPLETELY BENEFICIAL TO THE
INDIVIDUAL, BUT NOT TO DENTAL
SERVICES. SO WE WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT IT IS CONSIDERED AS
BENEFICIAL TO THE TREATMENT OF
PATIENTS BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
IT'S SO IMPORTANT, UH, TO THINK
ABOUT OUR MENTAL HEALTH, AND
THAT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S INITIATIVE ON MENTAL
HEALTH, SO WE WOULD BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO WITH YOU ON THAT, UH,
POTENTIAL LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU. FANTASTIC. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. UH, AND CHAIR ASHBY.
SORRY I LIED TO YOU. WHEN I SAID
I DIDN'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. I
APOLOGIZE. ALL RIGHT. THIS ONE'S
MULTI LAYERED A LITTLE BIT.
YOU'RE PROGRAM IS OBVIOUSLY
QUITE LARGE IRRESPONSIBILITY, SO
THIS IS JUST ME SORT OF DIGGING
INTO THE WEEDS. DOES IT STILL
MAKE SENSE FOR SO MUCH OF YOUR
OPERATIONS TO INCLUDE MANAGING
THESE COMMITTEES OF LICENSES OR
INTERESTED PARTIES OR OTHER
INDIVIDUALS? WHAT'S THE VALUE?
ADD FOR EXAMPLE OF HAVING THE
LAYER OF A STATE MAINTAINED, UH,
DIVERSION EVALUATION COMMITTEE.
AND ARE THERE OTHER WAYS WE CAN
ASSIST DENTAL PROFESSIONALS WHO
ARE FACING VERY REAL SUBSTANCE
ABUSE CHALLENGES. WE BELIEVE
THAT OUR DIVERSION PROGRAM IS
ACTUALLY WORKING VERY WELL. SO
OUR DIVERSION COMMITTEE, UM
CONSISTS OF SEVERAL MEMBERS AND
A PROGRAM MANAGER IN THE BOARD,
AND WE WORK OUR PROGRAM MANAGER
WITH MAXIMUS. THAT IS THE CON,
UH, CONTRACTED VENDOR TO PROVIDE
MONITORING AND OVERSIGHT. SO
THERE'S A VERY SPECIFIC CRITERIA
FOR INDIVIDUALS THAT ENTER INTO
THE PROGRAM AND HOW THEY'RE
MONITORED. AND HOW THE PROCESS
IS TERMINATED. UH PART OF THE
MONITORING INVOLVES DRUG TESTING
AND REGULAR CONTACT TO ENSURE
THAT THEY ARE MEETING THEIR
PROBATIONARY REQUIREMENTS. AND
SO IF THERE IS ANY VIOLATIONS,
IT'S REPORTED TO THE BOARD SO
THAT WE CAN TAKE THE APPROPRIATE
DISCIPLINARY ACTION. SO WITH
REGARD TO, UH THAT THE DIVERSION
EVALUATION COMMITTEE, I WOULD
SAY IT'S VERY USEFUL AND VERY
SUCCESSFUL, AND WE HAVE A
COMMITTED THAT WORKS CLOSELY
WITH OUR PROGRAM MANAGER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WITH THAT. WE'RE
GONNA OPEN IT UP TO, UH, MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO HAVE COMMENTS
JUST A REMINDER. TWO MINUTES PER
ORGANIZATION AND WE'RE GONNA
WE'RE GOT TWO MORE BOARDS TO GET
THROUGH. SO WE'RE GONNA KEEP IT
AT A TIGHT TWO MINUTES. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RIGHT? UH, GOOD MEM.
GOOD MORNING, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND CHAIR BERMAN AND
CHAIR ASHBY. UH, MY NAME IS MARY
MCCUNE AND I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION.
WE'RE PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS BROUGHT
FORWARD TO THE DENTAL FROM THE
DENTAL BOARD TO THIS COMMITTEE
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS AROUND A LOT OF
THESE AROUND, UM, PATHWAYS TO
LICENSURE FOR OUT OF STATE
DENTISTS FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH,
CONTINUING EDUCATION, UM AND
CLEANING UP THE DENTAL
ANESTHESIA, PER PERMITTING
STRUCTURE. UM, WE'RE ALSO IN
SUPPORT, UM, WITH LIMITING THE
FOREIGN DENTAL SCHOOL APPROVAL
TO REALLY THE ENTITY THAT'S MOST
APPROPRIATE FOR THAT, WHICH IS
CODA CODA REGULATES THE SEVEN
DENTAL SCHOOLS HERE SIX SOON TO
BE SEVEN AND THE 66 OTHERS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY. UM THIS
ENSURES BOTH EQUALITY IN DENTAL
SCHOOL EDUCATION THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY AND PATIENT SAFETY.
WE'RE ALSO ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL FOR THE SUNSET
BILL TO EXPAND LICENSURE FOR
DENTAL ASSISTANCE THROUGH THE
PRECEPTORSHIP PATHWAY. UM AND WE
ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO LOOKING
AT THAT AND OTHER THINGS TO
BRING A MORE CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY DIVERSE POPULAR
WORKFORCE FROM DENTAL ASSISTING
ALL THE WAY THROUGH DENTISTS. UM
AND LASTLY, WE'RE ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE EXISTING
STRUCTURE OF THE DENTAL
ASSISTING COUNCIL. I KNOW THAT
THERE WERE TALKS ABOUT BOARD
COMPOSITION CHANGES. WE REALLY
THINK THAT THE DENTAL ASSISTING
COUNCIL ALLOWS FOR A MORE ROBUST
DISCUSSION, USING SEVERAL
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF EXPERTISE
AND PERMITS WITHIN THAT
WORKFORCE TO HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS WITHIN THE REGULATE
WITHIN THE REGULATORY BODY OF
THE DENTAL BOARD, RATHER THAN UM
, COMBINING THAT INTO ONE
ADDITIONAL PERSON ON THE DENTAL
BOARD. UM AND FOR THOSE REASONS
THAT STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
DENTAL BOARDS CONTINUED, UM,
REGULATORY AUTHORITY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING CHAIRS
AND MEMBERS. MY NAME IS MELODY
RANDOLPH AND I'M HERE,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF DENTAL ASSISTING
TEACHERS, THE DENTAL ASSISTANCE
ASSOCIATION AND THE EXTENDED
FUNCTIONS ASSOCIATION AND WE
SUPPORT THE EXTENSION OF THE
DENTAL BOARD. UH, FIRST, WE'D
LIKE TO NOTE THAT WE'RE VERY
PLEASED WITH THE WORK THAT
DOCTOR TRACY BON HAS DONE HIS
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE DENTAL
BOARD, WE HAVE FOUND HER TO BE
APPROACHABLE AND EAGER TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. UM THERE ARE THREE
ISSUES IN PARTICULAR. WE WANT TO
BRING TO YOUR ATTENTION. ONE HAS
ALREADY BEEN ADDRESSED IS THE,
UH, REPRESENT REPRESENTATION ON
THE BOARD. THERE IS ONE DENTAL
ASSISTANT ON THE BOARD,
REPRESENTING APPROXIMATELY
75,000 DENTAL ASSISTANTS. YET
THERE'S EIGHT DENTISTS
REPRESENTING APPROXIMATELY
35,000 DENTISTS. UM YOU CAN SEE
THAT INEQUITY AND THERE IS ALSO
STILL A HYGIENIST ON THE DENTAL
BOARD, EVEN THOUGH THE DENTAL
BOARD DOES NOT REGULATE
HYGIENISTS ANY LONGER. THEY HAVE
THEIR OWN BOARD SO WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST. UM THAT
YOU CONSIDER THIS INEQUITY AND
CHANGE THAT HYGIENE POSITION.
EXCUSE ME. TO A DENTAL ASSISTANT
. SECOND THE UNLICENSED DENTAL
ASSISTANTS, ALTHOUGH WE SUPPORT
AN ENTRY LEVEL WORKER FOR THE
DENTAL OFFICE, UH, WHO MAY
EVENTUALLY BECOME LICENSED
THROUGH A WORK PATHWAY, THE
UNLICENSED DENTAL ASSISTANT
CONTINUES TO BE A CONCERN AS THE
DENTAL BOARD HAS NÓ AUTHORITY
OVER THESE, UH, INDIVIDUALS WHO
TYPICALLY HAVE NÓ BACKGROUND IN
DENTISTRY, UM, YET THEY HAVE
DIRECT PATIENT TREATMENT
RESPONSIBILITIES. MANY R Dð. A
APPLICANTS HAVE BEEN DENIED
LICENSURE FOR VARIOUS CRIMINAL
ACTS, YET THEY CAN CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE TO PATIENTS AS AN
UNLICENSED DENTAL ASSISTANT. WE
REQUESTED THE DENTAL BOARD BE
DIRECTED TO RESEARCH AND DEVELOP
A TRACKING SYSTEM FOR THESE IN
UNLICENSED INDIVIDUALS AT
MINIMUM, REQUIRING REGISTRATION
WITH THE DENTAL BOARD IN THE
FORM OF BACKGROUND CHECKS. UM
THIS WOULD ALLOW FOR POTENTIAL
SCREENING AND TRACKING FOR
PATIENT PROTECTION. AND LASTLY,
UM, THE REGULATORY LANGUAGE
UPDATE A THOROUGH REVIEW OF THE
REGULATORY LANGUAGE REGARDING
DENTAL ASSISTING PRACTICE AND
EDUCATION STARTED IN 2014 AND
HAS YET TO BE COMPLETED. DOCTOR
MONTEZ IS INFORMED US THAT THEY
HAVE STARTED OVER WITH A REVIEW
OF THE ARTICLES OF CHAPTER
THREE. AND WE, UH, ARE
ENCOURAGED BY THIS NEWS. UM WE
REQUEST, HOWEVER, THAT THIS
COMMITTEE EMPHASIZED TO THE
BOARD THE NEED TO COMPLETE THIS
PROJECT WITH ATTENTION TO DETAIL
BUT ALSO IN A TIMELY MANNER
MANNER. TO RECTIFY THESE ISSUES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANKS. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
ASHBY AND CHAIR BERMAN. GARY
COOPER, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF ORAL
AND MAXILLOFACIAL SURGEONS. WE
CERTAINLY RECOMMEND THAT THE
DENTAL BOARD BE REINSTATED AND
BE RENEWED. UH JUST TALK TALKING
A COUPLE OF ISSUES NUMBER ONE IS
THE FIRST ISSUE THAT'S RAISED IN
THE BACKGROUND. UH, REPORT. UH,
WE BELIEVE THAT THE ELECTIVE
FACIAL COSMETIC SURGERY
CREDENTIALING COMMITTEE, UH,
SHOULD BE MAINTAINED. WE KNOW
THAT IT HAS BEEN SUGGESTED BY
THE DENTAL BOARD, UH, TO SUNSET
THAT WE BELIEVE FOR THE SAFETY
OF THE PUBLIC AND FOR THE
PROFESSIONALISM OF THE
PROFESSION THAT IT SHOULD BE
MAINTAINED AND KEPT IN STATUTE.
UH, THE SECOND ISSUE IS ITEM
NUMBER NINE DEALING WITH S¼, B
501 AND GENERAL ANESTHESIA. AS
YOU ALL KNOW, WE WERE VERY PROUD
TO BE THE SPONSORS OF S¼ P 501
IN 2017 AND 18, AND WE'RE VERY
HAPPY THAT IT HAS BECOME THE LAW
OF THE LAND. UH AND SO WE DID
INTRODUCE IN LIKE 2021 A BILL TO
MAKE THAT S¼ P 501 STATUTES AND
PROVISIONS WILL APPLY TO ADULTS.
WE CERTAINLY BELIEVE THAT TODAY
AND WE BELIEVE IT THEN AND WE
BELIEVE IT NOW WE BELIEVE THAT
JUST BECAUSE SOMEONE TURNS 13
YEARS THEY SHOULD HAVE. THEY
SHOULDN'T BE, YOU KNOW, FORCED
TO HAVE LESS SAFETY IN THE
DENTAL OFFICE THAN PEOPLE WHO
ARE UNDER 13. SO AT SOME POINT,
WE ARE CERTAINLY RECOMMENDING
THAT THE PROVISIONS OF S¼ P 501
BE, UH, ADDED TO THE ADULT
POPULATION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR ASHBY AND CHAIR
BERMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS JUANITA
CHÁVEZ. AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF DOLORES HUERTA
FOUNDATION AND ITS FOUNDER, MY
MOTHER, DOLORES HUERTA. AND I'M
HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE ISSUE OF
THE SHORTAGE OF DENTISTS IN
RURAL AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. UM AS, UH, DOCTOR
FELSEN FELD MENTIONED IF ONCE
THEY ARE GRADUATED, DENTISTS
WILL GO TO WHERE THE WORK IS
WHERE THE JOBS ARE, BUT WHAT WE
FIND FROM, UM THE DENTAL BOARD'S
OWN DATA IS THAT DENNIS WILL
TEND TO GO TO URBAN AREAS, SO WE
HAVE DATA FROM THE BOARD THAT
SHOWS AND I'M THERE SAID THEY
DON'T COLLECT DATA, SO I'M NOT
REALLY SURE HOW THEY CAME UP
WITH THIS DATA. BUT YOU KNOW,
SAN FRANCISCO HAS ONE DENTIST
FOR EVERY 710 RESIDENTS. ORANGE
COUNTY ONE DENTIST FOR EVERY, UH
774 RESIDENTS, WHEREAS YUBA
COUNTY HAS ONE DENTIST FOR EVERY
11,750, SIERRA COUNTY HAS NÓ
DENTIST IN THEIR COUNTY ALPINE
ZERO DENTIST. SO WE, YOU KNOW,
WANT TO REFUTE THE IDEA THAT
DENNIS STAR WAITING AND GOING TO
WHERE THE JOBS ARE, BECAUSE
REALLY, THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
THESE AREAS THAT ARE SO NEEDING
THEM. AND EVEN IN THE URBAN
AREAS, I'VE SUBMITTED LETTERS
FROM THREE ORGANIZATIONS IN THE
LOS ANGELES AREA AND URBAN AREA,
BUT THEY THEY WORK IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES, AND THEY'VE STATED
HOW CHALLENGING AND DIFFICULT IT
IS TO ATTRACT AND HIRE DENTISTS
TO SERVE THESE COMMUNITIES. SO
WE ARE SUPPORTING, UM, A B 2920
AUTHORED BY GÓMEZ REYES. BECAUSE
THE PRIOR ACCREDITATION OF
FOREIGN DENTAL SCHOOLS UNDER A B
1116 KEELEY IN 1998 SUCCESSFULLY
INCREASED ACCESS TO DENTIST AND
UNDERSERVED AREAS AND SHOULD
CONTINUE OVER 300. DENNIS
SUCCESSFULLY GRADUATED AND
BECAME LICENSED UNDER A B 116
AND MANY DEDICATED THEIR
PRACTICES TO PROVIDING DENTAL
CARE IN THESE UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. A B 2920 WOULD
ENSURE THAT THIS PIPELINE OF
QUALITY DENTAL PROFESSIONALS
CONTINUES TO BENEFIT THESE
COMMUNITIES. FOREIGN DENTAL
SCHOOLS ACCREDITED UNDER A B
1116 UNDERWENT RIGOROUS AND
METICULOUS REVIEW BY THE DENTAL
BOARD BEFORE RECEIVING
ACCREDITATION. AND IF YOU THAT'S
TWO MINUTES WE COULD WRAP UP.
THAT'D BE GREAT. THANKS. SO WE
KNOW THAT, UH, A B 1519 LOWS
REQUIREMENT PRETTY MUCH, UH,
TOOK AWAY THAT ENTIRELY ENDED
THIS PROGRAM AND WE KNOW THAT
CODAS TAKING 10 TO 12 YEARS TO,
UM, ACCREDIT ITS, UH, UH, TO
BECOME FOR THEIR SCHOOLS TO
BECOME ACCREDITED. SO WE JUST
LIKE TO SAY THAT, UM WE WANNA,
YOU KNOW, SUPPORT A B 2920 THAT
THE DENTAL BOARD CONTINUED TO
HAVE THAT RESPONSIBILITY. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, EVERYONE. MY
NAME IS ANNA MARIA QUINTANA. I'M
VICE MAYOR FOR THE CITY OF BELL.
I COME BEFORE YOU TO ALSO
RECOMMEND THAT THE DENTAL BOARD
BE RENEWED RELICENSED. UM, THAT
BEING SAID, I DO WANT TO, UM,
ASK THE MEMBERS OF THE BOARD TO
SUPPORT HAVING THE DENTAL BOARD
REINSTATE THE APPROVAL PROCESS
FOR DENTAL SCHOOLS. FOREIGN
DENTAL SCHOOLS SPECIFICALLY, MY
COMMUNITY IS 49% FOREIGN BORN
LANGUAGE IS VERY, VERY LIMITED,
AND STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT
HAVING CULTURALLY COMPETENT, UM
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS JUST
IMPROVES THE QUALITY OF SERVICES
. THE REASON WHY, UM, I
CHALLENGE THE DENTAL BOARDS
AUTHORITY TO NOT DO THIS IS
BECAUSE WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
CODA CODA UNDERTOOK THE PROCESS
OF ACCREDITING FOREIGN DENTAL
SCHOOLS AT THE REQUEST OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE PURPOSE
OF THE DENTAL BOARD IS EXACTLY
THAT TO RENEW TO REGULATE THE
PROFESSION IF WE AS A STATE FIND
THAT THERE IS A SHORTAGE OF
CULTURALLY COMPETENT ATTORNEY.
UM SORRY, DENTIST. I'M AN
ATTORNEY. SO SLIP OF THE TONGUE
HERE, UM WE HAVE A DUTY TO FIX
THAT. NEED THE REASON WHY, UM, I
THINK THE DENTAL BOARD IS ALSO
CAPABLE OF DOING THAT, AND IT'S
KIND OF ESSENTIAL THAT THE
DENTAL BOARD TAKE ON THAT TASK
IS THAT THE CODE APPROVAL
PROCESS TAKES 10 TO 12 YEARS IN
A FOREIGN CONTEXT, STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN IN THE RECORD SHOWS THAT
WHEN THEY STARTED, THIS PROCESS
WAS IN 2007. WHEN THE DENTAL
BOARD MAKE THAT REQUEST, AND AS
OF DATE, AND DOCTOR MONTEZ IS
CORRECT, AND THEY ARE TWO
SCHOOLS, BUT THAT TOOK 10 TO 12
YEARS TO ASK MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES, RER. COMMUNITIES TO
WAIT 1210 TO 12 YEARS TO HAVE A
SCHOOL TO CREATE A PIPELINE THAT
SERVICES OUR COMMUNITIES. I
THINK IT'S UNCALLED FOR, UM, THE
10. THE APPROVAL PROCESS FOR THE
DENTAL BOARD WAS 2 TO 3 YEARS.
SO TO FINISH THE RECOMMENDATION,
I WOULD ECHO UM SENATOR ROTH'S
WORDS IS TO LEAVE THE POLITICS
ASIDE AND COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION WHERE IN WHICH WE CAN
PROVIDE SERVICES FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES. IT IS ESSENTIAL IT
IS, UM THE PANDEMIC HAS A WHOLE
HIGHLIGHTED. THAT EXIST, SO WE
HAVE THE RESOURCES AND IF WE'RE
NOT, WE NEED TO HAVE A DUTY TO
PROVIDE THEM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, JUST TO HIGHLIGHT VERY
QUICKLY BECAUSE YOU'RE TOO
REALLY QUICKLY SINCE WE DID TALK
ABOUT EARLIER ABOUT RESOURCES,
REINSTATING THE DENTAL BOARDS
AUTHORITY TO APPROVE FOREIGN
DENTAL SCHOOLS WOULD NOT BE A
BURDEN ON THE STATE BECAUSE THE
COST ENTIRELY WILL BE BORNE BY
THE APPLICANT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANKS. ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS. GOT A COUPLE DOWN HERE
FROM, UH, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE DOCTOR. EGG MEN, AND
THEN WE'LL GO TO SENATOR ROTH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. UH, THANK
YOU. UM CAN YOU RESPOND TO SOME
OF THOSE COMMENTS JUST ABOUT YOU
KNOW, I MEAN, WE KNOW, RIGHT?
WE'VE COVERED DEEPLY BOTH BOTH
BY ACCESS. UH IN IN EVERYONE OF
THESE OVERSIGHT HEARINGS. WE DO
RIGHT. UH AND SO WE KNOW THE
ABILITY TO PROVIDE DENTAL CARE,
AND WE KNOW ALL THE IMPACTS ON
THAT FOR EDUCATION AND SCHOOLS.
SO CAN YOU SPEAK TO THIS A
LITTLE BIT, AND THEN, EVEN LIKE
WHERE DID THE DENTIST THAT WERE
APPROVED? GO. A RE. THEY CAN
THEY COME BACK? IT IT'S
DIFFICULT TO TRACK WHERE ALL OF
THEM GO. I CAN I CAN TALK TO
YOU. ANECDOTALLY I'VE SPENT MOST
OF MY CAREER TEACHING AT U èC L
A AND I WAS DEALING WITH THE
DENTIST FROM FOREIGN COUNTRIES
WHO TOOK THE TWO YEAR PROGRAM.
AND THEY DID NOT GO INTO THEIR
CATCHMENT AREA AS IT WERE FROM
WHERE THEY WERE FROM WHERE THE
PEOPLE ARE. THOSE ARE THOSE
PEOPLE. EXCUSE ME, MR. CHAIR, I.
I MEAN, I II. I DON'T THINK WHEN
PEOPLE ARE TALKING WITH DATA
THAT THAT WE SHOULD GO BACK TO
ANECDOTES. THAT'S I. I WOULD
AGREE WITH YOU COMPLETELY. THE I
THINK THE POINT IS THE CREATION
OR THE APPROVAL PROCESS THAT WAS
DONE BY THE BOARD BACK THEN, WAS
NOT NEARLY AS RIGOROUS AS IT IS
WHEN IT'S DONE BY èC Dð. SO
WE'RE GIVING THEM A LESSER
ACCREDITATION OR APPROVAL
PROCESS, THEN WOULD BE NECESSARY
FOR THE SIX NOW TO BE SEVEN
DENTAL SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE TO GO THROUGH. I CAN'T SEE
THE EQUITY THERE. DON'T WE HAVE
WE HAVE DOCTORS, THOUGH, FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES WHO HAVE GONE
TO, UH, MEDICAL SCHOOLS IN OTHER
PLACES, CORRECT. WE DO, BUT
THEY'VE BEEN LICENSED THROUGH
VARIOUS MECHANISMS. RIGHT, AND
SO EN CODA CAN'T SET UP A
SIMILAR PROCESS. LIKELY NOT, BUT
WE CAN'T SPEAK FOR CODA. I WANNA
CLARIFY TOO. CODA WASN'T SET UP
AS AS A RESULT OF CALIFORNIA
AGAIN. THE U S¼ DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HAS DESIGNATED CODA AS
THE CREATION FOR DENTAL SCHOOLS
IN THE UNITED STATES, AND IT'S A
CHOICE WHETHER OR NOT SCHOOLS
CHOOSE TO BE CODA APPROVED.
THERE'S CODE APPROVED SCHOOLS IN
CAÑADA. THEY'RE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES AGAIN. WE HAVE TWO THE
AMOUNT OF TIME IF IT'S IN U S¼
IN THE UNITED STATES, IT'S GOING
TO BE LESS BECAUSE A LOT OF OUR
TEACHING IN OUR SCHOOLS ARE VERY
SIMILAR IN STANDARDS AND SO
FORTH. IT DOES TAKE LONGER FOR
INTERNATIONAL SCHOOLS BECAUSE
THERE'S THERE ARE MORE THINGS
THERE'S THE TIME THE DISTANCE
THINGS LIKE THAT. BUT REALLY, IT
COMES DOWN TO THE COMPLETING THE
APPLICATION, SETTING UP THE
APPOINT, PROVIDING THE MATERIALS
. IT'S A PROCESS THAT'S
ITERATIVE. IT GOES BACK AND
FORTH. SO WHEN YOU SAY 10 TO 12
YEARS AND SPEAKING WITH CODA.
THEY WILL NOT GIVE YOU A
SPECIFIED TIME FRAME. I TRIED TO
DO THAT, AND THEY SAID NÓ
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MANY
VARIABLES THAT ARE INVOLVED, BUT
THE FACT IS, IS THAT THERE ARE
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE GOTTEN
APPROVED THROUGH èC Dð. AND UH,
WE HAVE WE RECOGNIZE THEM AS
AUTHORITY AND AS DOCTOR FELSEN,
FELD SAID. IT'S THE STANDARDS
FOR HEALTH AND SAFETY AND
PATIENT PROTECTION. YOU KNOW,
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE TO KEEP IN
MIND IS THAT, UM IF WE WERE TO
GO BACK TO THE DENTAL S¼, UH,
BOARD DOING THIS? WE DON'T HAVE
THE EXPERTISE TO FULLY ENSURE
THAT ALL OF THOSE STANDARDS ARE
MET. THAT'S WHY WE LEAVE IT TO
PROFESSIONALS WHO DO
ACCREDITATION. THANK YOU. DO AND
WHILE THAT WAS IN EFFECT WHILE
YOU YOU WERE OVERSEEING IT WERE
WERE THERE WHAT PROBLEMS AROSE.
IT'S HARD TO. IT'S HARD TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION. UH,
PROBLEMS WOULD COME WITH, UH,
POOR PATIENT CARE, COMPA PATIENT
COMPLAINTS? UH, IF THE NUMBER
300 IS ACCURATE, AND I'M NOT
SURE THAT THAT'S REALLY TRUE.
THERE'S STILL 43,000 DENTISTS IN
THIS STATE. UH, IT'S A VERY
SMALL PORTION OF THE DENTIST
HAVE COME THROUGH THESE
PATHWAYS. THAT PREVIOUSLY
EXISTED, SO IT'S GOING TO BE
HARD TO DETERMINE HOW BADLY OR
HOW WELL THEY'RE PERFORMING. UH,
IT'S NOT THE DATA WOULD NOT
SUPPORT THAT. AND WE DON'T
PROVIDE THAT DATA LIKE WE DON'T
SAY THIS PERSON GRADUATED FROM
THIS SCHOOL, AND NOW THEY HAVE
DISCIPLINARY ACTION. ONCE YOU'VE
GRADUATED AND BECOME LICENSED,
THAT'S IT. WE'RE NOT LOOKING AT.
YOU KNOW, THE BACKGROUND WE'RE
LOOKING AT. YOU MET THE
REQUIREMENTS YOU'RE OUT
PRACTICING, AND IF THERE IS AN
ISSUE, IT WOULD COME THROUGH A
COMPLAINT AND THE DISCIPLINARY
PROCESS. I. I GUESS I'M STILL I
MEAN, I. I HEAR WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING. AND IT SOUNDS LIKE WE'RE
TALKING A LOT ABOUT ANECDOTES
BECAUSE SOMEBODY WHO REPRESENTS
RURAL AREA WE KNOW THE PROBLEMS
THAT RESULT FROM LACK OF ACCESS.
SO THIS IS THE PATHWAY TO
ACCESS. AND YOU'RE SAYING
ANECDOTALLY, YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT
SURE IF IT WORK. WE'RE NOT SURE
IF IT DIDN'T WORK, BUT BUT WE
OFFER NOTHING IN IN ITS PLACE.
WELL IT WORKED IN THAT IT GAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR INDIVIDUALS
TO GO THROUGH THAT SCHOOL AND
GRADUATE, BUT TO CONTINUE TO
ALLOW THAT IS PROBLEMATIC FROM
THE BOARD'S PERSPECTIVE, BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
OFFER ACCREDITATION. IT WAS A
TEMPORARY FIX FOR A REQUEST. AND
ONCE THE APPROVAL WAS MADE FOR
THOSE TWO SCHOOLS. DURING THE
TIME THAT THAT WAS HAPPENING,
THEN CODA WAS ESTABLISHED. SO
èC Ó Dð WAS NOT ESTABLISHED.
SO WE DID. THE BOARD DID APPROVE
THOSE SCHOOLS. BUT NOW WE HAVE
CODA AND GIVEN THAT WE DON'T
HAVE THE EXPERTISE, THAT'S THE
SITUATION, BUT WE DON'T TRACK
YOU KNOW, LICENSES, YOU KNOW, TO
SEE HOW THEY DO OR DON'T AGAIN.
THEY'VE MET THE BAR. THEY'VE
THEY'VE BECOME LICENSED. AND
THEN THEY'RE OUT TO, YOU KNOW,
DO THEIR PRACTICE. AND I. I GREW
UP IN A RURAL AREA JUST SOUTH OF
A COMMENT AND THEN A COUPLE OF
REQUESTS. MAYBE ARE MATERIAL
INDICATES THAT WHEN IN 2019 WHEN
THE SUNSET BILL TRANSFERRED THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR APPROVAL FROM
THE DENTAL BOARD, DAKOTA THE
SCHOOL IN MEXICO DID NOT OPPOSE
BECAUSE THEY WERE CURRENTLY
INVOLVED OR THEN INVOLVED IN THE
CODE, A ACCREDITATION PROCESS
JUST TO CLARIFY THE ORIGINAL
QUESTION THAT I ASKED SO I GUESS
. ONE REQUEST IS TO SEE IF WE
CAN GET THE STATUS ON THAT. CODE
ACCREDITATION PACKAGE FROM THE
SCHOOL IN MEXICO. TWO I ASSUME
THAT YOU KEEP TRACK OF YOUR
DENTISTS BY PRACTICE LOCATION
AND AT LEAST IF YOU'RE LIKE
LAWYERS THEY TRACK THEY HAVE A
DATABASE THAT TRACKS WHERE WE
GOT OUR WE RECEIVED OUR LAW
DEGREE. SO I'D LIKE YOU ALL TO,
UM SEE IF YOU CAN TELL US WHERE
THE DENTIST WHO GRADUATED FROM
THE SCHOOL IN MEXICO. HAVE
PRACTICED OR ARE CURRENTLY
PRACTICING. TWO. NUMBER TWO AND
THEN REQUEST NUMBER THREE. YOU
KNOW, YEARS AGO WE DID A PROGRAM
FOR PHYSICIANS TO TRY TO
ENCOURAGE PHYSICIANS TO SERVE IN
MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED AREAS.
PHYSICIANS FROM MEXICO TOOK US A
LONG TIME TO GET THAT PROGRAM UP
AND RUNNING. THANKS TO MY
COLLEAGUES, PERHAPS THE ONE TO
MY RIGHT AND OTHERS FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. THE PROGRAM IS
SEEMS TO BE MOVING NOW. I'D LIKE
FOR YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT
WHETHER THAT SORT OF PRO COULD
ALSO WORK FOR DENTISTS AND WHAT
IT WOULD TAKE TO IMPLEMENT THAT
PROGRAM IN OUR, UM DENTAL
UNDERSERVED AREAS OF THE STATE
THREE REQUESTS HAPPY TO DO SO. I
KNOW THAT'S THE MEXICO PILOT
PROJECT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU, MR CHAIR. THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS FROM COLLEAGUES. SEEING
NONE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE THE VERY ROBUST AND
IMPORTANT CONVERSATIONS. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE BOARD
FOR PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS, LAND
SURVEYORS AND GEOLOGISTS. THE
NEXT ITEM ON OUR AGENDA IS THE
BOARD FOR PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS
, LENS AND GEOLOGISTS. WE SHOULD
HAVE MICHAEL HARTLEY, CHRISTINA
WONG AND RICK MOORE HERE WITH US
TODAY, AND I UNDERSTAND  N.
NANCY EISLER, UH, IS NOT ABLE TO
ATTEND. BUT WHENEVER THE FOLKS
ARE WHO ARE HERE, PLEASE? UH, GO
AHEAD. WE'RE READY FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
AND MAYBE JUST HIT THE BUTTON ON
THE MIC. THERE YOU GO. HOW ABOUT
NOW? PERFECT. ALL RIGHT. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRS AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEES AND STAFF. MY
NAME IS MICHAEL HARTLEY. I AM
THE PROFESSIONAL LAND SURVEYOR
MEMBER ON THE BOARD AND THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT. WITH ME TODAY
ARE CHRISTINA WONG, WHO IS A
PUBLIC MEMBER AND IS ALSO VICE
PRESIDENT. UH AND RICK MOORE,
OUR EXECUTIVE OFFICER. WE
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE AN UPDATE TO THE
COMMITTEES ON THE ACTIVITIES OF
THE BOARD DURING THE LAST FIVE
YEARS, AS WELL AS PRESENT OUR
IDEAS AND THOUGHTS ON THIS
SUNSET REVIEW. I'LL BE SPEAKING
ON THE HISTORY OF THE BOARD ITS
CURRENT MAKEUP AND AN
INTRODUCTION OF THE BOARD'S
ONLINE CONNECT SYSTEM. OUR
EXECUTIVE OFFICER, RICK MOORE
WILL FOLLOW WITH MORE DETAIL ON
THE CONNECT SYSTEM ADDRESS. SOME
OF THE ISSUES PRESENTED BY THE
BACKGROUND PAPER AND CHRISTINA
WONG WILL WRAP THINGS UP. THE
ORIGINS OF THE BOARD DATE BACK
TO 1891. WHEN LAND SURVEYORS
WERE FIRST REGULATED IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATION.
REGULATION OF PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS BEGAN IN 1929
FOLLOWING THE EARLY MORNING
COLLAPSE OF THE SAINT FRANCIS
DAM, WHICH CAUSED A DISASTROUS
FLOOD ALONG THE SANTA CLARA
RIVER AS IT COURSED THROUGH LOS
ANGELES AND VENTURA COUNTIES.
THE EVENT CLAIMED THE LIVES OF
OVER 400 INDIVIDUALS, DESTROYING
MANY HOMES AND FARMS. UH, IT IS
STILL CONSIDERED ONE OF THE
WORST AMERICAN CIVIL ENGINEERING
DISASTERS OF THE 20TH CENTURY
AND THE THIRD GREATEST LOSS OF
LIFE IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY. UM
AFTERWARDS. OTHER BRANCHES OF
ENGINEERS WERE ADDED THROUGH THE
ENSUING YEARS AND THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE FORMER
BOARD OF GEOLOGISTS AND
GEOPHYSICISTS WAS MERGED WITH
OUR BOARD BY THE LEGISLATURE AS
A RESULT OF THE BUDGET CRISIS
FROM 2009. TODAY THE BOARD DOES
SEVERAL THINGS, UM, REGULATES
ALMOST 100 AND 90,000
INDIVIDUALS, THE MAJORITY OF
WHICH ARE LOCATED IN CALIFORNIA,
WITH SOME DISPERSED THROUGHOUT
THE UNITED STATES AND AROUND THE
WORLD. UM THE BOARD ISSUES AN
AVERAGE OF 5500 NEW CERTIFICATES
AND LICENSES ANNUALLY. DEVELOPS
AND ADMINISTERS OVER 4800 STATE
EXAMS ANNUALLY PROCESSES A
VOLUME OF OVER 6500 APPLICATIONS
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS PRIMARILY
THROUGH THE BOARDS RECENTLY
IMPLEMENTED ONLINE CONNECT
SYSTEM. THE BOARD IS MANDATED TO
SAFEGUARD THE LIFE HEALTH,
PROPERTY AND PUBLIC WELFARE BY
REGULATING THE PRACTICES OF
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERING, LAND,
SURVEYING, GEOLOGY AND
GEOPHYSICS. THE BOARD QUALIFIES
AND LICENSES. INDIVIDUALS
ESTABLISHES REGULATIONS ENFORCES
LAWS AND REGULATIONS, AND THE
BOARD HELPS THE PUBLIC MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS. THERE ARE 15
BOARD MEMBERS CONSISTING OF FIVE
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS, ONE
LICENSED LAND SURVEYOR. THAT'D
BE ME. ONE PROFESSIONAL
GEOLOGIST AND EIGHT PUBLIC
MEMBERS. ALL APPOINTMENTS TO THE
BOARD ARE FOR A TERM OF FOUR
YEARS, AND THERE ARE CURRENTLY
TWO VACANCIES. INTERESTINGLY UH,
THE BOARD HAS EXPERIENCED
CONSIDERABLE TURNOVER AND ONLY
ONE THIRD OF THE CURRENT MEMBERS
ON THE BOARD WERE A PART OF THE
LAST SUNSET REVIEW. UH, AS A
RESULT OF AN EXTENSIVE MULTI
YEAR BUSINESS MODERNIZATION
EFFORT, THE BOARD RESPONDED TO
THE UNIQUE CHALLENGES FACED
DURING THE PANDEMIC BY LAUNCHING
THE FIRST OF MANY PHASES OF THE
CONNECT SYSTEM IN SEPTEMBER OF
2020. PRIMARY GOAL WAS AND STILL
IS TO PROVIDE A MORE EFFICIENT
INCONSISTENT SERVICE TO THE
PEOPLE WHO NEED TO CONDUCT
BUSINESS WITH THE BOARD. AS A
LICENSEE MYSELF. I CAN SAY THAT
I'VE USED THE CONNECT SYSTEM TO
RENEW MY LICENSE. IT WAS VERY
INTUITIVE, AND, UH, REALLY MADE
THE RENEWAL PROCESS. PAINLESS.
UM WHILE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
CONNECT SYSTEM CONTINUES TO
EVOLVE FROM THE INITIAL 2020
SUCCESS, THE BOARD RECOGNIZES
THAT MORE EFFORT IS NEEDED
TOWARDS ACHIEVING THE ORIGINAL
GOAL AND IS COMMITTED TO
PROACTIVELY ADDRESSING FEEDBACK
PROVIDED BY ITS USERS. I'D LIKE
TO ASK EXECUTIVE OFFICER RICK TO
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL DETAIL.
GOOD MORNING. SO WHEN THE BOARD
TRANSITION FROM THE FORMER
DOWNLOAD THE APPLICATION
COMPLETED BY HAND. MAIL THAT IN
WITH ALL THE INFORMATION FROM
YOUR REFERENCES TO A COMPLETELY
ONLINE SYSTEM THAT COULD BE
ACCESSED 24 7 ANYWHERE IN THE
WHOLE ENTIRE POST PANDEMIC
WORLD. UH, WE ENTER IN
UNDERESTIMATED THE POPULARITY OF
THAT. AND, UH, SOME OF THE SOME
OF THE REASONS THAT WE HAD, UH,
WE CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING, UH,
THAT IS HE HINDERING US FROM
MEETING REACHING OUR ULTIMATE
GOAL FOR PROVIDING THE BEST
SERVICE IS KIND OF A TOO MUCH OF
A GOOD THING. TYPE OF SITUATION.
WE DO A CUSTOMER SATISFACTION
SURVEY AS A RESPONSES FROM OUR
USERS ON THE SYSTEM, AND WHILE
WE RECEIVE A RESPECTABLE 4.5 OUT
OF FIVE RATING ON THAT, WHEN WE
DRILL A LITTLE BIT DEEPER INTO
THAT THOSE RESPONSES AND THE
FEEDBACK THE USERS OF THE SYSTEM
THAT ARE SUBMITTING INITIAL
APPLICATIONS FOR LICENSURE. HAVE
A LESS A LESSER SATISFACTION
RATE. WE BELIEVE THAT'S
PRIMARILY DUE TO THE MUCH LARGER
VOLUME OF APPLICATIONS THAT WE
ARE NOW RECEIVING. WE LITERALLY
WE COULD OUR STAFF COULD START
STOP WORK AT THE END OF THE DAY
AND COME IN THE NEXT MORNING,
AND THERE'S ANOTHER 100 150
APPLICATIONS IN A PIPELINE. UM
SO IT'S KIND OF AN INTERESTING
SITUATION. UH, WE MORE
PARTICULARLY WITH THE
ENGINEERING AND CIVIL
ENGINEERING APPLICATIONS. WE'VE
SEEN AN ALMOST 70% INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS THAT
ARE COMING IN, AND SOME OF THOSE
ARE, UM NOT AS COMPLETE AS THEY
WOULD HAVE BEEN IN THE PAST AND
THAT HAS LED TO US RE EVALUATING
HOW WE NEED TO ADDRESS THOSE
SITUATIONS. WE HAVE NOTICED THAT
THE PEAK OF THAT VOLUME HAS
PASSED US AND WE'RE STARTING TO
TRIM. DOWN TO A LITTLE BIT MORE
OF THE LEVELS WE ANTICIPATED. SO
WHAT WE'VE DONE IS WE'VE KIND
OF, UH, REDEDICATED OUR STAFF
INTERNALLY TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THAT SITUATION AND WE ARE SLOWLY
CHIPPING AWAY AT THE BACKLOG IS
WHICH WE REFER TO IT, AND WE'RE
HOPING BY THE END OF SUMMER
EARLY FALL THAT WE WILL BE DOWN
TO THE MORE MANAGEABLE LEVELS WE
EXPECT TO ANOTHER ANOTHER.
RESULT OF GOING ONLINE WITH THE
SYSTEM AGAIN IS WE ALSO HAD
COMPLAINTS TO MENTALS GO THROUGH
THE NEW CONNECT SYSTEM AGAIN
COMPLAINTS 24 7 FROM ANYWHERE IN
THE WORLD. WE'RE RECEIVING FAR
MORE COMPLAINTS THAN WE EVER
USED TO IN THE OLD IN THE OLD
METHOD. UH, MANY OF THOSE ARE
NOT WITHIN THE BOARD'S
JURISDICTION. UH, MANY OF THEM
ARE NOT, UH, SUBMITTING COMPLETE
INFORMATION THAT ALLOWS US TO
ACTUALLY COMMENCE THE
INVESTIGATION. SO OUR BOARD IS
WORKING TO IMPROVE THE
COMMUNICATION AT THE COMPLETE,
UH, COMPLAINT SUBMIT LEVEL TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THAT AND HELP
MITIGATE THAT SO BECAUSE THAT IS
AFFECTED OUR TIMELINES DOWN THE
LINE WITH OUR INVESTIGATIONS.
WE'VE ALSO NOTICED THAT, UM
SWITCHING OVER TO OUR PHONE
CONDITION. OUR REVENUES HAVE
SPORADICALLY REMAINED. PRETTY
CONSISTENT THROUGH THE YEAR.
SINCE THE LAST SUNSET, HOWEVER,
EXPENDITURES HAVE INCREASED
PRIMARILY DUE TO STATE SALARY.
EXPENSES AND, UH, STATE
ADMINISTRATION COST SO THAT HAS
RESULTED IN A FUN CONDITION THAT
IS REACHING THE LIMITS OF WHAT
OUR REVENUE IS ALLOWING US TO DO
. SO WHAT WE'VE ALREADY DONE IS
WE'VE COMMENCED. UH
UNCONDITIONED OR A BUDGET
ANALYSIS AND A FEE SCHEDULE
ANALYSIS. UH, INTERNALLY WITH
OUR OFFICE WITH Dð èC A BUDGETS
AND WE ARE WE'RE VERY MUCH
UNDERNEATH OUR STATUTORY LIMITS
FOR OUR FEES, SO WE'RE ABLE TO,
UH IF WE NEED TO ADJUST THOSE
FEES, WHICH WE HOPE TO PRESENT
TO OUR BOARD LATER THIS SUMMER.
WE UH, WOULD EXPECT TO BE GOING
THAT THROUGH THE RULE MAKING
PROCESS. AND WE WOULD EXPECT
THAT WOULD BE A TARGET DAY,
PROBABLY JANUARY, 2026 IF THE
FEES DID CHANGE. OKAY WITH THAT.
I WOULD LIKE TO PASS IT ON TO
MISS WONG AS A PUBLIC MEMBER. WE
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE
FOR HER TO BRIEFLY ADDRESS SOME
OF THE PUBLIC COMMUNICATIONS
INFORMATION. GOOD MORNING. UM
THE BOARD PRIMARILY COMMUNICATES
WITH CONSUMERS, APPLICANTS,
LICENSEES AND STAKEHOLDERS
THROUGH MULTIPLE AVENUES
INVOLVING ELECTRONIC
COMMUNICATIONS BOARD MEETINGS,
ONLINE PUBLICATIONS AND SOCIAL
MEDIA POSTS BOTH VIRTUALLY AND
IN PERSON. WHILE THE BOARD HAS
MAINTAINED A POLICY OF HOLDING
PUBLIC BOARD MEETINGS AT VARIOUS
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE,
IT IS RECOGNIZED THAT A HYBRID
ACCESSIBILITY APPROACH BY ADDING
THE VIRTUAL MEETING OPTION
ENCOURAGES MANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ACROSS ALL DEMOGRAPHICS
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE MEETINGS.
MUCH OF THE BOARD'S LICENSING
AND ENFORCEMENT OUTREACH IS
PERFORMED BY LICENSE STAFF
MEMBERS AND THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER. UH, THROUGH BOTH
VIRTUAL AND IN PERSON WORKSHOPS.
THE BOARD INITIATES
COMMUNICATION WITH APPLICANTS,
LICENSES AND REPRESENTATIVES OF
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE ON A REGULAR BASIS.
THE BOARD'S MOST RECENT
STRATEGIC PLAN, DELINEATES THE
OUTREACH OBJECTIVES IN RELATING
TO DIVERSITY. EQUITY AND
INCLUSION. SPORTS STAFF ARE
IDENTIFYING WAYS TO EXPAND ON
THE DELIVERY OF AWARENESS AND
EDUCATION ABOUT OUR MISSION AND
LICENSING TO UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WITH THAT I'LL
OPEN UP TO COLLEAGUES, QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. I'VE GOT A COUPLE.
I'LL GET STARTED. AND THEN IF
OTHER FOLKS HAVE ANY, UH, FEEL
FREE TO JUMP IN, SO I KNOW A BIG
ISSUE OF CONCERN HAS BEEN
UNLICENSED ACTIVITY. UH HOW MANY
COMPLAINTS RECEIVED BY THE BOARD
ARE RELATED TO UNLICENSED
ACTIVITY AND RELATEDLY. WHAT
PORTION OF INVESTIGATIONS
CONCLUDE THAT IN LICENSED
ACTIVITY IS INDEED OCCURRING.
UM, AND THEN I MIGHT ASK A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION OR TWO. WELL,
LET'S START THERE. YES UM,
UNLESS I UNLICENSED ACTIVITY HAS
LONG BEEN A CONCERN FOR OUR
BOARD. UH, WE THAT'S PROBABLY
ONE OF THE AREAS THAT WE MORE
COMMONLY COLLABORATE WITH OUR
PROFESSIONAL SOCIETIES. UH IT'S
A CONCERN FOR THEM. IT'S A
CONCERN FOR US. FROM THE
CONSUMER POINT OF VIEW. I DON'T
HAVE EXACT NUMBERS, BUT I WOULD
SAY THE UNLICENSED. UH MOST OF
OUR COMPLAINTS ARE RELATED TO
LAND SURVEY AND CIVIL
ENGINEERING. UH, MOST, UH, I
WOULD SAY THE UNLICENSED ASPECTS
OF THAT ARE PROBABLY EASILY 25
TO 30% OF THOSE COMPLAINTS. UM
OUR LICENSEES. ARE VERY
SUSCEPTIBLE TO PRACTICES THAT
THEY DO ARE VERY SUSCEPTIBLE TO
ADVANCEMENTS IN TECHNOLOGY. IT'S
KIND OF A TWO EDGED SWORD WITH
OUR LICENSEES. IT'S A GOOD
THING. IT HELPS THEM DO THE WORK
THAT THEY DO THAT'S VERY
VALUABLE TO THE CONSUMERS. ON
THE OTHER HAND, SOMETIMES IT
MAKES IT MUCH EASIER FOR
UNLICENSED PEOPLE TO DO THAT
WORK, TOO, AND THAT'S WHERE
COLLECTIVELY WE'RE ALL
STRUGGLING WITH THAT, AND FOR
UNLICENSED ACTIVITY. UH UH.
UNLICENSED. FOLKS TO DO THAT
ACTIVITY POORLY. I WOULD SAY
POORLY. YES UH, IN MANY WAYS,
THEY DON'T REALLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND.
RIGHT UH, HOW DOES THE BOARD'S
ENFORCEMENT UNIT COMPARE TO
COMPARABLE LICENSING ENTITIES?
HAVE YOU LOOKED AT OTHERS? THIS
THE BEST PRA PRACTICES OR I
WOULD SAY, UM WELL, I KNOW THAT
OUR ENFORCEMENT STAFF REGULAR
COMMUNICATES WITH OTHER
ENFORCEMENT STAFF WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA, BUT WE ALSO
WANT A NATIONAL LEVEL. OUR
ENFORCEMENT MANAGER IS PART OF A
COMMIT ENFORCEMENT COMMITTEE
WITH OTHER ENGINEERING SURVEY
AND BOARDS ACROSS THE NATION AND
REGULARLY COMMUNICATES. UH, WE
DO PROBABLY HAVE A HIGHER VOLUME
OF COMPLAINTS, BUT WE TEND TO
HAVE A HIGHER VOLUME OF
LICENSEES, TOO. UM I WOULD SAY
IN CALIFORNIA WE DO HAVE, UM, A
BETTER PROCESS FOR HANDLING
UNLICENSED IN TERMS OF WE CAN
ISSUE AN ADMINISTRATIVE CITATION
AND A FINE WHERE MANY STATES ALL
THEY CAN DO IS ISSUE A CEASE AND
DESIST AND UNLICENSED PEOPLE CAN
IGNORE THEM. UM BUT IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE VERY ACTIVE
IN BOTH IN WITHIN THE STATE AND
NATIONALLY. THANK YOU. UH I
MIGHT COME BACK TO A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS, BUT WANNA GO TO
SENATOR BECKER? YEAH. A QUESTION
ABOUT THE, UH, COMPLAINT PORTAL.
UM I MEAN, TALK ABOUT IT IN THE
IN THE DOCUMENT, AND I THINK YOU
REFERRED TO IT IN THE CONNECT.
UM UH, WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
TRANSITION TO CONNECT IN 2020,
THEN THERE WAS SOME ADDITIONAL,
UM UH, YOU KNOW, BACK OFFICE
ADDED TO THE COMPLAINT. PORTAL
HOW DO PEOPLE IS? HOW DO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC? HOW DO PEOPLE
ACCESS THE COMPLAINT PORTAL? AND
IS THAT THAT PROCESS BEEN CLEAR.
WE HAVE A LINK ON OUR WEBSITE
FOR CONSUMERS AND LICENSEES,
ANYONE TO SUBMIT A COMPLAINT. IT
CAN BE SUBMITTED ANONYMOUS. UH,
WE'VE, UH, IT'S WE? WE DON'T
LIKE TO SAY IT'S AN EASY WAY TO
SUBMIT A COMPLAINT. BUT WE HAVE
MADE IT EASIER FOR THEM TO DO
THAT. AND IT'S ALL DONE PURELY
ONLINE WITHOUT, UH, ANY
INTERACTION WITH OUR STAFF, AND
THEN WE'RE TO SLOW DOWN IS IN AN
INTAKE BECAUSE MANY OF THE
COMPLAINTS COME DON'T COME IN
WITH SOME MORE SUPPORTING
DOCUMENTATION, OR THEY DON'T
PERTAIN TO THE JURISDICTION OF
OUR BOARD. AND SO THE INTA
INTAKE PROCESS IS WHERE WE'RE
SLOWING DOWN AND IT'S PASSING ON
TO OUR INVESTIGATION. BUT WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO NOW IS TRY TO
IMPROVE THE COMMUNICATION AT
THAT COMPLAINT WHEN THEY'RE
COMPLETING THE COMPLAINT AT THAT
TIME WHEN THEY'RE SUBMITTING IT.
TO TRY TO REINFORCE WHAT
INFORMATION WE NEED TO DO TO
BEGIN A SUCCESSFUL
INVESTIGATION. IF THAT HELPS.
YEAH YEAH, THAT IS HELPFUL. AND
IF PEOPLE KIND OF GOOGLE THEY
FIND THE BOARD AND THEY FIND
THAT YOU'VE JUST THAT WE FOUND
THAT IT'S ACTUALLY VERY EASIER
TO FIND, UH, OUR BOARD AND OUR
COMPLAINT ONLINE COMPLAINT BY
GOOGLE AND THEN IT USED TO BE,
YES. THANK YOU. AND YOU SAY THEY
CHAIR, ASHBY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. SORRY. I'VE BEEN IN AND
OUT TAKING CARE OF A COUPLE OF
OTHER THINGS, TOO. I JUST HAVE
ONE QUESTION FOR YOU. WHAT IS
THE EXTENT OF LAND SURVEYOR?
UNLICENSED ACTIVITY. IS IT
PREVALENT ENOUGH TO DEDICATE
FULL TIME INVESTIGATIVE STAFF TO
ENFORCE ONE OF THE THREE
PRACTICE ACTS ADMINISTERED BY
THE BOARD AS A BACKGROUND PAPER
SUGGESTS IN INDUSTRY IS WILLING
TO PAY FOR IT. I WOULD SAY THAT,
UM I WOULD SAY THE LANCE IN THE
LANCE SURVEY AND LICENSURE PART
OF OUR OUR MISSION IS PROBABLY
ONE MOST SUSCEPTIBLE TO
UNLICENSED PRACTICE BECAUSE AS I
MENTIONED THE TECHNOLOGY, ANYONE
ANYONE HAS A PHONE WITH GP S¼
THAT IS READING SATELLITES ON A
DAILY BASIS AND USING THOSE
DIRECTIONS AND ASSUMES THAT
LANDS ARE UTILIZING THE EXACT
SAME EQUIPMENT. THEY'RE USING
THE SAME SATELLITES. BUT THEY'RE
USING EQUIP MENT THAT INSTEAD OF
GETTING YOU WITHIN A 10TH OF A
MILE OF WHERE YOU NEED TO BE FOR
AN ADDRESS, THEY'RE GETTING YOU
WITHIN FIVE MILLIMETERS OF WHERE
YOU NEED TO BE. AND THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHEN YOU'RE A
SURVEYOR, AND YOU HAVE A
PROPERTY TO COME OVER WITH THEIR
IPHONE AND SAY, I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THIS IS WHERE MY
PROPERTY CORNER IS. AND THE
LICENSEES ARE NÓ. THAT'S THAT'S
NOT EXACTLY THE WAY IT'S DONE.
THERE'S ALSO TECHNOLOGY THAT
COUNTIES AND CITIES AND LOCAL
PUBLIC AGENCIES ARE USING WITH
ONLINE MAPPING SYSTEMS THAT SHOW
UM TAX ASSESSMENT PARCELS
OVERLAID WITH AERIAL PHOTOGRAPHY
, AND MANY CONSUMERS ASSUMED
THAT THAT INFORMATION IS AS
ACCURATE AS WHAT A SURVEYOR
WOULD DO, AND IT HAS OPENED THE
DOOR FOR, UM ORGANIZE. I
WOULDN'T SAY ORGANIZATIONS FOR
COMPANIES AND INDIVIDUALS TO
OFFER SERVICES TO THE CONSUMERS
IN AN EFFORT TO SIDESTEP PAYING
FOR A SURVEYOR, AND THAT HAS
BEEN VERY PROBLEMATIC FOR BOTH
US AND THE LICENSEES. YEAH, I
THINK THAT'S I THINK THAT THAT
COVERED A LOT OF WHAT I WAS
GONNA ASK. ALSO LET'S OPEN IT UP
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. UH,
FOR ANY COMMENTS, JUST A
REMINDER, TWO MINUTES PER
ORGANIZATION. UM AND WE'RE STILL
HOPING TO GET ONE MORE BOARD IN
BEFORE ABOUT NOON. SO WE'RE
GONNA BE A LITTLE TIGHT ON THAT
TWO MINUTES. UH, GOOD MORNING.
UH, COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND CHAIRS
. UH, MY NAME IS ALAN SARDA. I'M
A LICENSED PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEER. I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS IN
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT COMMONLY
KNOWN AS PE. I'M CHAIR OF THEIR
COMMITTEE THAT FOLLOWS THE BOARD
AND AS SUCH, I'VE ATTENDED 90
PER CENT OF THEIR HEARINGS OVER
THE LAST FOUR YEARS, SO I CAN
PERSONALLY ATTEST TO THE BOARD
AND ITS STAFFS, PROFESSIONALISM,
THEIR COMPETENCY AND THEIR
DEDICATION. SO WHAT I'D LIKE TO
DO IS HèA HAVE MAKE THREE
COMMENTS ON THE SUNSET REPORT.
FIRST AND FOREMOST IS P STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THE RENEWAL OF THE
BOARD OR ALL THE THINGS THAT
THEY DO ENFORCEMENT EXAMS. IT'S
VERY ESSENTIAL TO PROTECTING THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC.
UH, THE OTHER TWO ISSUES ARE IN
THE LICENSING ISSUES IN THE
REPORT. FIRST WOMEN'S CONTINUING
EDUCATION LICENSE ISSUE NUMBER
OR ON PAGE 40. TAKE SUPPORTS
CONTINUING EDUCATION JUST NOT
LEGISLATIVELY MANDATED BOARD
IMPOSED PROGRAMS THAT HAVE FEES,
ASSESSMENTS AND ADDITIONAL TIME
REQUIREMENTS. UH AS A
ENGINEERING WORK FOR THE STATE
FOR NEARLY 30 YEARS. WE HAD
TRAINING PROGRAMS SECOND TO NONE
, AND WE HAD VARIOUS OTHER
CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS AND ARE
ON THE JOB IS CONTINUING
EDUCATION IN ITSELF. UH SO WE
WOULD CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
BOARD OF FINANCE ALTERNATIVE.
THE MANDATORY FEE BASE CONTINUE
IN EDUCATION FOR THE LICENSES
THAT THE BOARD OVERSEES. LAST IS
THE LICENSE ISSUE ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE, THE GEOLOGIST WORK
EXPERIENCE. IT'S ALSO LOCATED ON
PAGE 40. CURRENTLY, GEOLOGISTS
HAVE, UH EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS.
ENGINEERS AND LAND SURVEYORS
DON'T HAVE THAT SAME REQUIREMENT
FOR LICENSURE. SO, UH, IT HAS
IMPACTED SOME GEOLOGISTS IN THE
ABILITY TO APPLY FOR
APPLICATIONS. SO WE'D LIKE TO DO
IS ENCOURAGE THE BOARD TO
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT SUBSTITUTING
WORK EXPERIENCE IN LIEU OF
ACADEMIC FIELD EXPERIENCE. WE
THINK THAT THAT, UM OUR WORK
EXPERIENCES IS COUNTED TOWARD
ENGINEERS. WE'D LIKE TO SEE THE
SAME THING FOR GEOLOGISTS.
GREAT. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. GOOD MORNING CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS TYLER MUNZING ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN COUNCIL OF
ENGINEERING COMPANIES,
CALIFORNIA, UH, REPRESENTING
ABOUT 25,000 OF THE DESIGN
PROFESSIONALS THAT ARE LICENSED
BY THE BOARD. ALSO THIS MORNING,
UH, REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
LAND SERVICE ASSOCIATION, WHICH
REPRESENTS THE OVER 4000 LAND
SURVEYORS, ALSO LICENSED BY THE
BOARD. UM SHORTLY JUST WANTED TO
MENTION THAT WE OBVIOUSLY
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BOARD'S,
UH, SUNSET EXTENSION. UM ONE
AREA, WE WOULD RECOMMEND THE
COMMITTEE TO LOOK INTO FOR
ADDITIONAL ACTION. AS DISCUSSED
THE UM UNLICENSED PRACTICE
ISSUE, ESPECIALLY IN THE AREA OF
AND THE DISCIPLINE OF, UH UH,
LAND SURVEYING. UM AND, UH, WE
OFFERED OUR SUGGESTIONS ON THIS,
UH, BOTH TO THE COMMITTEE AND TO
THE BOARD FROM A èC èC BACK IN
OCTOBER, UM, FROM èC. S¼ L A
FROM SALSA. OH, SORRY. UH, YEAH.
THE LANCER ASSOCIATION. UM IN
FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR, UM AND,
UH UH, BOTH OF YOU RECEIVED THAT
IN WRITING PREVIOUSLY, UH, JUST
WANTED TO SAY WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE BOARDS. UM
ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE.
OBVIOUSLY UM, WORKING WITH THE
BOARD. UH, VERY CLOSELY. UM AND,
UH, VERY PROUD OF THE PEOPLE
THAT WORK AT THE BOARD AND THE
WORK THEY'VE DONE ON THIS AS
WELL AS AS MUCH AS WAS MENTIONED
IN THE REPORT, UM, SPEEDING UP
THE APPLICATION REVIEW PROCESS,
WHICH IS, UM, MOVING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. AND, UH,
FINALLY FOR THE WORK DO FOR BOTH
THE ENGINEERING AND, UH, LAND
SURVEYING INDUSTRIES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. UH, THANK
YOU, CHAIRS AND MEMBERS. MY NAME
IS DON SHINSKY I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STRUCTURAL
ENGINEERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA STRUCTURAL ENGINEERS
IN CALIFORNIA. UH FIRST RECEIVE
A PROFESSIONAL ENGINEER'S
LICENSE AND THEN UNDERGO. UH,
ADDITIONAL TESTING HAVE
ADDITIONAL WORK, EXPERIENCE,
REFERENCES AND SO ON IN ORDER TO
QUALIFY AS A STRUCTURAL ENGINEER
TWO ISSUE POINTS WE WANT TO
RAISE. UH, ONE IS THE TOPIC OF
CONTINUING EDUCATION. UH YOU
KNOW IF STRUGG IF YOU ASK
STRUCTURAL ENGINEERS WHETHER
THEY WANTED IT, YES. MAYBE UM,
WE'LL SEE DEPENDS. UH, BUT POINT
BEING IT'S DISCUSSION THAT NEEDS
TO BE HAD WHILE THE LAWS OF
PHYSICS DON'T CHANGE HOW WE
APPLY THEM IN, UH, ENGINEERING
HAS CHANGED DRAMATICALLY. UH UH
UH WHAT? YOU KNOW WHAT YOUR DAD
LEARNED AS A STRUCTURAL ENGINEER
30 YEARS AGO. THE SAME AS WHAT
YOUR DAUGHTER IS LEARNING AS A
STRUCTURAL ENGINEER NOW, UH SO
IT I IT'S A FAIR EXPECTATION. UH
UH IN DECIDE WHETHER THERE'S A
WAY TO MOVE FORWARD. THE OTHER
TOPIC. I JUST WANT TO FLAG IS,
UH, KIND OF LONGSTANDING ONE FOR
OUR ORGANIZATION. IN 1933. WE
HAD 220 SCHOOL BUILDINGS FAIL IN
THE LONG BEACH EARTHQUAKE IN
1971. WE HAD A COUPLE OF
HOSPITALS COLLAPSED. A FEW MORE
THAT WERE DAMAGED AND MADE AN
OPERATIVE. ON THE HEELS OF BOTH
THOSE STRUCTURAL ENGINEERS, UH,
WERE GIVEN THE ADDED TO THEIR
TITLE AUTHORITY, UH, RESTRICTED
PRACTICE THAT IS ONLY STRUCTURAL
ENGINEERS CAN DESIGN SCHOOLS AND
HOSPITALS. NOW THAT'S A WELCOME
THING. WE THINK IT'S A GOOD
THING. IT ALSO DOESN'T REPRESENT
A VERY COHERENT STRATEGY ON THE
BEHALF OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THEY THESE WERE. I
THINK IT'S SAFE TO SAY.
REFLEXIVE MOVES AND, UH AND I
ASSUME WHEN THERE'S ANOTHER
EARTHQUAKE, THERE'LL BE ANOTHER
SET OF REFLEXIVE MOVES THAT ARE
MADE, THE QUESTION BECOMES, CAN
WE DO A LITTLE BIT BETTER THAN
THAT? AND FOLLOW THE LEAD OF
WHAT ALMOST ALL OTHER PACIFIC
RIM AND WESTERN STATES HAVE DONE
NOW, WHICH IS ADOPT SIGNIFICANT
STRUCTURE, LANGUAGE? THAT
RESERVES THE DESIGN OF COMPLEX
OR HIGH OCCUPANCY, OR IMPORTANT
STRUCTURES TO STRUCTURAL
ENGINEERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS. I'M THE
EXECUTIVE SECRETARY OF
CALIFORNIA AND NEVADA, CIVIL
ENGINEERS AND LAND SURVEYORS.
MANY MISSOURI GANG STAT. WE
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE BOARD AND
ITS EFFORTS WITH THE SUNSET
REVIEW PROCESS. APPRECIATE A LOT
OF THE COMMENTS HERE AND FOCUS
WHEN WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
BOARD FOR SOME TIME NOW, AND IT
PRESENTED OUR POSITION AS LONG
AS IN CONJUNCTION WITH
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS STEEL S¼.
I'M GOING TO BE BRIEF WITH MY
COMMENTS BECAUSE I HAVE SEVERAL
LICENSE EASIER TO BRING FORWARD
AND LET YOU TELL. TELL THEM TELL
THAT TELL YOU ABOUT WHAT THEIR
EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN, BUT I WANT
TO JUST TOUCH ON A COUPLE OF
AREAS AND FOCUSING EXCLUSIVELY
ON UNLICENSED PRACTICE, WHICH,
RIGHT NOW, I WOULD SUBMIT TO YOU
, UH, INCONSISTENT WITH THE
BOARD'S DATA, WHERE THE NUMBER
OF LICENSED LAND SURVEYORS IN
THIS STATE ARE SLOWLY DECLINING
THAT SOME OF THAT HAS TO DO WITH
WHAT LICENSED LAND SURVEYORS ARE
SEEING ARE OCCURRING WITH
UNLICENSED PRACTICE. THIS. OUT
THERE EVERY SINGLE DAY IN MY
OFFICE. I SEE INCIDENTS OF THIS
PROVIDED TO ME BY MANY OF THESE
LICENSES THAT WILL SHARE WITH
YOU, UH, ON ON A DAILY,
SOMETIMES WEEKLY, SOMETIMES
DAILY BASIS, UM, JUST HIT ON TWO
QUICK POINTS THAT WE WANT TO
FOCUS ON ENFORCEMENT AND
SUBSIDIZING THAT ENFORCEMENT
THROUGH THROUGH FEES ENHANCED
FEES BY MEMBERS. AS WELL AS
ENHANCED PENALTIES SIGNIFICANTLY
AND ENHANCE PENALTIES SO THAT WE
PROVIDED DETERRENT EFFECT FOR
MUCH OF THIS BEHAVIOR. UM
SECONDLY, THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT CONTINUING
EDUCATION AND, UH AND THAT
REQUIREMENT WE SUPPORT THIS. WE
ALSO SUPPORT PUBLIC EDUCATION
BECAUSE MANY CONSUMERS OF
SURVEYING SERVICES, WHETHER
PUBLIC AGENCIES DEVELOPERS,
CONTRACTORS OF THE GENERAL
PUBLIC NEED TO KNOW WHAT IT IS
THAT LAND SURVEYORS DO WHY IT'S
SO IMPORTANT AND HOW AND HOW IT
AFFECTS THEIR LIVES, SO THAT WE
HAVE SOME APPRECIATION FOR THE
FACT THAT THESE LICENSES THEIR
TRAINING AND THEIR EXPERTISE
HELPS KEEP THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SAFE. AND SO
THAT'S THAT'S ANOTHER ELEMENT OF
THIS THAT WE WERE, WE WOULD BE
MORE THAN WILLING TO ASSIST THE
BOARD IN WHATEVER CAPACITY THAT
THEY WOULD LIKE TO HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO MINUTES FLIES BY. OKAY
I'M GONNA LEG PERFECT. THANKS.
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS DAVID
RON I'M AN OWNER OF MARTIN RON
AND ASSOCIATES IN DOWNTOWN SAN
FRANCISCO. OUR FIRM HAS WORKED
ON MAJOR DOWNTOWN ICONIC
PROJECTS LIKE SALESFORCE TOWER
CHASE CENTER A T AND T PARK
ANYMORE. I DROVE THIS MORNING
FROM THE HALF MOON BAY COMMUNITY
, WHICH IS MR BERMAN'S DISTRICT
AND MR BECK, BECKER'S DISTRICT.
THIS IS PERSONAL TO ME. I
APPRECIATE YOU GUYS BRINGING UP
THE UNLICENSED PRACTICE AS A
PROFESSIONAL LAND SURVEYOR. THIS
IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST THINGS
THAT WE SEE THREATENING OUR
PROFESSION AND HARMING THE
PUBLIC. THE RECENT CROWN HOME MY
SITE. MY SITE PLAN DOT COM CASE
SHOWS JUST HOW CHALLENGING IT IS
FOR THE BOARD TO EVEN PUNISH AND
EGREGIOUS BAD ACTOR IN THIS
SITUATION. SO AGAIN, I WOULD
LIKE TO JUST THANK THE BOARD
FOR, UH, FOR WORKING ON THAT AND
THEN FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S AND
THE SENATORS FOR UNDERSTANDING
AND RECOGNIZING THIS UNLICENSED
PRACTICE ISSUE. AND, UH, THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
MAKING THE DRIVE MYSTIC ASIDE.
YEAH, EXACTLY. GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US HERE
THIS MORNING. MY NAME IS MATT
STRINGER. I'M THE VICE PRESIDENT
IN CHARGE OF SURVEYS AT A 400
PERSONS, CIVIL ENGINEERING AND
LAND SURVEYING COMPANY.
PRIMARILY SUPPORTS PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. I PERSONALLY OVERSEE
15 LICENSEES, AND I'VE BEEN
LICENSING FOR MORE THAN TWO
DECADES. AND I JUST WANT TO, UH
THEN MY SUPPORT TO WHAT THE
BOARD HAS SAID TODAY AND I WANT
TO SAY I APPRECIATE YOUR
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE ENHANCED
ENFORCEMENT AGAINST UNLICENSED
PRACTICE AND ESPECIALLY THE
THOROUGH ANSWERS WE'VE HAD HERE
TODAY. I THINK THAT IS THE
BIGGEST ISSUE FACING LICENSED
LAND SURVEYORS TODAY. AFTER ALL,
IF WE ACCEPT UNLICENSED
PRACTICE, WE MIGHT AS WELL NOT
HAVE A LICENSE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS JIM DICKEY. I'M
PRINCIPAL WITH A VERY LARGE
SURVEYING COMPANY UP IN SANTA
ROSA, CALIFORNIA WE HAVE ABOUT
40 PEOPLE. WE DO WORK WITH
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. UM
UNLICENSED PRACTICE IS THE
BIGGEST ISSUE THAT WE HAVE GOING
FORWARD AND IT'S UNLICENSED
PRACTICE AFFECTS CONSUMERS. IT
ALSO AFFECTS UM, PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS AND THAT UNLICENSED
PRACTICE CAN LEAD TO ADD
ELEVATIONS. BAD GRADES AND YOU
KNOW, HOPEFULLY IT WILL NOT END
UP WITH, YOU KNOW. FALLING DOWN
INFRASTRUCTURE, BUT IT VERY WELL
COULD IN THE FUTURE. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR THOUGHTS AND
CONCERNS ABOUT THESE ISSUES, AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO BEING ABLE TO
SUPPORT YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. GOOD MORNING, CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I'M JEFF
SUTERA WITH SANDERS, CIVIL
ENGINEERS. WE'RE 125 PERSON FIRM
IN, UH, NORTHERN CALIFORNIA FIVE
OFFICES. I WANT TO ECHO MY, UH,
MY PEERS. WE WANNA CONTINUE TO
WORK TOGETHER. SUPPORT THE BOARD
AND WHAT IT DOES AND A
PARTICULAR ATTENTION TO THE
UNLICENSED PRACTICE THAT'S
ONGOING. UH I MEAN, JUST
YESTERDAY I RECEIVED AN EMAIL
SOLICITATION FOR A COMPANY
OUTSIDE CALIFORNIA THAT DOES.
CONSTRUCTION LAYOUT. UM TO THE
POINT. UM, I THINK PROTECTING UH
, THE PROFESSION, UH, THROUGH
LICENSING IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
OF THE WORK THAT WE DO WITH
INFRASTRUCTURE, SCHOOLS,
HOSPITALS, HIGHWAYS OF THESE
THINGS NEED THE CARE AND
RESPONSIBILITY THAT WE AS
PROFESSIONALS TAKE ON. I'VE
CERTAINLY DEDICATED MY CAREER TO
UPHOLDING THE PROFESSIONALISM.
THAT HAS BEEN PUT FORTH IN THE
BOARD AND IT'S REGULATIONS. AND
WE'RE GOING TO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO SUPPORT THE BOARD AND
YOUR EFFORTS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING. I AM G V AIRS. I
REPRESENT THE ASSOCIATION FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ENGINEERING
GEOLOGIST. THANK YOU. CHAIR
BERMAN AND CHAIR ASHBY AND
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK. APPRECIATE THE WORK OF
THE BOARD, AND WE ARE OFFERING
OUR CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR THE
BOARD. WE APPRECIATE THE HARD
WORK AND COMMITMENT OF COMMITTEE
STAFF. ACKNOWLEDGE THAT HAVING
DONE THIS BEFORE MYSELF. UH IN
THE SUNSET PROCESS AND STRINGENT
WORK OF THE BOARD. AGONIZING
WORK OF THE BOARD AND DOING THIS
AS WELL. UH WE SUBMITTED A
LETTER OF SUPPORT TO THE FROM
OUR FROM OUR ASSOCIATION
PRESIDENT COMMITTEE STAFF. AND
SO WE WILL BE VERY BRIEF HERE.
CALIFORNIA'S GEOLOGICALLY THE
MOST DIVERSE STATE IN THE
NATION, AND GEOLOGISTS PLAY A
IMPORTANT ROLE IN GUARDING THE
PUBLIC INTEREST IN NUMEROUS
AREAS, INCLUDING INFRASTRUCTURE
DESIGN. AND CONSTRUCTION, WATER,
SUSTAINABILITY AND LAND
INTEGRITY. WITHOUT GETTING TOO
FAR INTO THE WEEDS. OR I GUESS
SHALL I SAY INTO THE CREVICES OF
THE ROCK? UH E G STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THE GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES OUTLINE OF THE
BOARD'S STRATEGIC PLAN. AND A G
CONTINUES TO ASSIST THE BOARD'S
GOAL BY HELPING TO PROMOTE THE
IMPORTANCE OF LICENSE SHIRTED
GEOLOGY. AMONG STUDENTS AND
EARLY CAREER PROFESSIONALS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
LOOK FORWARD TO THIS PROCESS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO EVERYONE
WHO TOOK THE TIME TO COME AND
TESTIFY ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS? WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT BOARD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. EVERYBODY APPRECIATE
IT. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GONNA
START THIS NEXT BOARD. THIS IS
THE REVIEW BOARD FOR VOCATIONAL
NURSING AND PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS JOINING US TODAY ARE
I THINK CAROL MOUNTAIN ON THE
BOARD PRESIDENT AND ELAINE
YAMAGUCHI, THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER. ON ZOOM, RIGHT. OKAY.
ARE YOU BOTH ON ZOOM OR JUST I'M
SORRY, SIR. A WEB BACKS. SORRY
WEBEX. YOU'RE RIGHT. I NEED TO
BE CORRECT. THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN MR BERMAN STEPS AWAY. WHAT
ELSE CAN I MESS UP WHILE HE'S
GONE? SENATOR ARCHULETTA. WHAT
ELSE CAN WE DO? ALRIGHT LET'S
GO. ALRIGHT WE APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE VERY MUCH. WE'RE
GOING TO GET STARTED. UM, GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU SO MUCH TO THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR. ASHBY CHAIR
BERMAN AND MEMBERS. THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
THE BOARDS HARD WORK OVER THE
PAST THREE YEARS. I'M DR CAROL
MOUNTAIN. IT'S MY HONOR TO SERVE
AS THE BV, NPT BOARD PRESIDENT
WHEN WE APPEARED BEFORE YOU IN
2021. THE JOINT COMMITTEE WAS
VERY CLEAR WITH US. OUR PROGRAM
APPROVAL PROCESS WAS NOT
ACCEPTABLE. WE TOOK THAT VERY
MUCH TO HEART BEFORE 2022, AN
ORGANIZATION COULD SEND IN A
LETTER OF INTENT THAT ONLY
CONTAIN THE NAME OF THE
ORGANIZATION AND THE GENERAL
AREA IN WHICH THEY PLAN TO OPEN
A SCHOOL. NOW, THANKS TO THE
AUTHORIZATIONS FROM A B 1536 AND
THE SUBSEQUENT REGULATIONS AND
ENTITY MUST BE READY BEFORE
REQUESTING TO OPEN A NEW SCHOOL.
THIS MEANS COMPLETED CURRICULUM
AND POLICIES, ITEMS THAT HAD
REPRESENTED THE LARGEST PART OF
THE PROCESS. AFTER OUR 2021
HEARING, STAFF AND LEGAL COUNSEL
WORKED TO UPEND THE LONGSTANDING
PROCEDURES, CREATE CLEAR,
THOROUGH FORMS AND CRAP, THE
NECESSARY REGULATIONS. WE
REACHED OUT TO STAKEHOLDERS,
EXISTING PROGRAMS AND GROUPS
THAT HAVE EXPRESSED INTEREST IN
STARTING NEW PROGRAMS. A SERIES
OF WOMEN. OURS WAS HELD
EXPLAINING ALL THE FACETS OF THE
NEW PROCEDURES AND FORMS AND THE
PROJECTED TIME FROM FOR THE
WHOLE PROCESS, APPROVAL AND
RECOGNITION OF THE LENGTH OF
TIME SOME HAD BEEN WAITING. WE
OPENED THE FIRST ROUND IN 2022
ONLY TO THOSE WHO HAD BEEN ON
THE WAITING LIST BEFORE JANUARY.
1 2020. THE BOTTOM LINE IS IN
2021 ARE WAITING LIST WAS MORE
THAN 50 TODAY. WE DO NOT HAVE A
WAITING LIST SINCE 2021 23 NEW
VOCATIONAL NURSING PROGRAMS HAVE
OPENED IN 2024. WE ARE ON TRACK
TO SEE 12 NEW PROGRAMS START AT
THIS POINT. I AM HAPPY TO
INTRODUCE OUR EXECUTIVE OFFICER
ELAINE YAMAGUCHI. THANK YOU,
DOCTOR. MOUNTAIN CHAIR, BERMAN.
SURE. ASHBY MEMBERS. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. I
KNOW IT'S GETTING LATE. BUT I
ALSO WANTED TO SAY HOW MUCH WE
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT AND HARD
WORK OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF. AND
I WOULD LIKE TO VERY BRIEFLY,
VERY, VERY BRIEFLY ADDRESSED THE
BOARD'S OVERALL HEALTH IN 2021.
IT WAS PROJECTED THAT WITHOUT
ACTION, THE BOARD WOULD BE
INSOLVENT BY THIS FISCAL YEAR.
BUT TODAY WE HAVE NEARLY NINE
MONTHS FUNDS IN RESERVE. UM
MAYBE 1536 AUTHORIZES CHARGE THE
SCHOOLS AND PROGRAMS FOR THE
WORK ON APPROVALS FOR BOTH NEW
AND CONTINUING PROGRAMS. AND
THIS WAS THE FIRST TIME THAT
WE'VE BEEN SO AUTHORIZED. WE
DEFINITELY APPRECIATED THE
SUPPORT OF THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR. AND WHILE THIS WAS
A VERY MINOR, UH, MODEST
INCREASE TO OUR BOTTOM LINE, IT
WAS A VERY, VERY IMPORTANT
STARTING POINT. SO IN THE
MEANTIME, WE INCREASED OUR OTHER
FEES TO THEIR STATUTORY CEILINGS
TO ENSURE THE BOARD
SURVIVABILITY. AND OUR NEXT STEP
WILL BE TO ENGAGE IN A STUDY OF
THE BOARD'S OVERALL FISCAL
OPERATIONS AND REVENUE STREAMS
AND DEVELOP A PERMANENT
STRUCTURE WHICH WOULD BE
SUSTAINABLE AND ENABLE US TO
RIGHT SIZE ALL OF OUR FEES, AND
THE BOARD IS VERY COMMITTED TO
HAVING THIS DISCUSSION. WE
CONTINUE TO LOOK FOR
EFFICIENCIES AND COST SAVINGS.
RIGHT NOW. WE'RE IN THE PROCESS
OF RENEWING OUR LEASE, AND WE'LL
BE ANALYZING THE BEST UNIVERSITY
BASE AND RESOURCES HOPE TO MAKE
SOME COST SAVINGS THERE. THE
BOARD ITSELF IS CLOSE TO OUR
FULL STRENGTH. WE DO STILL NEED
ONE L V N MEMBER. OUR MEETINGS
HAVE BEEN EFFICIENT AND
SUCCESSFUL. I THANK AND COMMEND
OUR BOARD MEMBERS FOR THEIR
ENGAGEMENT. ENTHUSIASM I'M
ESPECIALLY GRATEFUL TO DR
MOUNTAIN OR VICE PRESIDENT, MR
JOHN DEERE KING FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP IS OUR EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE FOR THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS, AND OF COURSE, I THINK
OUR LEADERSHIP TEAM AND STAFF OR
THEIR DEDICATION, THEIR HARD
WORK AND THEIR SENSE OF HUMOR,
AND WE WELCOME YOUR QUESTIONS.
SENSE OF HUMOR IS IMPORTANT TO
GO ALONG WITH HARD WORK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. UH FOR YOUR
REMARKS, WANT TO OPEN UP THE
COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? UH SENATOR ARCHULETTA.
THANK YOU. AND THANK YOU FOR THE
WORK YOU DO. AND THE BOARD? UH
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT YOU'VE
HAD IN THE PAST THAT KEEPS
COMING UP OVER AND OVER IS THE
NUMBER OF NURSES AND
PRACTITIONERS TECHNICIANS THAT
ARE TRYING TO ENTER THE FIELD.
AND UH, AND IN THE BOTTOM NECK,
AND I GUESS THE LICENSING AND
EXPEDITING THOSE LICENSES SO
THEY CAN GET TO WORK. THE OTHER
THING IS THE FACT THAT YOU
MENTIONED SCHOOLS AND THEIR
ACCREDITATION AND WHERE THERE'S
A PATHWAY FROM THE SCHOOL TO
CONTINUING THE EDUCATION THAT'S
NEEDED. AND THE HOURS THAT ARE
NEEDED, AND THEN IN TURN FINDING
THE EMPLOYMENT WOULD YOU ADDRESS
SOME OF THOSE ISSUES? WOW WHERE
WOULD I DOCTOR MOUNTAIN? WOULD
YOU LIKE TO START OR SHOULD I?
I'LL START AND THEN I'LL TURN IT
BACK OVER TO YOU. UM, I WANTED
TO ADDRESS REALLY QUICKLY. THE
IDEA THAT THERE'S A BOTTLENECK
AND WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
HELPING STUDENTS GET THE
EDUCATION THEY NEED. CERTAINLY,
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD WITH
HELPING SCHOOLS TO OPEN. WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE SCHOOLS
ARE PROVIDING ADEQUATE EDUCATION
AND CREATING SAFE PRACTITIONERS.
ANOTHER ISSUE THAT WE HAVE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT HAS
BEEN TALKED ABOUT A LOT IS
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS. YOU CAN'T
EXPECT A NURSE TO GO TO WORK. IF
THEY'VE NEVER TOUCHED THE
PATIENT. THERE WAS A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS DURING THE
PANDEMIC WHEN CERTAIN STUDENTS
WEREN'T ABLE TO GO INTO THE
CLINICAL AREA. AH, FOR US AT THE
BOARD. PATIENT SAFETY. CONSUMER
SAFETY IS PARAMOUNT AND MAKING
SURE THAT EDUCATION ALIGNS TO
CREATE SAFE PRACTITIONERS TO
PROVIDE THE CARE IS OUR ONE OF
OUR MOST IMPORTANT DUTIES THAT
WE DO MISS YAMAGUCHI OVER TO
YOU. THANK YOU. I DON'T KNOW
THAT THERE REALLY IS, UM, A
BOTTLENECK PER SE. I THINK, UM,
IN TERMS OF THE VAST MAJORITY OF
FOLKS WHO COME AFTER SCHOOL TO
BECOME LICENSED, AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PROBABLY EIGHT OR
9000 A YEAR. THOSE ARE PROCESSED
VERY, VERY QUICKLY. UM, ABOUT A
WEEK, PROBABLY. UM, THERE ARE,
OF COURSE, UH, INDIVIDUALS WHOSE
APPLICATION PROCESSES AREN'T
NEARLY SO SIMPLE. WE DO HAVE
COURSE HAVE, UM, A COUPLE OF
EQUIVALENCY OR PROGRAMS THAT, UM
BASICALLY AROUND THE TRADITIONAL
PATH. THOSE DO TAKE A LONG TIME
AND ABSOLUTELY AND THEY NEED TO
BECAUSE IT SHOULDN'T BE EASY TO
BECOME A NURSE OR CYTOTEC. IT
HAS TO BE VERY, VERY CAREFULLY
MONITORED. UM BEFORE WE WILL LET
SOMEBODY TAKE THE TEST TO BECOME
A PRACTITIONER. UM SENATOR, I'M
NOT SURE IF WE ANSWER ALL THE
POINTS YOU RAISED. WELL, MY,
YES, YOU HAVE, AND MY CONCERN IS
IN THE COMMUNITIES IN L. A
COUNTY THAT THAT I REPRESENT, UH
, YOU KNOW, THERE'S ALWAYS THE
NEED FOR THE NURSES AND CLINICS
AND SO ON, AND I KEEP HEARING
THAT TRYING TO GET THEIR LICENSE
AND GETTING THAT ON THE JOB
TRAINING THAT THEY'VE GOT TO
HAVE THE HOSPITAL AND CLINICS
AND EVERYTHING ELSE AND IT'S
HARD TO GET IN THERE SOMETIMES,
AND THEN TO FIND THE EMPLOYMENT
THEREAFTER. I JUST WANTED
POINTED OUT THAT YOU KNOW, I'M
GLAD YOU'RE AWARE AND YOU'RE
WORKING ON IT, AND WE'RE TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE CURRICULUM
IS TIGHT, AND IT'S AS YOU SAID,
PATIENT ORIENTED PATIENT SAFETY
AND THE PROFESSIONAL THAT'S
NEEDED IN THE INDUSTRY THAT
YOU'VE ALWAYS BEEN THERE FOR. I
JUST WANTED TO ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES. AND I THANK YOU FOR THE
WORK YOU DO. SO BIG SHOUT OUT
FOR YOU AS WELL. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. BUT YOU YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT. THERE IS AND
ALWAYS PROBABLY WILL BE. UM, A
TIGHT AMOUNT OF RESOURCES IN
TERMS OF CLINICAL SITE
PLACEMENTS FOR NURSING STUDENTS
AND BLUNTLY, UM ESPECIALLY IN
AREAS LIKE L. A COUNTY. UM MOST
OF PROGRAM. MOST OF CLINICAL
SITES WOULD RATHER HAVE AN RN
STUDENT AND AN L V N STUDENT OR
SITE TEXT YOU SO I'M SORRY. SORT
OF STATE OF AFFAIRS. GOOD I
THINK I THINK THAT IS. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU, MR CHAIR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ASHBY. YEAH, THANK
YOU. THIS IS MORE OF A
STATEMENT, BUT ONE THAT I FEEL I
NEED TO MAKE ON THE RECORD SO
THAT YOU KNOW, SINCE I'M A NEW
NEW CHAIR TO THE POSITION THAT I
DO APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT SCHOOLS AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO PARTNERING WITH YOU GUYS. AND
THE OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE
THAT QUALIFIED STUDENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO QUALITY, AFFORDABLE
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS THE
NECESSARY CLINICAL TRAINING TO
PROMOTE PATIENT SAFETY. SO THANK
YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY JUST TO LET YOU KNOW
ON THE RECORD THAT I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THAT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CHAIR ASHBY REGARDING ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR IN THE BACKGROUND
PAPER THE NEW FEDERAL TITLE FOR
CHANGES IF THE MINIMUM NUMBER OF
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM HOURS WERE
DELETED, WHAT WOULD THE APPROVAL
PROCESS? LOOK AT INSTEAD? OH
THAT IS THE VERY QUESTION, SIR.
UM RIGHT NOW WE DON'T KNOW AND
ARE WAITING ON SOME GUIDELINES
SOME DIRECTION FROM THAT BETTER
DEPARTMENT OF ED. UM ON THE
AMONG OTHER THINGS ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE AND TIME
LINE. BUT IF WE WERE TO, FOR
EXAMPLE, JUST STRIKE THE NUMBER
OF REQUIRED HOURS IN OUR
STATUTES AND OUR RAGS, UM WHAT
WE WOULD THEN BE FACED WITH IS
US SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF WE'LL
REVIEW ANALYSIS AND I THINK, UM
REVISITING. CURRICULUM REFORMS
CURRICULUM REQUIREMENTS BECAUSE
SHORT OF REQUIRING HOURS. WE
VERY VERY WE'RE WORRIED ABOUT
JUST CUTTING THAT NUMBER. I MEAN
, IT NEEDS TO WE WOULD NEED TO
INSTALL SOME VERY RIGOROUS
CRITERIA. OR WHAT THE LESSON
PLANS WOULD INCLUDE WHAT THE
CLINICAL REQUIREMENTS WOULD
INCLUDE HOW THEY WOULD BE
CORRELATED. UM, WITHOUT CITING A
NUMBER. DR MOUNTAIN DID YOU WANT
TO ADD TO THAT? I JUST THINK
THAT THE IMPORTANCE OF MAKING
SURE THAT ESPECIALLY VOCATIONAL
NURSES AND PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS, THEIR PROGRAMS GO
BY VERY QUICKLY. MOST OF THEM
ARE 18 MONTHS OR LESS. AND SO
THAT DELINEATING THOSE HOURS HAS
BEEN REALLY HELPFUL IN
MAINTAINING CURRICULUM RIGOR,
WHICH IS IMPORTANT WHEN YOU HAVE
PEOPLE THAT ARE INTERFACING SO
CLOSELY AND INTIMATELY WITH THE
PUBLIC. AND SO I WOULD HATE TO
SEE THE HOURS JUST DISINTEGRATE.
I KNOW THERE'S BEEN DISCUSSION
ABOUT REVISING THOSE HOURS OR
REVISITING THE WAY THE
CURRICULUM IS DELINEATED, WHICH
MIGHT BE MORE ADVANTAGEOUS TO
MAINTAINING PUBLIC SAFETY. THANK
YOU BOTH. AND DEFINITELY KEEP US
IN THE LOOP IS AS SOME OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS CONTINUE. UM WITH
THAT, LET'S OPEN IT UP TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. UH FOR
ANYBODY WHO HAS ANY QUESTIONS
ARE ACTUALLY MADE ANY COMMENTS
TO MAKE JUST REMINDED TWO
MINUTES PER FOR ORGANIZATION
SLASH PERSON. FEEL FREE TO JUST
SAY ME TO SOMEBODY COVERED WHAT
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT. MR CHAIR
VICE CHAIR. SENATOR. UH KOBE
PRESIDED WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS, UM, I WOULD AGAIN
LIKE TO HURRICANE BACK TO YOUR
COURT REPORTING COMMENT OF THIS
WOULD BE A GREAT PATHWAY. SCITEX
L V N S WOULD BE AN AWESOME
PATHWAY TO WORK WITH CSB A AND
THE COUNT, UH, AND THE SCHOOL
COUNSELORS ASSOCIATION. TO GET
MORE PEOPLE COMING INTO THE
PROGRAMS. POST COVID. UH I COULD
SAY OUR UNION HAS LOST OVER 1000
MEMBERS JUST AS A MATTER OF
ATTRITION THROUGH RETIREMENT.
PEOPLE DO NOT WANT TO DID NOT
WANT TO WORK, UH, IN IN THE
ENVIRONMENT. UH HUH. WE
REPRESENT 5300 OF THE LICENSES.
UH THERE'S APPROXIMATELY 8600
LICENSES IN THE STATE. FROM A
DECADE AGO, THERE WAS OVER
12,000. A SCITEX SO I'M JUST
TRYING TO ILLUSTRATE THE POINT
THAT THERE'S NOT ENOUGH PEOPLE
COMING INTO THIS PROGRAM AND YET
LOOKS LIKE PROPER ONE IS GOING
TO PASS. WE'RE GOING TO BUILD
CAPACITY IN THE MENTAL HEALTH
ARENA. YET THERE'S NOT A LOT
BEING DONE TO BUILD THE CAPACITY
TO TREAT WE'RE BUILDING THE
PROGRAMS, BUT NOT THE TREATMENT
ITSELF. SO WE WANTED TO REALLY
HIGHLIGHT AND ILLUSTRATE THAT
POINT AND THEN TO THE ISSUE. UH,
OF FEES. THE BOARD HAS THE
ABILITY TO RAISE FEES ON
LICENSES. THEY HAVE TO COME TO
THE LEGISLATURE IN ORDER TO
RAISE OR CREATE AND THEN THEY
CREATED AND THEN RAISE FEES ON
THE SCHOOLS. UM WHEN THE BOARD
MADE THE DECISION TO RAISE FEES
ON THE LICENSES. THEY DID IT
WITHOUT A SINGLE LICENSEE MEMBER
OF THE BOARD PRESENT. SO THERE'S
FOUR LICENSE REPRESENTATIVES ON
THE BOARD TO CITE TEXT TO
OBEDIENCE. NOT ONE OF THEM WAS
PRESENT WHEN THAT VOTE WAS
TAKEN, SO I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
THAT VERY CLEAR. THAT RAISED THE
LED LICENSE RENEWAL FEES FROM 2
22 300. I I'M TRYING TO IMPRESS
THE POINT THAT, UM WE WOULD LIKE
FOR THE SCHOOLS TO PAY THEIR
FAIR SHARE, BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
IT'S YOU KNOW. ON THE BACKS. THE
BURDEN IS ON THE BACKS OF THE
LICENSES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ON THAT NOTE EXACTLY BACK
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY SCHOOLS. UM I
WASN'T REALLY GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THE FEES, BUT IT WAS
INTERESTING TO HEAR THE BOARD
CHAIR AND STAFF SAY THAT THEY
ARE IN A GOOD FINANCIAL
SITUATION. I THINK I HEARD NINE
MONTHS OF FISCAL RESERVE. OUR
FEES WERE SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASED. WE HAD NEW FIELDS IN
THE LAST SUNSET. UM OR MAYBE IN
THE 2018. BUT ANYWAY, THERE ARE
NEW FEES. THE FEES THAT I SAW IN
THE REPORT ARE SUBSTANTIAL AND
CERTAINLY ALARMING TO US. PUT
THAT ASIDE. THOSE FEES AND THE
OTHER ISSUES REALLY WON'T MATTER
IF WE DON'T FIX THE TITLE FOR
ISSUE PROBLEM THAT WE AS
CALIFORNIA DID NOT CREATE. THE
FEDS HAVE NOW YOU KNOW, PLACED
IN OUR LAPS THIS TITLE FOR ISSUE
THAT 133 133 OF THE 150 SOME ODD
. THE N PROGRAMS WILL BE TITLED
FOR INELIGIBLE JULY 1ST 2024.
THAT MEANS ALL OF THE STUDENTS
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT THAT YOU
WANT TO GET INTO THIS
PROFESSION. WILL NOT HAVE THE
FINANCIAL TOOLS TO ATTEND OUR
SCHOOLS. THAT IS OBVIOUSLY AGAIN
NOT A PROBLEM THAT WE CREATED.
BUT THE WAY THAT THE TITLE FOR
LAW IS WRITTEN, IT LINKS TO YOUR
HOME STATE'S MINIMUM
REQUIREMENTS. CALIFORNIA IS ON
THE HOOK FOR THOSE MINIMUM
REQUIREMENTS. 133 SCHOOLS ARE
ABOVE THE MINIMUM HOURS. THEY'VE
ALL BEEN APPROVED BY THE BOARD.
THEY'RE ALL OPERATING IN THE
STATE BECAUSE WE WERE APPROVED
AT THOSE NUMBERS. IT'S
BENEFICIAL TO THE STUDENTS ARE
TEST RATES ARE BETTER. THERE'S
REASONS WE DO THAT WITH
EMPLOYERS. UM SO WE NEED TO FIND
A SOLUTION TO THAT ISSUE AGAIN.
UNFORTUNATELY WITHIN THE NEXT
FOUR MONTHS AND, UM, MISS
YAMAGUCHI AT HER LAST BOARD
MEETING SAID, EVEN IF THEY
DROPPED EVERYTHING THEY DO AND
TRIED TO APPROVE THE 103
PROGRAMS BEFORE JULY, 1ST THEY
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO GET THERE.
SO FORCING SCHOOLS OR TELLING
SCHOOLS TO GO DOWN TO THE 1530
IS NOT A VIABLE SOLUTION. BUT BY
JULY 1ST, SO WE OBVIOUSLY LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE A.
THE BOARD ALL OF YOU TO FIND A
SOLUTION BEFORE JULY 1ST. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING, KAREN CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS. UM KIRK BLACKBURN HERE
ON BEHALF OF CONCORD CAREER
COLLEGES, ALSO TO BRIEFLY TOUCH
UPON THE TITLE FOUR ISSUE. I
JUST WANTED TO STRESS THAT YOU
KNOW, ONCE AGAIN CONQUERED, AS
HAS EDUCATES NEARLY 1000
STUDENTS PER YEAR WITHOUT A
STATUTORY CHANGE OR SOME TYPE OF
FIXED BEFORE JULY 1ST ALL THESE
STUDENTS AND WILL BE INELIGIBLE
FOR FEDERAL FUNDING. SO I JUST
WANTED TO STRESS THAT COMMITTEE
MIRRORS HOW CRITICAL THIS ISSUE
IS AND ALSO WANT TO THANK
EXECUTIVE OFFICER I'M A GUCCI
AND THE BBM PT FOR THE PROPER
ATTENTION TO IT. WITHOUT THE
LEGISLATURE'S TIMELY HELP, UM
SCHOOL STUDENTS AND ULTIMATELY
THE HEALTH OF THE PUBLIC WILL BE
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED. SO THANKS
FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK
IDENTIFYING A TIMELY SOLUTION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WANT TO GIVE? UM UM EXECUTIVE
OFFICER YAMAGUCHI OR PRESIDENT
MOUNTAIN AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
SOME CLOSING COMMENTS IF THEY
WANT BUT NOT YOUR GOOD.
EVERYONE'S GOOD. UM, IT WOULD BE
IT WOULD BE REDUNDANT AT BEST, I
THINK. YOU KNOW THE POINTS ARE
THE POINTS RAISED BY, UM ARE OUR
FRIENDS AND THE COMMUNITY.
ABSOLUTELY WELL PUT ABSOLUTELY.
THINGS THAT WE SLEEP. WE GO TO
SLEEP THINKING ABOUT WHERE WE
WILL BE WORKING AT THE HARDEST
AS I DO CAN EXCUSE ME, AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO, OF COURSE, OUR
HELP FROM THE LEGISLATURE AND
YOU'RE FINE COMMUNITY STAFF OR
COMMUNITY OR BOARD AND ALSO NOT
TO NOT TO LET LEAVE OUT OUR
COLLEAGUES AT OTHER BOARDS,
INDEED, BECAUSE THIS, UH,
REGULATION PACKAGE WILL AFFECT A
NUMBER OF THEM, SO I DO BELIEVE
THAT WILL BE WORKING TOGETHER
WITH A NUMBER OF THE OTHER
IMPACTED BOARDS AND THE
DEPARTMENT AS A WHOLE MOUNTAIN.
ANYTHING ELSE, BUT I ABSOLUTELY
ECHO WHAT YOU JUST SAID. AND
THAT IS OUR GOAL TO, UM, SUPPORT
THE SCHOOLS, ALWAYS KEEPING
PATIENT SAFETY IN MIND. UM AND I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU, ELAINE,
FOR ALL HER HARD WORK, TOO, AND
MAKING ALL OF THIS HAPPENED AND
REALLY LISTENING TO THE PUBLIC.
AND TO THE MEMBERS OF THE BOARD
WHEN WE HAVE CONCERNS THANK YOU.
YEAH. THANK YOU. BOTH UM, WITH
THAT WILL WRAP UP THE BOARD OF
VOCATIONAL NURSING IN
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS SEGMENT
OF THE SUNSET REVIEW PROCESS.
THAT'S ALSO THE LAST, UH, BOARD
OR ENTITY TO DISCUSS, SO I JUST
WANT TO REALLY THINK OUR STAFF
ON BEHALF OF TRASH BE, UH AND
MYSELF. THE SENATE STAFF, THE
ASSEMBLY STAFF. WHO PUT IN LONG,
LONG HOURS, UH, TO UNDERSTAND
THE NUANCES OF ALL THESE
IMPORTANT CONCERNS THAT ARE
RAISED AND ISSUES THAT NEED TO
BE ADDRESSED. AND WITH THAT
TODAY'S SUNSET REVIEW HEARING IS
ADJOURNED.